there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody tom's like looking over
there okay
oh yeah she says she's sleeping in the
chair yeah did something happen with the
camera why is this camera like oh yeah
it needs to go a little bit more where
your way yeah this like that it's not
the whole camera it's just the just the
lens pookie must be uh coming in here
and [ __ ] around no it looking rotate
it what are you talking about rotate it
yeah it's fine okay that's what that i
always use uh i always use box shoulder
as a guide
so that's how i do it but like i said i
haven't touched it so
uh so there we go we already got a super
chat thank you very much jeffy iron for
the super chat um i also wanted to give
a shout out to trey who sent us a paypal
donation today who actually he said he
used to be on patreon but he's been
having trouble with it so he's been
sending me paypal donations instead uh
which is very very nice and anyone else
that wants to do that uh to join patreon
or give me a paypal donation uh would be
much appreciated uh 13 zack says love
the hairdo jen thank you very much i was
just saying like before the thing
because we i recorded a couple of videos
oh bless you sweetie
she's amazing uh because we recorded a
couple videos earlier today and i was
wearing my red wig and then i was like
when i was doing the show i'm like i was
gonna put it back on i was like man my
head kind of hurts i don't really want
to go hey i'm going to turn this i'm
going to turn a fan off
you're that's just you man how you can
do it because it's cold in here i'm not
it's [ __ ] hot it's cold in here
i mean i'm the one that's in here all
day it's cold in here i'm telling you is
that and that's the way i like it you
know what i mean
i just run harder than you do
it's like you know i'm aging in dog
years
i guess
maybe that's what it is oh i'm [ __ ]
constantly hot yeah see i'm not i mean i
i am if it's like it's now i i will say
like i said in the bedroom it's kind of
hot in there like not hot hot but it's
kind of like a little bit stuffy in
there in here it's like always cold
which like i said that's why i usually
wear like little jackets and stuff
uh kanavatsan says never heard of these
dudes who are they some pt barman bailey
fanboys no uh these guys are actually
now the thing about whatever well
sellers technically they're it's weird
because they're always associated with
grave robbing but as far as i know they
never actually robbed any graves they
just went straight to the middle man
it's like let's just make some bodies
you know what i mean because they were
serial killers they were body sellers
yeah body sellers back in the old days
now the thing about it i kind of feel
like because tom's like didn't we do a
show about them already i don't think we
did a whole dedicated show to them i
think we brought them up or we talked
about them a little bit okay a long time
ago when we did a show about uh
buried alive buried live we did a show
called buried alive okay and i was kind
of talking because i had read a book
about it and i was like really into
um you know like the people that they
put like cages and all the all the [ __ ]
that like you know bells and stuff like
that so keep people from getting buried
alive like all the cool like gadgets
they came up with so i think that we
brought them up on that show now that
i'm thinking because we've done a couple
shows about like creepy scotland but i
think that we did one on gray gray
fire's kirk yard which was that was like
a paranormal poltergeist kind of [ __ ]
and then we did one about
like hauntings like overton bridge like
where the dogs jump off and stuff like
that we've done like that but i don't
think we've done like a whole birken
hair show okay but we have brought them
up before on like other shows so that's
kind of where all right i want to thank
you guys for the [ __ ] super chat so
early on we've uh we haven't really been
[ __ ] pushing super chats too much we
know that [ __ ] it's a hard time for
everybody you know it's like an
economy's not doing too good and [ __ ]
just getting hit with so many [ __ ]
expenses and [ __ ]
the other day i was gonna go out and get
a damn
lawn mower but i i
i had a change of plans
i could probably make an online purchase
a little bit better i'm gonna get one of
those [ __ ]
so i got nearly an acre here you know
and spending a hundred two hundred
dollars a month to have this place
[ __ ] mode
i'm gonna buy my own [ __ ] ride on
lawnmower see
thomas be out there on the loan yeah
because i could
find out that you can you can get you
can get one on a 36 month payment plan
so it would be less
you know what i mean
i mean
and then after a couple years
like you know what i mean i wouldn't
have to pay anything
the idea what the thing is now it's got
to figure out which one to get i think
i'm going to get the that [ __ ]
husqvarna
v twin
750
one it's got like uh that briggs and
stratton v twin in there that's [ __ ]
pretty good engine
and
um be able to do this whole they've got
headlights on it so i can mow this place
at [ __ ] night so i don't have to be
out there in the damn sun
that's probably a good idea yeah like as
long as it's not super late so people
will be back but it's like probably
about 100 bucks a month just to pay for
that maybe not probably it'd be more
no it wouldn't probably 100 something
bucks so it'd be
cheaper than hiring the lawn crew
yeah you know there's a little down
payment on it you know yeah they put 3
400 down on it but you know what's you
know y'all you all will pay for it
you're so cheeky yeah yeah you're so
shameless i was gonna ask you if you
were gonna hang any truck nuts on the
thing yeah i might have [ __ ] dragging
in the ground
rubbing testicles on the back of that
[ __ ] they're calling truck nuts i have
them on a [ __ ] rope
bouncing off the damn lawn
yeah
that's cold yeah i'll drink and mow at
the same time and everything
uh don't drink and mow
everybody else does it that's true
everybody else does it drinking mo
you're riding on it well i mean it's not
going fast the thing about it was that
at our old house one the yard was much
smaller and two
um we didn't own the house we rented it
so we just paid extra on the rent like
for there's the homeowners like to pay
for the service to come but now that
like we own the house and the yard is
like big massive yeah um
and we'll probably get in trouble again
because we do have an hoa although
they're not as strict as they were at
the old place but you do get in trouble
if you don't know your lawn hasn't been
really regularly watered probably in
years and now that i got that [ __ ]
water
that water that watery system [ __ ]
rocking and rolling and all of the snuff
because it kept breaking because they
hadn't done anything with it forever and
they just let the damn yard die
now that it's getting water those damn
seed sprout things are [ __ ] coming up
like crazy i'm just getting the grass
getting thicker and thicker and thicker
so
in the summertime it's going to have to
be mowed every
every week
probably probably every week
yeah i mean well they at our old house
they used to come every week yeah it's
gonna be like and at least do the grass
and then i think like every few weeks
they would try to started adding it up
man and [ __ ] that's
a hundred dollars a week
that's a lot yeah
i can't go out there and keep them
things beating down with a [ __ ]
electric weed whacker
and i'm definitely not gonna have a
[ __ ] push mower this is nearly an
acre and it's not all flat it's got
[ __ ] it's all these ravines and
hillary yeah yeah so yeah this is a big
lot it's like
it's like i think it's three quarters of
an acre a little bit more than that so
it's yeah it's really big i guess
something decent for maybe about 25 to
20 2500.
so that's not that bad i just put it on
a payment plan yeah get it on that
payment plan that's what he was doing
yesterday he was like going out there
and then he was like he was going to go
look at mowers and then he was just kind
of like well wait a minute maybe i
should just like
order the [ __ ]
online
like buying a car almost and just
[ __ ]
getting that [ __ ] financed
so i don't have to [ __ ] you know what
i mean
struggle out there with a [ __ ] 300
lawnmower
you know yeah because we're going to be
here for a while so i might as well have
the damn equipment that's true i thought
i would just get like a 300 one and then
use that to kind of keep it under
control and then hire the crew to come
in here but it just doesn't make any
[ __ ] economic sense the way to do it
is to buy the equipment and finance it
and i just got to do it
but you know man's work is never done
nobody's work has ever done no
some of them right i didn't either so
then ride on mowers you could put a
[ __ ] roof on it like an accessory you
know what i mean so you have some cover
probably wouldn't work but i mean
because that's the thing if i yeah if i
were you as long as it's not like super
late like especially during the summer
times you probably want to do it at
night yeah just like in headlines yeah i
mean as long as it's not past what is it
10 p.m yeah i think that's when you get
a sunday night just do it at nine yeah
something like that because during the
day um you're gonna have a heat stroke
yeah you're gonna have a bad time you
see i don't have to do it all at night i
could do the front and then the back the
next day yeah that's true i'm telling
you to do it all at once
camp guy said i got a honda push mower
my old man bought before he died and
that was 13 14 years ago it's still
running like a champ yeah
and he said i always had trouble with
cheap riding mowers yeah vibrations and
uneven ground can shake the belts off
exactly that's why i don't want that
single cylinder i want the v-twin that
runs a lot smoother that brings the
stratton engine in that husqvarna and
it's got like a three-year warranty on
it and everybody says that's a good one
but they want more i think it's about 27
2800
but that's probably the way to go
yeah i mean you don't want it to like be
breaking all the time and have to pay to
fix it and [ __ ] like that there's also
that yeah so you know i'll take good
i'll take care of it keep it in the
garage
yeah let's make room in there in the
garage next to the motorcycles
there's room in there yeah i gotta
rearrange some [ __ ] but i also have to
have the hookups set up for the
generators i got two generators in there
they'll run this whole house because
hurricanes yeah
although it's not the worst part of
hurricane season yet that usually
doesn't
usually if it's going to be bad it'll be
september yeah
is when because then all the heat
has soaked into the ocean you know what
i mean yeah cause it's been beaten down
and it'll
pop out but we'll see hopefully we don't
have any bad ones this has this house
actually has a lot of like hurricane
yeah uh safety because it's not that old
yeah it's one of the newer ones the
house the front door opens out like on a
trailer it's [ __ ] ridiculous man
that's that's part of the new standards
i don't know why that is well it's
probably it's probably like a little bit
safer so it doesn't blow in you can also
and also the whole house is uh cinder
block yeah it's not like because a lot
of two-story houses especially in
florida are some some of them are cinder
block on the ground floor but then the
second floor is wood
yeah it's just wood and drywall but this
one is cinder block all the way up
there's no glass in the front doors
either yeah yeah which like i said
probably a lot safer that's you know at
our old place every door was glass
yeah and most of the walls were glass
and we had like some kind of like storms
hit that really kind of made me worried
i mean we were sleeping in a damn closet
yeah that one hurricane that came
through we all went and sleep in the
walk-in closet yeah we pit we picked up
the kitties and like ran in there like
clothes cats what the [ __ ] is going on
they knew something was wrong yeah they
were freaking out yeah so we had to like
sleep on the floor but i was just i was
just kind of like i don't want that
[ __ ] because the our bedroom at the
old house it had like the big sliding
glass doors like right there i was like
i don't want that [ __ ] blowing in we'll
[ __ ] die yeah and there was no power
yeah it sucked yeah hottest [ __ ] in
there it was yeah
man that was terrible pouring down rain
and [ __ ] 100 mile an hour winds and
it's still [ __ ] 90 degrees
95 degrees in the house and it sucked
and it's like i couldn't sleep it was
like so loud and i was just kind of like
worried i was worried about pookie i was
worried about like the roof blowing off
i was just kind of like you know i had
[ __ ] whole bags of ice and [ __ ]
[ __ ] big ol [ __ ] coolers and
[ __ ] garbage cans and you know clean
garbage cans inside the house [ __ ]
filled with [ __ ] ice and food because
you have to take everything out of the
refrigerators
all the [ __ ] yeah we have big ice
blocks like in these old like litter box
containers and [ __ ] like head clean all
the bathtubs plug them all up [ __ ]
fill up all the bathtubs so you have
water just in case so you have fresh
water inside all the bathtubs because uh
you may even need that water to flush
the toilet pouring it down the back if
they lose power lose water
yeah or the pump stations lose power
[ __ ] i haven't had that happen like as
long as i've lived in florida the worst
i had it was i think in 2004
and that was when there were like four
hurricanes and or tropical storms that
hit like within a six week period like
in this was when i lived in daytona
thankfully i didn't have too much damage
to the house because my house was old it
was from 1958 and it was all cinderblock
um
so i didn't have too much damage like it
blew some [ __ ] off my roof and it blew
all my fence down like from the back uh
backyard so i had to like build that
back up
but the power was out for eight days
and the street flooded and the street
got all nasty and like they wouldn't let
you go down the street like it was
blocked off because like some of the
power lines like went down in the water
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so we
had to so not only was the power out for
i think it was eight days maybe nine
days um you also had to boil water for
like a little while afterward because it
was all like contaminated so that wasn't
that wasn't a fun time i ate a lot of
granola bars
during that time period like i was
prepared and stuff but it was still kind
of like yeah it was kind of a nightmare
[ __ ] khan says that's another shirt
mowing with cougar car
yeah yeah a matter of fact i just put a
little cartoon of tom with this little
drink look at pineapples working on a
new batch of shirts i got
one screen done
it's of the omega man screen it looks
good it looks real good should i show it
to him
uh if you want to all right and then i
refreshing all the other screens and i'm
gonna have uh [ __ ] ocp
uh it's not
you uh it's the [ __ ] communications
one not the ocp omni consumer products
you did notice that right
i just did what you just did what you
saw yeah okay
that one will work
um then there's the uh
uh
carrillo studios corellco studios i got
that one pronounce it yeah i don't know
it's coral color
right
and then cannon studios i got that shirt
omega man
what was the other one
that's it there was four of them four is
that it okay
yeah the omega man what i did was i
actually took a screenshot of
the movie like when it had the title
card because when the whole
reason that we got the idea to do that
shirt
was because when we were re-watching the
omega man the other day
um i happened to mention like when the
title came up like next to
cheston
i was like hey
i have that font
i think it's called ravenscroft uh i
have it on my computer it's actually the
same font or very similar to the one
that disney used for the haunted mansion
so i was like so that's why i have it
because i do like a lot of that kind of
[ __ ] so i was like so i have that font
and tom's like oh you should totally do
a shirt so i took a screenshot of that
you know charlton heston with the title
and i just built it in illustrator you
know what i mean that's it so yeah it
looks like it looks like that it's gonna
be white on a black shirt can they see
it
i can see it
yeah that's something that's the
can't really see that can you yeah
that's just like that's a transfer
that's a transfer yeah that's what it's
going to look like yeah that's right
from the movie
yeah i did it right in the thing
yes we did a can on one tail we didn't
see like that
they can see it like that
yeah that's better that's better
yeah
and i did smaller versions of it too
like for for smaller shirts smaller
shirts i'm gonna focus on the big one
first because i think that's the most
versatile one right you're going to
focus on the big one
you said fergus no i said focus
i'm afraid
it's from the first one
did you leave that door i see the
yeah there's some light coming in here i
don't like i don't like that like i
don't like light coming in
you know what i mean yeah the [ __ ]
sun's coming in
yeah i don't need that because the sun's
still [ __ ] out
it's [ __ ] bright as hell six o'clock
it's bright as yeah it's bright all the
way until almost 10.
it's so weird it's like because i always
feel like i mean you know you guys i get
up really early and i get to work like i
get up at like seven usually and i get
to work and i usually work until 6 or 7
p.m um you know depending on whether
we're live streaming or not so then
we'll go in the room well sometimes
we'll pour a cocktail or we'll get some
snacks or whatever and then we'll just
like watch a movie and
we'll watch a whole entire movie and
then i'll go to the bathroom and i'm
like what the [ __ ] the sun's still out
it's like [ __ ] nine o'clock it's and
i'm like i'm ready to go to bed and like
it's still [ __ ]
i'm getting so old it's not so much that
it's just that i wake up really early
yeah you know what i mean so by the time
it's like 9 30 or 10 o'clock i'm like
i'm like
you know dozing off
i don't mean to wake up that early i
don't know why i wake up that early i
just do and camp guy to read camp guy
what he said about his old man mowing
the grass oh yeah i remember my old man
mowing some grass for the last time he
had an oxygen tank he had to carry with
him jesus christ yeah that's commitment
and then underneath that
where he continues
i was mowing the grass when my wife came
out and told me he had just died yeah
man there's a lot of grass knowing that
that's pretty weird actually
[ __ ] mowing the lawn and dies
dying and lawn mowing there's a great
association
i'm sure well that's the thing gonna get
out there to work man well i'm sure that
like some dudes have probably died
mowing the lawn sure especially in
florida like i said you [ __ ] have a
heart attack or heat stroke or something
like that
jenny did tom cx he would have got a
kick out of that southern horror he
didn't i actually watched it because i
reviewed it for my uh for my
thing for my flickers video about it
yeah remember that was the one that i
wanted to see in the theater that was
like a like a throwback slasher
barely you say that a lot i don't
remember them all that you yeah i wanted
to see it in the theater and we never
got around like by the time we were
actually gonna go and then it wasn't
playing anymore yeah and so then i was
like well [ __ ] i guess i'll just stream
it but then it was 20 so then i waited
like a couple weeks and then it went
down to 5.99 so the other day i was like
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna rent it and watch
it and review it for my flickers of fear
series was it good
you i think you know what i think you
would really like maybe we ought to
watch it again um yeah i mean we yeah we
totally could i think you would really
dig it it's actually it's it's a slasher
but
it's set in 1979 it's very texas
chainsaw massacre but it also has like a
porny kind of thing because it's like
all these young people going to this
place in texas yeah to like make a porn
movie yeah and then they get like bumped
off one by one so i mean it's really
good i liked it a lot i really liked it
a lot and i think you would probably
like it too i think you would because
usually i mean the thing the reason that
i started
that whole um
my whole flickers of fear thing was
because there was a lot of horror movies
that i wanted to see that i thought you
probably wouldn't like
because i like kind of more arty [ __ ] or
like weird [ __ ] and you don't usually
like that
but that's not what it is it depends on
what it is yes it's gonna be real well
written sometimes you like it and
sometimes you don't and but i was
getting so behind too and i was just
like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna start doing
all this stuff because there's a lot of
like [ __ ] that i want to see
that i don't necessarily want to have to
subject you to because i know you
probably won't like it but that one i
think you would probably really like it
i really liked it i had a good time with
it i thought it was really fun and it's
like super super gorgeous one of the
ones i thought i was gonna absolutely
hate it was is one of my favorite movies
which is art of self-defense she thought
i was gonna hate that see that blew my
mind that blew my mind that you really
liked it was very well written because
it seemed to me like when we were
watching it i said this is exactly the
kind of movie that you usually hate
um
you know what i mean
but
it
it was well written you know what i mean
it was well written and there was truth
in it
you know it was
it was
you know it was
it was slightly satirical it was
satirical yeah but there was a lot of
truth in it you know what i mean and i
liked it
that guy the the guy that directed that
has a new one coming out yeah i saw the
uh what the [ __ ] was the name of it i
saw the um the trailer for it and i was
like wow that looks weird as [ __ ] i'm
yeah i'm into it but i can't remember
what the name of it was i can look it up
but
he has another one coming out i don't
know when it's going to be out there but
i saw a trailer like you see i think a
couple days i think he was
slightly kind of making fun
of the of the karate thing all right uh
yeah
not realizing that there was a lot of
truth in what he was that [ __ ]
you know what what he's taught that
existed
that existed that that was [ __ ] count
dante's [ __ ]
black dragon society well i think that
that's where some of the inspiration
came from yeah sure like when they went
back yeah yeah so a lot of that
ridiculous [ __ ] did is based on some
real based on some [ __ ] which we did a
show about that right
uh where that whole
martial arts what do we call it the
[ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
and just but i think he i think he was
he was satirizing and kind of but he
didn't really in the end he came around
and preserved the honor of [ __ ]
martial arts and warrior cultures in the
end it was it was it its honor was
restored
yeah so
i don't know if he meant to do that but
it did
i'm sure he probably did i mean the
thing about it is that unless you're a
complete hack yeah if you're making
movie like if you're uh you know a
screenwriter you're making movies and
stuff like that you usually have a
really good grasp of like i said what it
is if you're good at what you're doing
yeah then you'll have a really good
grasp like usually you've seen tons of
other movies read tons of other books
you know like all the story tropes and
stuff like that um you know what
references you know what things you're
homaging stuff like that so i usually
assume that people
do things deliberately like that
sometimes accidental [ __ ] comes out and
like i said i'm not talking about people
that just make stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
i'm not talking about that but i'm
talking about somebody that actually
like knows what they're doing if you
guys have never seen artist self defense
see it he's plugging it again plugging
that [ __ ] again one of my friends i
wish i could remember what the new
because i just saw
and i think because i was watching
something on youtube i think it was on
youtube and there was a commercial and
then the a trailer came on and i was
just like oh this movie looks
interesting and then they said oh it's
the same guy that did art of
self-defense and i was like ooh so i had
to tell you that like as soon as you
came out of the bathroom but i can't
remember what the name of it was it
looked really weird and i was like oh
okay i'm into that the guy who wrote and
directed art of self-defense it's just
evidently just one of the wimpiest dudes
ever
and he writes a story kind of like
karate kid kinda but more realistic
based on [ __ ] that actually did happen
uh but not in this story it's
oh it happened out in chicago [ __ ]
the black dragons fighting society all
right count dante out of the comic books
and he does point out how ridiculous
warrior cults are and they apply to all
warrior cults including the infantry and
the army there's a lot of elements of
truth in what he's talking about that's
right zach said it's called duel d-u-a-l
as in okay yeah all right yeah that's
right that's right it's it's kind of
about
cloning or something yeah it's like a
clone kind of thing it looked good had
started jesse eisenberg and that other
girl was fantastic they were both in
image and poots yeah you mentioned poops
and
they were in um vivarium
and oscar just brought that up vivarium
is another great job
i [ __ ] loved bavarian i know it was
really um
i don't know what was it kind of like
people liked it
but that was honestly one of my favorite
movies of that year i thought that was
[ __ ] great we've seen it like two or
three times [ __ ] great sci-fi man
real good oh it was so creepy it's kind
of like a i was into it an extra
dimensional [ __ ] parasite got a hold
of these people made him raise its child
and it had a lot of analogies and and
stuff between child rear and it made you
raise its child like a cuckoo
yeah and it's eerie weird real weird and
it was like it was so twilight zone yeah
and it's irish it's an irish movie the
irish did a real good job on it so some
people said all that jesse eisenberg you
know
but uh no and it's i
maybe he wasn't in a bunch of great
movies but the ones that he elected to
be in these projects i respect his
his choice and what projects to be
involved in on the back of those two
movies right there he's got taste
he's got that's what i mean he's well he
always comes up he was in social network
and i feel like that was kind of i don't
know if that was like his big breakout
role but i think that was the first time
that i saw him that was the movie about
he played um mark zuckerberg like the
facebook founder i haven't seen it it's
good it's really good i think i saw the
theater maybe
but i think that was the first time i'd
seen him in anything like really big and
i really liked that i mean he was in
[ __ ] uh he was in zombieland too
wasn't he like which was also fantastic
so i kind of feel like he picks really
interesting movies he doesn't really
seem to care about oh this is some big
temple i always like respect actors more
even if the movie like ends up not being
all that good i'm i way more respect
like artists directors actors anything
that just like picked someone that's
like i really want to do this this is
like this is a like a passion project
that even if it's weird or even if they
think thinks nobody's going to see it i
mean because bavarium was a pretty weird
[ __ ] movie yeah but weird only works
when the writing is [ __ ] solid well
yes story is solid and it's good ideas
but i'd rather you go weird and fail
yeah then just try to go bland and and
then
that's true but
sometimes just being weird
is a way of masking the fact that your
story [ __ ] sucks in the case of
[ __ ] vivarium it's weird and it's a
real good story real good writing
and with a lot of kind of underlying
messages and stuff and it's the same
with
the same with art of self-defense but i
think ex-military guys would
would appreciate it guys that were
pro fighters or
guys that were in karate school or
something you know they'd really they'd
understand it
although
you understood it you understand you
appreciated the same that i the same as
i did so that's what i mean i don't
think that you had a survey i had a
certain
a certain angle of appreciation though
of you know coming up around guys like
that i mean i'm not saying that like
obviously you're gonna appreciate
something more like if you have some
kind of like personal connection to it
but i don't think that you can
necessarily like just say across the
board oh well other people that don't
have the same experience as me can't
appreciate it the same as me because i
kind of feel like sometimes people can't
for me that story was mostly just about
the the corruption of cults and warrior
cults in particular which that's us army
army infantry anything in the combat
arms
[ __ ] us army rangers
there is corruption in those things and
they are cults there's a lot of cult
like
stuff happening in them and it's the
same as a dojo
all right and a bunch of cult-like stuff
happening in there but this one is being
told you as if it's [ __ ] cow dante
and his [ __ ]
sensei and as bizarre as his sensei is
he's in the the jesse eisenberg
character is there to learn how to be a
man
and to [ __ ] protect himself because
he's constantly he he saw his [ __ ] and
it works he does become a man all right
but it's weird he's doing [ __ ] at the
office that's crazy and [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] up his dog to give him a
masculine dog they killed his dog yeah
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ]
happening
and then uh the best student in there's
a girl but she never gets promoted
because she's a woman because a woman
could never be a man yeah and [ __ ]
and just the way the dude is saying this
and there's like this weird homoerotic
[ __ ] going on and it's just if you've
ever seen that [ __ ] never seen it
it's good it's almost like the dark flip
side of the karate kid yeah it's like
cobra kai
it is it's kind of like cobras it's not
it is serious kinda
well the humor is not the same quite the
same as cobra and then it turns out
these these these people they're killing
people yeah you know it's it's not
it's not [ __ ] the light subjects
matter you know they [ __ ] the story
gets darker and darker it's a dark
comedy yeah sure
oscar says flickers of fear and tones of
terror are great don't stop them jenny
oh i never would say seriously i have
huge huge lists i just got a couple
emails the other day people sending me
copies of their like authors sending me
copies of their books they wanted me to
review so i got to do that i got like a
pile of books over there i gotta do and
this i don't know if i've mentioned this
before but
i'm actually gonna be starting
another channel
that's more dedicated that's just like
all horror movies and books
and
it's mostly going to be like i'm only
going to put up like a couple videos a
week maybe mo mostly but it's going to
be like more like um
i have like a website i haven't put it
up yet it's probably going to be like a
few days before i put it up but i have
like a bunch of content on there like
big long form like movie reviews that
i've written and all kinds of stuff so
i'm gonna do new stuff i might do a new
do a true crime channel too but i need
to work on that still but it's that's
kind of the plan but i am so i'm gonna
start doing like even more
horror content and maybe even more like
true crime content like going forward
because like i said i just feel like i'm
getting behind on all the horror movies
man
sly was out there he doesn't miss
[ __ ] mowing grass with that 36 inch
yard machine eight years in texas
apartment yeah
yeah the ones that i'm looking at i
think they're told they're smart smaller
they're 24 inch i think they're only 24
to 26 inch i think so
but hey you know
i'm limited into money
willa lisa did you see amulet i did i
don't remember like a lot about i
remember liking it but it didn't like
leave a lasting impression but i did i
remember liking it no maniac we were
saying vivarium not bavarian
yeah zach says i rewatched a history of
violence recently and i forgot how much
i loved it i need to rewatch that too
that's david cronenberg by the way um
yeah i think i saw that once or twice
and i remember really really digging it
i think i saw that in the theater also
but i don't think i've seen it again
since then
um
oscar says yes jenny a true horror
review channel horror is where the heart
is that's true and like i said
i'm just
i know that i
that i started like doing the extra
videos and stuff but i'm still behind
and i still every time i scroll through
like all the streaming services and see
i was like oh i want to see oh i got to
see that oh i got to see that oh my god
i'm so behind it so it's like old stuff
new stuff anything i'm just like maniac
you never saw vivarium
if you haven't seen that you got to see
it man that's a good one
same i mean yeah like i said it seems
like divisive but i mean i really really
dug you can see it for free now
if you have if you have amazon or it's
one of the other streamings yeah i think
it's on amazon prime like if you have an
amazon prime subscription it's uh free
from it's [ __ ] for me on there yeah
that one vivarium and artist self
defense there's a two [ __ ] badass
classics i love them good movies
as far as the the new movies
or newer you know real good
i mean that's the thing i see
i love old movies but i see a lot of
really good new ones too yeah i get a
lot of attention a lot of the real good
ones like those two they didn't get a
lot of attention you got to find them
got to find them on your own and the
thing about it is that there's so many
movies coming out which is good i mean
you know what i mean that it's so much
easier to make indie movies nowadays
like it's much cheaper but that also
means that as a movie watcher you have
to like you know wade through a lot of
crap like before you get to something
good
but i will say that
i mean i've seen pretty like in the last
month or two months like of the show
that i've been doing i've seen a [ __ ]
ton of really really good
horror movies that i was really really
into like i think like the last like at
the beginning of june i talked about um
come true
and censor which both came out in 2021 i
think and those were phenomenal i loved
both of those those are like really
really good but i've seen like a lot of
really really good ones and even some of
the ones that aren't like fantastic are
still like really really decent and
worth watching you know so there's that
but uh yeah and like i said there's a
lot of old ones too this is saying the
stairs
2021 horror sci-fi free on youtube you
know that one i don't know that one
you haven't heard of that one
i'll have to check that out because i
don't have my pen but
my pen's like way over there
but yeah so i'm always just kind of like
whenever i'm looking for [ __ ] i mean
sometimes i'll hear [ __ ] through the
grapevine
you know like uh i'll see movies come up
on you know horror channels and
everybody's like oh this is like really
good everybody's gotta see that or it
goes around the festivals and everybody
like there's a lot of buzz about it so
i'm like okay well i gotta see that and
like you know give my opinion on it ones
that are like lesser known you kind of
have to like dig around so i kind of
like go around a different horror sites
like dread central and stuff like that
and i'm like what's
you know what's good this what's the
underrated [ __ ] this year that everybody
should have seen and like nobody saw it
and it's like so i really do try to like
keep up with [ __ ] but it's really hard
because like a lot of
a lot of stuff comes out and the thing
about it is a lot of a lot of that stuff
is probably like really good but
you know
because so much stuff comes out
it's like hard to
keep up with it so
i don't know
but i've been trying i have been trying
but i have like a massive massive list
of [ __ ] that i need to watch
so old [ __ ] new [ __ ] everything because
like i said i don't care i don't care if
it's old i don't care if it's new i'll
watch anything i just i love horror
stuff and i don't care what era how long
we've been rolling
39 minutes okay we got a pretty good
sized crowd in there if you want to
start on it we can are we ready to start
on
hair if you just got here yeah we're
only just you didn't miss much of
anything because we're only just
starting
again if you're i don't know if anybody
is new here but you know
we kind of give it a little while to
warm up before we start using yeah we
need like a little bit of uh alcohol
right to get like our tongues make sure
all the regulars have shown up and then
we go into it
oscar says jenny you and jason from
sinister cinema have become my favorite
horror reviewers thank you very much i
like i like sinister cinema as well i
like sinister cinema i like uh drum
dumbs i like
um
who else i like uh grumpy andrew uh he's
awesome he's british dude
and he usually does old [ __ ] though he
doesn't usually do new [ __ ] he does like
a lot of hammer movies and stuff uh so i
like that
uh i kind of like blood bath and beyond
those are they're pretty good
yeah when we were doing the 50s and now
we're doing 60 stuff people have been
kind of rooting us on to keep going with
some of the old classics
uh
we just recorded the one of uh whatever
happened to baby james yeah
it came out real good it'll be out when
is that coming out well for patrons
you'll be able to see it tomorrow um if
you're not a patron then you'll be able
to see it friday okay the um
in that one i said that we're gonna
eventually get around reviewing them
the one from the 50s one about the giant
ants we probably yeah we probably should
do because i feel like we did all the
other ones well we've covered a lot of
the classics from like the 70s and 80s i
feel like so i kind of feel like maybe
we should do more 50s and 60s [ __ ]
because we haven't done because when we
did what you know like i said we
recorded whatever happened to baby jane
today i was like oh that means we should
probably do hush hush sweet charlotte uh
which was kind of like it wasn't a
sequel to that but it was kind of like a
similar movie so we should do that and
there's like just a lot of movies from
the 50s and 60s
i want to do um
a
forbidden planet
we have done that one
maybe the original thing
thing from another world yeah that's
actually a good idea and then maybe uh
dave the earth stood still
yeah that would probably be good too
i've done that one i mean we've done war
of the worlds we haven't really done
like a lot of 50s
i did a couple on mines i think i did um
i did day of the triffids which i didn't
love actually yeah i liked it when i was
a kid we reached i remember seeing it
lately i re-watched it yeah i rewatched
it like the novel's better gonna say
uh zach says i'm pretty into ryan
hollinger oh yeah me too i forgot like
that irish dude yeah he's he's fantastic
uh but i wonder how much of that is how
attracted to him i am that man has
beautiful eyes he does actually he's
super super cute and it's like i love
that every single video that he does i
like that he puts up stuff pretty much
just once a week and he just picks a
random ass movie
um
and i like that
every single video because of his irish
accent he says i don't know if i can do
it but he says whenever he says however
he always says
like whoever i can't remember like how
he pronounces it but somebody always
like comments on it like how cute it is
look at the [ __ ] comments like how he
said so now he says it on purpose
because everybody comments on it but
yeah he's super cute i like him as well
i like him as well but uh yeah i'm
trying to think of like other because i
watch a lot of horror channels like
horror review channels um
who's that one guy there's one canadian
dude that i really like too but i can't
remember what his [ __ ] name is right
now and there's another guy who's
scottish i think called man vs film or
man v film or something like that and
he's usually pretty good but and i got
into this one guy i can't remember what
his name is but he does well i got into
him because he does like a lot of giallo
movies and i actually watched his review
of whatever happened to baby jane today
and he had never seen it and he was like
he couldn't believe he had never seen it
because he [ __ ] loved it he's real
into like 60s and 70s kind of horror um
but i kind of like his [ __ ] because
he just kind of like sits in a room and
just like rambles like we do
and he has like
allergies so he's always like kind of
sniff-like and stuff i can't remember
what his name is if you do if you know
like if you've seen it you probably know
what i'm talking about but i like that
dude too like he seems like really kind
of cool and
you know down to earth uh oscar says the
horror show they've gone downhill in all
honesty i do watch them every now and
then i do watch them every now and then
i tend not to like ones that are too
i don't know like over produced i would
mostly just like it if it was one person
like talking about a movie sometimes if
you have two guys because there's some
that are like these two guys who are
also canadian i like a lot of canadian
youtubers actually
there's that are also canadian and they
just kind of sit there and they drink
and they talk about but usually like
nice beer or wine or whatever and they
always say what they're drinking and
then they talk about a movie and they'll
talk about it for like half an hour or
something like that those dudes are
funny i like those guys but usually i
don't like
i don't like ones that are like way too
over the top like horror you know i
don't really like that kind of stuff
because i'm just like shut up and just
like talk about the movie okay let's
like let's not have all this kind of
like whatever they're trying to be like
they're on tv i do like dr wolfie livo
dr wolfila
is i mean he's just like i don't even
know what he really looks like because
he always wears like a cheap werewolf
mask and he does like a voice but that
dude is hilarious because he's not real
shouty or anything like that he's just
like really funny and he goes like in
depth uh in a lot of the movies
what about tila tila you uh you catching
the show right now if so it dropped us
uh yeah where is tila better
oh my goodness yeah where's where's
peanut butter eating sandra where's
peanut where's peanut butter sauce
peanut butter sandra
if you guys don't know who sandra was
sandra was a german girl that i talked
about peanut butter one time and she
started buying it and she had to buy
every kind of she loved it so she tried
to buy every kind of [ __ ]
peanut butter was out there
american peanut butter
yeah you got to get the american people
we know what we're doing we know what
we're doing yeah i heard the [ __ ]
europeans talking [ __ ] about peanut
butter and that's [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are they talking about they're talking
about [ __ ] british peanut butter
british peanut butter anything they
don't know they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing
skippy for peter pan or jeff jeff yeah
[ __ ] american peanut butter
crunchy or the creamy one of the two
like i said crunchy i'm going to cook
yeah and it is good too and you know
something other hamburgers man [ __ ]
hamburgers suck
yeah i [ __ ] been all over the world
[ __ ]
part of the time i was growing up in
brazil and what they called a hamburger
i'd throw in the [ __ ] garbage
terrible even the damn ketchup just
sucked
[ __ ] orange ketchup
and our convenience stores have better
hamburgers than that yeah the
guns that they were using [ __ ] sucked
and they would complain about yeah
american food isn't any good as [ __ ]
would you know
you know yeah
that's not that's that's not a hamburger
give me that [ __ ] well the thing
about it is sometimes if you go to
europe and i've seen this happen in
germany and i think it happens in the uk
as well like probably to a lesser extent
is that some companies that are british
companies will be like hey american
style but they'll just make it they
don't and they don't really know they
don't know what it is like what it is so
they'll just make it and people like man
this sucks i'm like yeah but that's not
the same as like what we're eating every
year yeah and there we go
eating peanut butter and jelly i mean we
have our share of shitty food over here
i'm not saying that i'm just saying that
a lot of times if you've never been here
like your perception of what american
food is is maybe like a little bit
strange right although you guys are
totally right about um portion sizes we
do have food if you go to a restaurant
there's massive if that's enough for
like two or three people used to be
there might be having food shortages now
who knows how big the [ __ ] smaller
portions are i mean the thing when we go
to like a sit-down restaurant like just
like a casual restaurant um they usually
give you like more food than you can eat
which is kind of a deal because you can
take it home and eat it later we've been
going to this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] florida as [ __ ] restaurant
up the road called the trough
t-r-o-f-f trough the trough is [ __ ]
good they don't even know how to spell
it trump
all right [ __ ] the bikers told me to
go there when i was at the oasis says
man i need some [ __ ] good you know
seafood yeah we wanted to see oysters
you know when i went there [ __ ] when
we first got there they're [ __ ]
harley's parked out there yeah and it's
just it's a nice place it's just real
basic looking
and you get fresh seafood
uh by market prices everything's at
market prices man the food there is
really good good i mean it kind of looks
i don't want to say it looks like a dump
because it doesn't i mean it looks like
it looks like a dump from the outside
yeah now the inside is like pretty nice
they have like big tvs it's turquoise
blue man it is the whole thing
it just looks like a little squat like a
concrete block building you go in it's
like it's got a bar
yeah they got a full bar i got a full
bar
a bunch of [ __ ] tables looks just
southern as [ __ ]
and families would come in [ __ ] had
old lady attack jenny i love you oh my
god they had her on a leash she had some
kind of stroke and she just
thought she was afraid everybody's
friends that was funny
but you could get
fried oysters they're like that big the
whole [ __ ] plate of them for under
20.
i mean we've eaten there a couple times
and like i've gotten a couple different
things in the food that was actually
it's just it's really really good
[ __ ] yeah really hard everything's
fried or or raw or [ __ ] something you
know i mean you don't have to get it
fried you can get it because i think i
got like kind of way yeah you can get it
any kind of way and the french fries are
great
onion rings and just
it's [ __ ] great seafood man it's
right there on the water
yep i don't think that's ocean though is
it no that's lake yeah
yep that's a lake
karen lee says the 1969 movie whatever
happened to aunt alice is really good
that's another one that i've been
wanting to watch because after whatever
happened to baby jane came out and i
think i forgot to mention this on the
review but that kind of like ushered in
the whole what they call the psycho
bitty sub genre or hag horror i've seen
it called that too uh where it's just
like a grotesque old woman like being
the villain
um and after that there were like a
whole bunch of copycats because whatever
happened to baby jane was like such a
big success so they had yeah who slew
auntie roo and all that kind of stuff
becca just showed up she said that
[ __ ] uh portion sizes in europe are
huge also
maybe they got big now yeah they must
have gotten big now like they got
americanized because i remember i mean i
haven't been in the uk since 2009 but i
started going there like back in the 90s
and that was one thing
that
like british people that came here that
have been to the us that was almost like
the first thing they commented on well
now they were kind of like excited about
it because they're like man we go in a
restaurant like man you could eat for
like two days off that [ __ ] like what
they give you like it's a big pile kfc
freak them out get a whole bucket of
chicken [ __ ] well see yeah my my
ex-husband's relatives came to florida
and they were here for like two weeks
they did the whole vacation package and
stuff like that they thought it was
fantastic well he was a big rugby player
from wales they were from wales yeah and
he was a big rugby player so he was like
he couldn't get over they have kfc over
there but i'm imagining that it's not so
over here you get like the big bucket
and he's well he was talking about how
cheap it was like you get this massive
bucket full of chicken and it was like
super cheap and he's like he could
probably eat the whole bucket by itself
coming in migrating down they're
migrating over here deep from deep deep
into honky motherland
over these buckets of chicken buckets of
southern fried chicken just calling them
as far as whales that's why we all have
fat and have diet
fat diabetes
it's all southern food
although to be honest with you nowadays
um
i probably could have eaten a lot more
fried chicken in my youth but nowadays i
can maybe eat two pieces i can manage
two pieces and then i'm like man i think
i'm gonna throw up
i can't really eat anymore sly would
love it down here sly [ __ ] there's
nothing
you know southern food and soul food
it's the [ __ ] same thing you know
they got soul food restaurants here you
get [ __ ] deep [ __ ] fried chicken
and waffles
[ __ ] really good over the chanters
you're making me watch it fried chicken
on a waffle with all the damn butter and
pork shrimp hot
hot [ __ ] yeah
shrimp and grits her shrimp and grits
are really good and the shrimp and grits
because
they have a little bit of cheese in them
and a little bit of coconut milk
i think hers are like the best shrimp
ingredients i've ever seen tells um uh
black biker chick she owns it her
husband's a biker too another black guy
a black guy
and then uh she runs around with it down
big little stuffed damn gorilla on the
on on the [ __ ] back of her bike she's
a character she's [ __ ] character
and uh got a nice little restaurant you
can look you can find it we probably we
probably got videos i know i think yeah
yeah we put videos up of of the trough
too
they're yeah
or they were on one of the shows
chantal's in sanford florida man yeah
it's downtown downtown staffordshire
right by mannequins you can find it on
google's you know i've done videos and
[ __ ] had pictures of
me and jenny in there drunk as [ __ ] i'm
trying to molest her and [ __ ] the
damn restaurant [ __ ] her boobs
[ __ ] looking so good [ __ ] [ __ ]
bags are coming out a little goth outfit
i got that [ __ ] on video i've showed it
before on on the show yeah i think i
gotta bust that [ __ ] out here
i how to bust that [ __ ] out john smith
says exploitation what exploitation
exploitation yeah yeah that's probably
what they should have called it i don't
it's like i like psycho bitty though too
i mean that's i guess that's what the if
that's what the wikipedia page is it
links to psychobitty so i guess that's
what they decided to call it which is
fine with me that's a good name zack
says whenever i can i get a rotisserie
chicken from walmart and use that [ __ ]
in sandwiches yeah that's actually like
um buying rotisserie chickens from
walmart or wherever is like actually
really good because
you can make sandwiches out of it you
can make soup with it you can make you
can use the bones and like use make
broth you can do all kind of [ __ ] with
that
you know you can make all the tacos [ __ ]
you can make all kind of stuff with it
you know chicken pox trying to get that
picture
for that video everybody's seen that
yeah okay a million times
[Laughter]
he doesn't yeah
he doesn't care yeah that's a chance
she's
yeah that was after the night it's
probably two to two o'clock in the
morning
it's a good place got a dj booth in
there and everything they do karaoke a
lot yeah
look at jitty laughing at the camera
hugo says you can make chicken taquitos
sure yeah yeah too i mean you can do
pretty much anything see this
sidetracking us again behind food you
guys know our weakness next thing a
[ __ ] is going to start asking
about grits
[ __ ] don't even start you started me on
grits man
i know we're already we're already like
an hour in right now
we got to start something on the show i
mean started talking about this [ __ ]
okay i mean should we even at this point
it's like should we even have a topic
yeah
no i'm really into this topic
like i said we have talked about broken
hair before but we've never had like a
whole show
we did a show
i can't remember how long ago it was it
was probably two years
maybe more
and i think it was just called buried
alive
and i was talking about all the
contraptions that people had come up
with like to keep their [ __ ] you know
relatives
bodies from getting stolen um and i
think we brought up like broken hair on
that but i don't think we did like a
whole
show about them
so like i said i put it in the poll and
it won so there you go
uh
yeah jeffrey yard's going yes talk about
these guys
and we're going to talk about them all
right we've been warming them up too
long go ahead jake there we go
i'm going to get a drink for you okay
freshen this up yeah just like put some
more ice and well i mean you might as
well fill it up while you're out there
because the ice is all melted because
it's florida
all right so
uh so like i kind of feel like this is
maybe well known but maybe it's not as
well known as i think it is
so birkin hair uh both their first names
were williams so it's william burke and
william hair because that's why
everybody's called them broken hair
now even though this is the strange
thing i kind of feel like they're
associated with grave robbing which
which is not crazy because they did kind
of come into being or they did what they
did because of the whole grave robbing
situation but as far as i know
they never robbed any graves their whole
thing was
well it's too much work to rob graves so
we're just gonna like make our own
bodies so there's that kind of thing so
essentially they're like serial killers
now
over a period of about 10 months so less
than a year uh in 1828 in edinburgh
scotland this took place
um they are thought to have murdered at
least
16 people maybe more not entirely sure
um and their whole thing was they did it
because
they were uh they just wanted money they
were so they were selling bodies to
uh anatomy like you know anatomy schools
or whatever
so this is the context this is where
this whole thing like started out so
it's early 19th century it's edinboro
scotland
now
for whatever reason just one of those
vicissitudes of history or whatever
um edinburgh had become kind of like a
central hub of anatomy research
scientific research into anatomy um it
wasn't the only place it was also laden
leiden whatever it is in the netherlands
and there was also padua in italy but
edinboro was definitely up there one of
the three like big centers where if you
wanted to be an anatomist or you want to
learn about anatomy um those were like
the schools that you had to go to that's
where all the best anatomists were and
all that other kind of stuff
so now obviously if you're gonna learn
about human anatomy
um you probably need some cadavers to
like practice on it's not like you could
get in the like [ __ ] vr
goggles and like cut a body up you need
to honestly i don't even know if i trust
a doctor that just had done it like vr i
guess it's better than nothing but you
wanted you know hands-on kind of
experience but yeah so like back then
you know that was kind of the only thing
so the medical students would come in
and you would have to have bodies to cut
up
and the thing that happened you know
this is like a little bit related i
remember reading a book i think it was
called
man it was by mary roach
and she was talking about like weird
[ __ ] that uh had done with dead bodies
and she did one chapter about plastic
surgeons and i had honestly never
thought about this plastic surgeons who
are also doctors obviously and they have
to practice on corpses too but ones that
would just do
face lifts and nose jobs and [ __ ] like
that they didn't even need the whole
body so you would go into this room and
she even had like a photo of one that
she had taken they would go into this
room like the plastic surgeon students
would go into this room and it was just
kind of like these like you know like in
a biology class with all these silver
trays and it would just be the head
and they would just do like a nose job
like just on this severed head and i was
just kind of like
like now that i think about it like yeah
that makes total sense but wow that's
really macabre i can't believe i didn't
know that but yeah so plastic surgeons
they just said yeah we just need a head
popped over here so we can like practice
nose jobs on it but i don't know why
that like stuck in my mind read mary
roach's books by the way if you're
interested in like weird macabre [ __ ]
because
she wrote about like science uh like
looking into the afterlife and she wrote
about like stuff that happens to corpses
after you die and it's like they're
super fun like her books are like super
funny i've read like a whole bunch of
them
but yeah so when you're training to be a
medical student obviously you need dead
bodies to like cut up onto practice like
i said because you're going to be
cutting up on live people and nobody
wants to be cut up on by somebody that
doesn't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
now
okay so in scotland at the time this is
beginning in the first quarter of the
19th century
scottish law had very specific
uh parameters over what bodies could be
used for dissection
you could use
convicted criminals that had died in
prison or had died on the gallows for
example
uh you could use suicide victims
you could use orphans
you know
children or whoever that died without
anyone claiming them you could use them
as well but that was about it
so for a little while that was fine that
was sufficient
but because as edinburgh became more of
a destination for people
you know looking to kind of excel in
anatomy or anything or everything like
that and also like a couple of years
prior they had also passed a law
which
on its face seems like a good thing
where they made it
because prior to this there had been
like the death penalty for a lot of like
kind of [ __ ] crimes like horse
thievery and stuff like that would a law
had been passed it was like okay well
let's not like have the death penalty
for minor [ __ ] which like i said is good
but in the aggregate it meant that well
now we don't have as many bodies
for students to cut up because before
they were just like
killing people for like i said minor
[ __ ] so
you know so they had plenty of bodies
but because so many students were coming
there and because of this new law where
they weren't killing as many criminals
uh they didn't have enough bodies to go
around uh at least legally are you gonna
get into the city of edinburgh at all
not a huge amount let me throw some in
there okay
when you when you hear about when you
hear the word edinburgh it sounds all
fancy like it's some exotic european
stuff you know like wow edinboro you
know it sounds all classy thank you
brace
edinboro was [ __ ] dangerous in this
time this is uh
like detroit of the area
well london was bad yeah i mean
everywhere was kind of bad
any big city was bad what they had done
is uh the [ __ ] because they had
[ __ ] up sanitation practices for a
long time
in most european cities
it was easier instead of to take all the
horseshit and [ __ ] human [ __ ] off the
[ __ ] main roads and it was too hard
to get rid of that it had been built up
over a long time they would just build
another floor
so you know i had an underground it's
like we don't want to clean all that
[ __ ] up yeah just build another floor on
top so you could take steps down and go
into what was called the underground the
storefront fronts were still there all
the old streets were still there and
above them was a wooden floor
but they were totally sealed off you
know i think they even put things like
you know his tarmac or whatever you know
that daylight wouldn't come through
water wouldn't even come through
those undergrounds was where um all the
bad [ __ ] happened yeah the esboro vault
i think we mentioned that on one of our
shows
it was just like out of star wars a hive
of scum
and villainy you know it was like that
pretty much so all your hookers and your
murderers and your [ __ ] organized
gangsters and criminals they were all
down there inside that underground
because nobody and all the rents of
course plummeted because you didn't want
to meet underneath there
um no subway you just walked around in
it and it was [ __ ] nasty
because there was no way to police it
even the police at the time which they
did they weren't modern police but
they're more like mall security really
they had some people that were
investigators kind of sherlock holmes
types but they just didn't have any
forensic science yeah they didn't really
have the resources no
if you killed somebody you were gonna
and nobody saw it you were probably
gonna get away with it uh there was no
way to prove you know that's just the
way it was
um
and if you killed a poor person you were
probably gonna get away with it didn't
have time to worry about poor people you
had you had well i mean case in point
these [ __ ] killed like
lots of people without you you just
didn't want to kill a wealthy person
because then they could actually fund an
investigation and fun try to track down
who did it you know it caused too much
mistake but it was really easy to commit
murder really easy to get rid of it and
that the underground of edinburgh had a
lot to do with it so geography always
[ __ ] sly i'll tell you he's also the
other old professional soldier what
dictates victory or defeat has nothing
to do with your army it's mostly the
geography you see
if you own the geography you win
just ask the vietnamese
unlimited air power you still lost they
owned the geography
well the criminal organ the criminal
underworld owned the geography of
edinburgh that and it was that
underground and a lot of [ __ ]
illicit trades including the selling of
dead bodies was taking place
organized from underneath that damn city
well the cops probably felt like well um
everybody down there is a criminal is
like why the [ __ ] should we even go down
there it's like why would anybody go
down there willingly unless they were up
to some [ __ ] yeah the rules were
basically if you were a cop you weren't
going down there they kill you
well and the same rule applied like i
said any big city like you know shortly
after the industrial revolution or
around this time where there was like so
many people living these tenements and
it was like super crowded like i said
they didn't have any sanitation or
anything like that um like i said the
same thing happened in london where you
kind of got like white chapel area stuff
like that where at least they kind of
had cops and stuff but
now from the american perspective
irish english some british
welsh scottish people germans
if you were a young guy and you were
down on your luck and had no prospects
but you had enough brains you're like
i'm not going to stay in these
underground so these cities i'm getting
the [ __ ] out of here i'm going to
america
and those dudes would end up in new york
and if they had still had money in their
pocket instead of getting trapped in new
york or new amsterdam or some place like
that which that's old new york
if you got trapped in those cities the
chances of you coming out of there
[ __ ] married and successful about
zero you're probably gonna [ __ ] work
yourself to death and die of some
disease in one of those in new york but
if you had money you could escape new
york you escape new york like you know
anyway and get and start moving west and
those dudes ended up being the people
you were know as the cowboys and [ __ ]
gunfighters and [ __ ] they were actually
came from places like this
well yeah i mean like i said around this
time period we had a lot of yeah that's
where a lot of the immigration came with
the irish immigration and everything
like that and a lot of them did stay in
the city and some of them like you know
obviously a lot of them were not
successful because poverty kind of
breeds poverty but some of them actually
like were able to crawl their way out of
the mire built huge empires like that
with you know starting with nothing
right so you know like i said it's it's
a very small percentage
statistically and this is based on all
the all the old books of the 70s and the
80s and the 90s that it used to read
about the old west and the victorian era
in the united states
if you were an immigrant coming into the
[ __ ] united states through the
eastern seaboard
you did not want to stop in any of those
cities
your chances of ever getting out of that
city
was very low you wanted out of there as
soon as possible
but a lot of guys it was a trap and it
was set up as a trap by the landlords
and all the industries there
guys would go and end up in those cities
thinking well i'll just be here for a
couple months and then i'll save up
enough money and i'll continue moving
west into a nicer neighborhood ah they
had that figured out already
you'd end up in a
dumbbell tenement basically as a slave
until you were dead working until you
died you'd never get enough money your
life expectancy was [ __ ] like under
10 years in some in some cases i mean
the conditions the conditions were back
then were awful
[ __ ] filthy in the and where they
would trick you into staying was
dangerous and the jobs that they would
trick you into taking was deadly
all the food was exalted rotten food
diseases bad sanity murders
yeah [ __ ] it was you wanted to keep
no thanks if you got to new york with
any [ __ ] money you wanted to keep
moving don't spend any of that money in
new york back in those days
so uh but that's where a lot of your
cowboys gunfighters and all the [ __ ]
figures of the [ __ ] old west as they
came from places actually originally
like by edinburgh or they were the
second generations
the sons of people who came from this
kind of stuff yeah i mean you didn't get
a lot i mean i know a lot of scottish
people came here too but i kind of feel
like well the main ones were irish i
mean obviously we have like a huge yeah
it was irish powered for a long time a
huge huge irish still i mean like people
here that's and i kind of feel like i
know people that are actually irish that
you know were born in ireland and grew
up in ireland i think it's very funny
that like so many americans say it's
like oh i'm irish american they're like
[ __ ] no you're not that was like
[ __ ] four generations again
that's where most of our i mean that's
where most of our ancestors
dna leads back to their that's where
most of our ancestors are the average
person especially my dad's side of the
family is
especially southerners
southerners it's mostly irish scottish
welsh
and german except for like the midwest
is more norwegian german yeah that kind
of stuff but i kind of feel like the
whole the south and the east uh eastern
seaboard is a lot of irish the whole
american war between the states or civil
wars led back to the honky motherland
ethnic differences between white people
back then it was more celtic germanic
people versus more scandinavian anglo or
british style people in the north there
was
ethnic
tensions
lived long you know went on for a long
time you know uh they're still around
it's just i don't think people are
really aware of them but
just now it's just cultural differences
but they you you go back to the 1850s
they were ethnic differences that's
where a lot of that [ __ ] came from
and in the south you also had uh native
americans and africans also blended in
and french and spanish
mixing in well yeah like i said i mean
florida big time is florida
mississippi louisiana spain i mean
florida is probably more spanish and
native american than a lot of other
south louisiana south louisiana's
[ __ ] french and french and haiti
basically yeah and to this day and you
can just see it in the people and
everything and in the culture it hasn't
changed very much
the populations are much bigger because
peop everybody has prospered
they were the populations were real
small back then but we're all
descendants of those real small seed
populations
john smith says i think boris karloff
played one of them in a movie or am i
misremembering you know i've seen
the um i've seen some clips from that
movie it was
karloff and bella lugosi was in it i
don't remember if he if they were
actually playing birken hair or if they
were referring to birken hair because
the clip that i saw
was boris karloff
going to bella lugosi and being like
i'll show you how burke did it
um and like trying to smother him so i
don't know if he was actually being
broken hair or if they were just like
referring to broken hair i mean i kind
of feel like these guys are like
really soaked into the public
consciousness in a way maybe more in the
uk than here
but
so there was that so yeah there have
been a couple of movies there was one
and i think um slasher fred brought it
up earlier there was actually a movie
that came out in 2010
that was actually directed by john
landis that was called broken hair it
was kind of like a black comedy about
them simon pegg was in it and um andy
circus you know the guy that always
plays he played gollum and all that
other kind of stuff so those two were in
it and i think i've seen it i remember
it being like really funny but i haven't
seen it like for a long time but yeah so
there was that so i kind of feel like a
lot of people know this story but
uh i will say that bryce who thank you
again just sent us a super chat well
sent us a super chat a while ago okay
what do you say uh said just tuned in
never heard of these two looks
interesting so i never know
i don't know i always kind of like
thought burke and hair
to me were like always like really well
known and stuff but i i forget that like
sometimes maybe people don't they're not
from the same country as me or they're
not from the same culture as me or
whatever so it's like maybe they
wouldn't have
heard of it and plus they probably are
younger than me because i'm old as [ __ ]
so you know what i mean
so
i don't know i kind of feel like
whenever we do something like this i'm
always kind of like well what new can i
bring to the table because everybody
already knows this story but then i'm
just kind of like people will come on
and be like i never heard of these
people so i'm like oh okay that actually
kind of makes me feel better because i
don't feel like i'm just like repeating
[ __ ]
so john smith also says i live in
glasgow so edinburgh is our rival city
there you go yeah there you go
yeah there are nice places now
nice cities now i mean i had always
wanted to go to scotland i've been to
england i've been to wales but i never
did get to go to scotland and i always
did want to go it actually looks uh
quite beautiful and i it's it's cold and
i'm into that you know there's a
historian named thomas soul he's
african-american historian and he'll
tell you all about southern culture
african-american culture and he'll trace
a lot of it back to
the british islands and uk
i'm in scotland ireland wales
a lot of the bad habits that your
ancestors have live on here they had
codified in our culture but it's
which is very because you guys have
moved up in the world well here we just
[ __ ] mutated and
america makes things bigger grander and
more grotesque and more stupid
but it works in a strange way
sometimes it god we still love it though
oh that's another uh
channel that i want to recommend he
probably doesn't need my recommendation
because he has a lot more uh subscribers
than us but i love
lost in the pond he's a guy
who
uh he's from the uk but he's lived in
these because he's married to an
american and he's lived in the u.s for
14 years and he lives in the midwest oh
yeah um and he makes videos he usually
puts one and he is super super funny
like he has that like dry british sense
of humor that i'm really into
and he'll do like videos like uh you
know differences between different words
or like
um you know and he goes around different
he had one the other day where he tried
chicken fried steak for the first time
yeah uh man he loved that [ __ ] of course
well he was talking to another youtuber
he was also like a scottish dude who was
traveling through america and he's like
[ __ ] you got to try like chicken fried
steak yeah and so he went to a diner
like he lives in chicago and um and he
had it and he was like oh my god this is
like
how have i not eaten this like until now
this is like fantastic so yeah so he's
like super funny too his name's lawrence
by the way but his channel's called lost
in the box southern food is one of the
dominant culinary forces in the that
represent in the united states and it's
all southern food southern food is soul
food it's the same thing uh but whites
and blacks ate the same food
when blacks moved north
they took southern food with them and
they called it soul food here it's just
called food
okay it's the same food pretty much
of course you know there's contemporary
versions and contemporary uh uh dishes
like um
okay chicken and waffles is new
that's soul food and that's very
southern those are southern classics
combined
but we're combining
old stuff to make something new okay
but uh
yeah [ __ ] southern food is one of the
dominant foods
of the american scene a lot of has to do
with the army u.s army
us army's menu traditionally was
southern food because most of the
soldiers were recruited from the south
of all races and it was you know whites
hispanics or mexican style from the
southwest and african style from the
deep south black guys and if you looked
it
some of them classic movies from the 80s
you know what i mean like predator one
and you looked at that [ __ ] racial
makeup and that special that mercenary
team that's the way the us army looks
let's that's what it looks like
and uh you're going to feed them what
they're comfortable with it's going to
be southern food you know
and militaries the army the army is
lingo sly back me up
it's all in a southern accent
a lot of outsiders don't know that but
militaries or the army army language is
it has a southern accent to it
uh okay glenn says uh talking about the
body snatcher there was actually a
robert louis stevenson
story that was called the body snatcher
that was based on broken hair
um
so there was that so they might have
made a movie of that i kind of feel like
probably dj maniac says ah yes the simon
pegg version killed my last laptop well
i'm sorry to hear that i remember it
being a funny movie but
it came out in 2010 that was a long time
ago and uh which is crazy to say but i
actually would like to see it again that
like seemed like super funny john smith
says birken hair are these days a
tourist attraction in edinburgh i was
watching an old british
documentary earlier today about birken
hair
and the guy that was presenting was in a
pub
in edinburgh that was called the broken
hair
pub like it's a pub and restaurant i
don't know if it's still there or not
because i have no idea like when this
[ __ ] because it looked [ __ ] old so i
don't know like when this [ __ ] came out
but yeah so i kind of feel like and well
i saw their um
their wax figures in madame tussauds
that's in london so i'm assuming that i
mean they're very famous john smith said
he had visited the united states once it
got [ __ ] up down in new orleans like a
[ __ ] got drunk out in the street that'd
be [ __ ] like it's right there
when i was living in gulfport you know
[ __ ] the french quarter was my weekly
hangout and go down there's a goth club
we had called the crystal we used to had
another one called the hellfire club
and or you know pierre's place and
[ __ ] you got to be careful down the
corner i mean there is some police
protection there but quarters dangerous
place really it is there's a lot of
crime very dangerous and um
it does have to watch your back it has a
tourist flare to it and there the police
are watching over those tourists
but when those cops aren't there the
wolves are still there and a lot of the
right generally in the u.s i'd watch
your back pretty much anywhere but
especially the friend fresh especially
new orleans
um
marilyn manson and uh
[ __ ] what's his name
trent rezner were living there during
the time that i was
[ __ ] hanging out there
and later on
marilyn manson wrote a book and he and
he said something that is a truism to
this day
he said you better watch it with new
orleans you're going to end up in one of
three places
a bar
as a hospital no excuse me a hospital a
bar no no it was it was a hospital
a cemetery or a prison that's what
you're going to end up in
this man i kind of feel like cemetery
should be the last yeah yeah yeah either
either a yeah
a hospital a pr a prison or a cemetery
and that's because rule of threes comedy
yeah
right
and that's because
all three of those are in
famous locations in [ __ ] new orleans
you know orleans parish prison is one of
the most notorious [ __ ]
french style [ __ ]
i feel like the crime there is still bad
yeah like i i think it's one of the
worst places yeah in the us well it had
a bunch of uh
diy projects and [ __ ] uh most of the
projects got torn down but they were
like something out of [ __ ] haiti
[ __ ] real violet
[ __ ] well it's very poor poor violent
and um
just mean
but you could have a good time there but
the life expectancy was low and extreme
corruption extreme corruption
um like some of the biggest bank robbers
and biggest criminals in new orleans
were cops
no nopd
they'd catch this [ __ ] they'd catch a
serial rapist eternity's a cop they'd
catch somebody who [ __ ] robbed
[ __ ] seven or eight banks turned out
he's a cop
you know
that's not a big shocker for me no it
turned they were they had they had
somebody that was somebody that was
robbing liquor stores and killed like
three or four people in execution style
and one of them and killed another
because it turns out it was a [ __ ]
female cop yeah i'm i'm not [ __ ] on
cops it's just i'm just saying
that sometimes the personality traits
that would lead you to want to be a cop
or sometimes the same personality traits
that would lead you to want to be a
criminal yeah it doesn't always overlap
it usually doesn't but sometimes
it does like enough to be
alarming they were recruiting them same
cops from javerville projects
that's what i'm saying yeah so we got to
watch yeah
i mean [ __ ] i've had numerous people
because you know like i said i'm i'm a
girl and i used to work at night so i'd
walk i would drive home alone at night
and i've had numerous people like even
if a cop like tries to pull you over
don't [ __ ]
pull over if you're by yourself or at
least pull over in front of somewhere
where there's lots of people because you
don't know one you don't know if that's
a real cop or two even if it's a real
cop you know that might be a bad they
could still like [ __ ] be a rapist yeah
or a murderer i was talking to my friend
tom my friend rob levinson he's from new
york can't trust nobody he's up in new
york and his solution is always take
away guns and [ __ ] add more cops you
don't know the south
you don't know the south at all so i can
uh just because somebody's a government
official that doesn't mean [ __ ]
i'm honestly not like no offense but i'm
not
not a big fan of cops
not a big fan well you know i've not
i've got friends that are cops i do too
but i got friends that are drug dealers
too
exactly you know what i mean i'm just
saying
individual yeah you know yeah
[ __ ] uh i i don't
it depends on the man and this is what
i'm talking about
i like to refer to things that people
understand real well go back to star
wars right han solo was a drug dealer
he wasn't a bad guy but he shot first he
killed greedo
okay but he was still a cool dude he did
the right thing and a lot in the long
run and everybody liked him okay
everything morality is situational okay
some people can come up out of that
situation and
and still be a good person as long as
your heart's in the right they didn't
choose to be born in the [ __ ]
situation that they were in and they
didn't choose to have
the same obstacles and the you know i
mean they didn't choose maybe
not having the [ __ ] being born with
the [ __ ] brightest of [ __ ] parents
you know i mean it's just
you have to come up somehow
well that's kind of like why
that's why i'm interested in true crime
i think because
you know while you can't excuse what
people like that do
i'm interested in like the mitigating
circumstances because the thing about it
is that sometimes like people have
horrible horrible [ __ ] upbringings
and i don't think that excuses [ __ ] you
do when you're adult because when you're
an adult unless you're impaired somehow
um
you probably do have some idea of what
is expected of you and like yeah let's
not do this because it's wrong even if
you only think oh it's wrong because
i'll get in trouble
which is very low level thinking but
okay um even if you have that but i kind
of feel like some people don't even have
that so i'm like really kind of
interested in
i don't know so that that's why i kind
of feel like
a lot of people get frustrated with
justice systems as a whole
but in a way they have to be as complex
as they are because every single case is
different
every single person is different you
don't know what that person's uh
background was like you don't know what
that person's genetics are like you
don't know that's why i don't believe in
either three strikes your outlaw good
thing that they got rid of that they
need to get rid of the mandatory
minimums you need to give the power
because everyone's it's you have to take
it on a case by i know it takes longer i
know but it's like you really have to
every single person that's a person you
got to give the choice back to a judge
you have to see that person you have to
take all the [ __ ] in the aggregate right
what was this person's background like
what were their what are their genetics
like what is their risk to re-offend
yeah this and that and the other you
can't just getting circumstances you
can't just like go right across the
board and say oh well okay like three
strikes yeah i was not a big fan of that
because that just seems like
well guess who was who i guess was the
main one behind that i know joe biden
well that was clinton mostly yeah it's
all both of them they were but i didn't
like that it was about money but see the
thing about it is like he wanted to look
like oh i'm tough on crime it's like
look that's not like the way to go about
it and like look i'm a liberal i'm a
democrat okay but it's like i did not
like that at all because i was like look
you're trying to like
put a one-size-fits-all solution on
something that is not one size fits all
every single situation is different and
i'm sorry that it takes a long time uh
you know that sucks and i know people
get frustrated but you really have to
take everything
as its own thing this is a a person this
is a person that is not like any other
person you have to like look at all of
the circumstances surrounding this
person before you decide
what your
you know judgment is gonna be on this
person you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
just like i'm a big advocate of that
like i said i know it takes forever and
i know people get frustrated and people
like yeah just hang the [ __ ] whatever
but it's like i you know you can't do
that you can't do that i know it's
frustrating i get frustrated but you
can't do that
i mean if you want to be like a person
i'm just saying
so uh
okay so we've had some people show up
um
jenny do they bury people standing up in
new orleans like in china and japanese
no no i don't think so i mean now they
bury people above ground but you can't
bury anybody because of the water table
i mean to be honest though in normal in
in in it
in modern days
new orleans mississippi
alabama most people are cremated
it's just so much which i'm kind of like
i'm a big fan of that because it's just
kind of marion people's very retro i
mean it's just seems so wasteful
like i know that look i get it like i
get the emotional attachment you don't
want to like yeah
but
i would never want to be buried
you watch it that's still like so weird
i want to remember me the way i was burn
me
just hand over some ashes
remember me like i'm dead i don't care i
don't want anybody to look at my [ __ ]
dead body
yeah that's kind of embarrassing
yeah that's what i always thought yeah
just like i don't have any control over
that [ __ ] it's like ew
well the romans thought the same thing
i'm not in there anymore romans started
burying people
later on but they they mostly cremated
that seems to me like i said and i'm not
like [ __ ] if other people have other
things that's fine
just try it destroy it
like i said i'm not in there anymore so
do whatever you want with this [ __ ] it's
going to be old and or honestly anyway
well i'm an organ donor so it's all my
driver's license and everything so it's
like if somebody needs a [ __ ] heart
or a liver
hopefully you don't need a liver because
i'm sure my liver is going to be [ __ ]
up by the time by that but you know what
i mean if you need something and it's
still like working uh you can have it
you're welcome to it uh fine but other
than that i don't like like i said i'm
not in there anymore so i don't really
understand like why you would like keep
that around okay like weird all right we
got a lot of people in there we gotta go
ahead and get this show okay so yeah
because i was trying to point like i was
like look at that's yeah i know look
look look yeah we're just starting this
people but we're just trying to give you
some background and people are partying
at the house anyway so i mean you know
yeah i do the same thing i lay down and
listen to my [ __ ] put my earbuds in
listen to [ __ ] talk on youtube
all day too i understand
i love it you know but
better than television
well you know yeah you find people you
like and you just want to listen to them
like talk all the time because i do that
too i don't i don't understand why
anybody would want to listen to us talk
but okay i don't understand why people
watch want to watch television i'm
looking at that [ __ ] in the map i can't
watch that [ __ ] there watch that [ __ ]
the biker bars look at their mouths
hanging open and i'm going said
watch any youtube shows and like huh
what's that don't even [ __ ] know they
got oh some of these old people are
still in the [ __ ] 1990s
that's crazy watching television and
it's gotten stupider
everything is almost kind of like
america's funniest home videos they just
different spin on that just dumb dumb
shit's on there now
yeah but people like dumb [ __ ] yeah
okay much to my sugar
john smith says on the theme of the
evening donate your body to science yeah
you probably should i mean
at least be useful in your burn that
[ __ ] up like i said well no that's why
like i said i'm an organ donor like like
i said if my [ __ ] is still working
take it
if it's still working take it we're
talking about i think most people in
their 20s that are [ __ ] that they
take the organs out of well it depends
if your shit's still working they'll
take it they'll take it they'll put it
in an old person maybe yeah that's what
i'm saying and i'm just like look i'm
not using it just you're welcome to it
that's fine
um honestly i went to see do you
remember when they did the bodies
exhibition uh toured around the u.s with
the um the kind of plasticine
bodies that they did that was in [ __ ]
casino royale yeah
i saw it when it was in um tampa yeah
and that was amazing oh it was so
awesome i like bought the book and
everything and when i was there i was
thinking to myself how [ __ ] cool
would it be
to have your [ __ ] body like to them
to like to peel all your flesh off and
like to because they had them like in
all action pose them like that that is
so cool now danny goes face comes in he
goes he's he's [ __ ] doing a real
[ __ ] shout out to the past
like an hour ago
to jesse eisenberg's best film was
totally american ultra based on the cia
mko ultra sleeper oh i haven't seen that
i haven't seen it okay oh [ __ ] oh cam
guy just sent us ten bucks thanks
[ __ ] thank you thank you thank you
happy summer solstice yesterday yeah
it's officially summer now my least
favorite
season yeah
next actually spring and summer there's
only a couple more months contention
it's only a couple more months i only
like fall and winter
i don't like the eggs it goes by fast
i know yeah it goes by fast couple
that's what that's one of the nicer
things about getting older is that
everything goes by really fast i'm like
oh i hate summer but it'll probably be
like over before i know it yeah yeah
lin uh sly says me too jenny i'm an
organ donor i'm a texas star yeah me too
i was just kind of like i'm not using
the [ __ ] i don't i don't understand like
why anybody would be like weird about
that but
if you are i'm not like i'm not hating
i'm just saying i don't understand why
you move it you're not using it give it
to somebody that can use it
so uh okay so we barely got into this
[ __ ] we were just talking about bodies
and then we got off yeah
i know
so yeah track and side tracking like
crazy i know why did we beat the
pookie's board even yeah he's like i'm
like still here [ __ ] snoring slowing
logs it's gonna be okay poovey look he
just said the chairs like [ __ ] all this
[ __ ]
you guys talk too much yeah that's
probably what she's thinking but yeah so
yeah so edinburgh was one of like three
major centers for
anatomy so like all the people coming
there and so there was because there was
a shortage in bodies to use for
dissection purposes
um as you might imagine the free market
kind of came to the rescue if you want
to call it that uh and people started
robbing graves
so you know it was that because that's
what would happen
people needed money and they're kind of
like hey
people need money i need money
and anatomists need bodies therefore
i'm gonna go to the cemetery and dig
that [ __ ] up that just got buried damn
gonna sell it to the [ __ ] so that was
what was happening
uh so there was like a whole brisk trade
in the [ __ ] they even had a name for
them resurrection men or
resurrectionists
which i kind of love
so there was that so there was like a
whole thing in it uh the whole trade
now
the thing about it this was kind of like
an awkward situation because at this
time in scottish law
disturbing a grave
was
illegal it wasn't like a big deal but it
was like a little bit illegal
uh if you took
property from a dead person like if you
stole rings or something off a dead body
that was also illegal but stealing the
body itself
technically was not illegal
so they were kind of like skirting
around the law there
because they figured hey nobody wants
the wants the body because no one owned
it so nobody really thought to like make
a law to make that illegal
you know what i'm saying yeah now so
uh so obviously they were taking
advantage of this [ __ ] now the going
price
back then
uh kind of fluctuated depending on what
season it was obviously if it was
summertime
um when you know your body would rot
quicker yeah
uh bodies we're not in season man their
bodies running they're wearing the
season you had to get rid of them quick
yeah
i don't mean to be like disrespectful
but i have like a terrible terrible like
morbid sense of humor remember this is
pre-refrigeration yeah okay i mean that
yeah you couldn't really like it was
[ __ ] hard
yeah and we'll just sell it later yeah
that's not going to happen they didn't
have that back she just starts stinking
fast this is early 19th century yeah
so during the summer you could get eight
pounds now back then
that was a pretty hefty sum gonna say
um you know because i mean but you'd
only get eight pounds because it's like
well you have to sell it like pretty
much right away because otherwise the
[ __ ] would rot and it wouldn't be any
good uh so you had to do that in the
winter you could get 10 pounds though
because obviously it was really cold
this is scotland it gets really cold
there and uh you could kind of like just
lay it out in the snow
and uh
preserve it for longer so you know what
i mean and uh consequently the
anatomists did more dissections during
the winter because you know they had
more fresh bodies because [ __ ] was
frozen because it was [ __ ] cold out
now during the 1820s uh people in
edinburgh were kind of like [ __ ]
goddamn like we're just like burying
grandma or whatever and then like a
couple hours later some [ __ ] come
along and like dig her up and sell her
to like somebody and people were
obviously like upset about that so there
were a lot of protests
so uh just like we mentioned very very a
long time ago on our buried live show
this kind of led to
a lot of stuff happening and you can
kind of still see it in some edinboro
cemeteries nowadays although some of it
has you know kind of rotted away and
stuff but
people would put what they called uh
mort safes like over like you bury your
relative and then you put like and it's
kind of it's essentially like a cage
you'd put like this iron
wrought iron cage like over the [ __ ]
with like the gravestone on it
i've seen like pictures of it and there
are some that are still like that
they're like they were trying to like
deter
grave robbers from coming and like
taking their relatives because that's
[ __ ] up uh also a lot of cemeteries
and you can still see this because they
still exist nowadays they would put in
like watchtowers uh at cemeteries where
like they'd have a guard like 24 7 like
watching out for the graves looking out
for grave robbers it was that much of a
problem that they were spending all that
money to [ __ ] do that because like i
said as soon as you buried somebody some
[ __ ] was gonna come in there and take
that body and like sell it because you
can make money on that stuff like i said
eight pounds ten pounds that was a lot
of money for poor people back then
um so yeah
now the thing about it so because there
was such a
crisis um
you know this was like a whole thing and
so into this kind of uh
whole thing that was happening
let's talk a little bit about
dr robert knox
now
spoiler alert this guy didn't really get
in super trouble but
he's very very important in the whole
broken hair situation
so he's an anatomist
and he had actually qualified as a
doctor in 1814
now he had gotten smallpox as a child as
i'm sure a lot of people did back in
this era because
man smallpox was the whole thing and
actually uh this is a little bit of
sidetrack but if you haven't read
i read this great book called uh i think
it was called the speckled monster and
it was about
the way that they found the vaccine for
smallpox it's so so good that's like one
of the best books of best nonfiction
books i've ever read so i'm recommending
that right now so he got smallpox as a
child
uh so and he got like uh disfigured and
he was like blind in one eye but he kind
of rose above i guess and he became like
an anatomy slater
uh he was even uh in the army he was a
doctor at the battle of waterloo and
he was in england he was in south africa
so he was like kind of a big deal
now he settles down in edinburgh in 1820
1825 he becomes a fellow of the royal
college of surgeons of edinburgh and he
was like one of their main attractions
for lecturing on anatomy he would do two
dissections a day
and he put out ads like i've seen
pictures of them if you google it you
can like see the actual ads from the day
uh where he'd be like hey
i have fresh ass corpses i didn't say
that exactly but you know what i mean he
had fresh corpses that was one of his
main like selling points and i'm going
to cut him up in front of all of y'all
uh two times a day yeah then there's a
[ __ ] all of y'all i am southern
i know it's funny
i am southern i'm just easier i'm
actually southern you have any you were
born in california i was born yeah but
of southern parents i know that and then
i and then yeah i have some parents i am
great i am a child of the south
southern grandparents
my grandparents i came here every summer
of my life though
i lived here every day yeah and every
winter uh you know it wasn't until after
i i didn't i didn't really live
live here
all the time 24 7 until 1980
yeah i lived here 87 88
89
and 89 i joined the army
i was born in
daytona beach florida halifax hospital
as soon as we went to war with iraq i
joined the army for the first day for
the first gulf war that's when i joined
i was like oh this is it this is it
time for me to go i'm going to the big
game
[ __ ] join the [ __ ]
infantry
wanted to go to theater and this is not
shut that off you got to go to korea
first in the 506 up on dmz
but i'm glad that i did that i'm glad
i'm glad they sent me there instead that
was like a ranger battalion [ __ ] man
awesome unit
still talk even talk to my old [ __ ]
c.o
and he said yeah that was the [ __ ]
toughest unit i was ever in it was
[ __ ]
as hard as a [ __ ] it was like being a
bad boy to me uh some of you army guys
know what i'm talking about the ranger
battalion it's like that all our ncos
were rage or qualified so they just ran
it like a ranger potato
and there was only one battalion of us
we're the dmz battalion
506.
john smith says in scotland it is
assumed you're an organ donor unless you
have a specific exemption card
honestly um i think that they should do
an opt-out
rather than an opt-in
to be honest with you well they consider
your body to be i mean you're a property
and a property or a family right but
you're dead they don't want to be
stealing nothing from you though
you're dead they don't want to they do
enough [ __ ] to your live body while
you're still alive it's like i don't
know why they still have this weird like
thing about you being dead you're dead
it wouldn't matter it wouldn't make a
big impact here in the united states
anyway i mean i'm just saying i think it
should be opt out rather than often if
you want to opt out you can but
i opted in i was just kind of like i
don't need my [ __ ] kidneys or
whatever like if they're still working
god forbid like you know if i'm in an
accident or something they'll like have
them you know it's a big place
most places are rural here
when you die
on average they don't want your [ __ ]
you're old okay if you're young and
you're in a rural zone
they take a organ out of you there's no
there's no place
they're not doing organ transplants in
rural areas what are they gonna do send
a [ __ ] to new york they got [ __ ] over
there new york [ __ ] you know well
because it's not the same i mean there's
big cities that have that and
even in rural areas yeah but a city can
fuel its own organ demands not
necessarily
they always they always have shortages
i'm gonna put this my way i don't want
no damn yankee running around with my
[ __ ] kidneys man
you'll be dead what the [ __ ] do you care
no i ain't helping them
well yeah but you're a sociopath
i'm taking them with me
let me be good that's stupid as [ __ ] i'm
just telling you that it is stupid let
me go let me go
that is stupid [ __ ] seriously honestly
like i kind of feel like
like i said i'm dead
look if my kidney could like help some
kid somewhere or some person like what
the [ __ ] do i need it anymore i don't
need it jesus
so take it
i'm fine with it i don't know
um yeah but like i said i kind of feel
like it should be opt out rather than
opt-in like i said you have a choice
still but
like i said you're dead you don't need
that [ __ ]
i know it's the really the only i kind
of feel like the only
objections to it are weird like
religious objections
yeah and i get you don't want your like
loved one's body to file i get that i do
but a lot of that is like superstition
or like religious kind of stuff and it's
like i'm not really into that i'm just
kind of like i'm a very practical person
um you know somebody alive a kid or
something like that could use that so
i don't need it please take it i'm just
i'm not like greedy like that
and i just like i said i'm dead so who
the [ __ ] do i care like who gets it i
don't i don't care who gets it it's fine
but yeah so he does two dissections that
which is kind of like a big that's like
a big deal now that i'm thinking about
it two dissections a day that's a lot of
bodies because he wasn't the only [ __ ]
doing that there was like a bunch of
other not just in edinburgh because it
was a bunch of [ __ ] doing it at that
college too but like
every medical college
throughout europe
also had bodies so the fact that he was
doing two bodies a day that's a lot of
like bodies so i'm put some more eyes on
this for you so i'm seeing how the
shortage could like uh you know be kind
of a big thing that ice maker is keeping
up and i love it you want any more vodka
in this
sure why not okay
so yeah so his ads like i said if you
look on google you can see them um
[Music]
his ads promised
a full demonstration on fresh
anatomical subjects so everybody come
and look at that [ __ ]
um and at times they would get like more
than 400
students i kind of feel like maybe they
weren't all necessarily students i feel
like some of them were probably just
like weirdos that wanted to just like
come see a dead body cut apart but you
know they didn't have a lot of
entertainment options back then so i'm
not going to lay too hard
so
that's dr knox and we'll get back into
him
in a little bit because he was the one
that
bought all the bodies
spoiler alert
but
let's talk about the guys that actually
did the killing
so let's talk about william burke
now
i don't know if this matters or not but
both of these guys even though this was
scotland both of these guys were irish
immigrants and i'm sure like the scots
would be like yeah that totally makes a
difference like [ __ ] irish
[ __ ] come up here and do this
[ __ ] i kind of feel like well i don't
understand it
look i lived in wales
the welsh hated the english even though
it was literally right there it's across
the severn river
it's right there
english [ __ ]
and the english also hated the welsh
it's just sheepshead just like it's just
like here
like i mean it's kind of like here it's
like from street
yeah it's not quite as bad it's not
quite as bad
i mean we at least have like chunks of
states that are kind of like kind of
like our own areas but the thing about
it is that
within those states like within florida
within you know you have like a panoply
of like whole different like uh
attitudes yeah yeah that might be god
miami things get things get painted with
a broad but like oh this and that but
there's a lot of science there's a lot
of different styles of different stuff
yeah you know if like you go south
florida is central america
and that's a good thing it's like a
central american [ __ ] paradise yeah
it's okay with me [ __ ] great yeah
they're they're running it good and
they've been there for [ __ ] centuries
they predate the united states as their
homeland and [ __ ] they treat it like
their homeland you respect it
and they're floridians just like us we
all get along
we all enter mary
you know we show you our friends from
the clubs here and we're in the center
between the panhandle and south florida
and we're all mixing around this area
and you look at the people people go to
club with and
you're not sure if they're
anglo or hispanic it doesn't matter
that didn't [ __ ] matter i mean
orlando is kind of like
as long as they're hot if they're hot
they're not there we're good to go
orlando is kind of like a waste station
because it's not just south florida
north florida orlando has people from
everywhere yeah you got tourists and you
got people that have moved here
and like yeah [ __ ] tons of people moved
to a lot of our friends are from new
york
i mean a lot of people from new york
well i told you i went to high school in
florida and i
me and one other girl that i knew were
the only people that were actually born
in florida everybody we knew was
from but let me everybody in our high
school was born somewhere else but
here's something that jenny doesn't
understand i've oh i don't understand
okay
i've been i've lived up north in boston
there i [ __ ] loved it had a good time
there
people move here
and they adapt to this culture it does
change them uh they become
like other people that you would meet in
florida
like little swell
little's a new yorker
but
he's been here for a long time and he's
not here he said he's upstate new york
yeah but he's just like any other
floridian
you know just in his opinions and
everything well like i said i don't
really even have a concept of floridian
because i don't think there's a
definition of that
because it's everybody here is from
somewhere else everybody's like from
everywhere so it's like i don't really
have like a
overriding
concept of like floridian
like i said no we're gonna talk about
floridian you might as well talk about
me i was born here yeah i was born in
florida yeah so it's like i'm more of
floridian than like some [ __ ] that
come down here like
i was born here if you were to go up
north and go to massachusetts you'd
stick out
you would
but you don't stick out here little
swole doesn't stick out here
okay well nobody sticks out because
everybody's
from somewhere else and everybody's
different and like nobody really like
thinks that he does [ __ ] here that
wouldn't fly in new york
could just you know he's carrying the
guns you know man he would it wouldn't
that wouldn't fly he comes down not in
new york
you know he's got a [ __ ] ccw and
[ __ ]
he's into country [ __ ] and [ __ ] goes
out there and [ __ ] catches frogs and
[ __ ] he's like an entomologist
and uh it's just
it's like he belongs here you know i
mean he's really into like frogs yeah
but i don't think that's a specifically
southern thing
i don't think
that but i'm that particular well that
particular thing there's just things
about him that he does here that
wouldn't fly in new york
hi
um
where was i oh sly says jenny i missed
that body exhibition in tampa florida
too far drive from orlando i mean i went
over well i lived in tampa at the time
and it was at our local museum
what is it the south florida
southward museum but like they had that
whole thing and man it was like so good
i'm sorry you missed it because man it
was fantastic i was like really really
into it i love that kind of [ __ ] rebecca
says never be ashamed of our dark sense
of humor it's the only humor i vibe with
yeah i mean you know
i don't like i said i don't mean to make
light of
terrible things but
i kind of feel like that's kind of
healthy in a way grab this showed up
what's up graham
yeah
grantham says by the way granthar's wife
and kids
went to wait you didn't go went to
disney in harry potter world last month
credit card bill came today seven grand
yeah i feel pretty quick
i can say hotter world that's not in
disney that's in uh
universal right
yeah but i mean it's all kind of like
it's in the disney area because yeah
you can you can go ahead and agree with
me like you always do all right now i'm
just [ __ ]
but uh
disney ain't worth a [ __ ] man compared
to orland uh [ __ ] universal
the intervals of studios man [ __ ] got
got disney over the [ __ ] barrel
i've been doing both in connor within a
decade or so and [ __ ] how long ago
was that we went to a long time ago it
was about ten it was it was 2011 or
2012. okay so yeah within 10 years
uh we saw that harry potter harry potter
ride man [ __ ] that thing was awesome
and the uh the roller coasters that they
had there i much preferred universal to
uh to disney the only thing i liked
about disney is the haunted house and
space mountain
other than that i really don't give a
[ __ ] about footage i also like thunder
mountain railroad well the thing about
disney is that i'd like a [ __ ]
universal is better i like their
commitment to
theming
um
haunted mansion is my favorite but i
like
that they do like the whole experience
but universal if you just want like
rides and like immersive it is
better it's better but we haven't been
like for a while we need to go to
universal but i well i can't afford that
[ __ ]
cost us what 200 probably 300 jesus
christ where have you been well it's 100
to get in right
yeah but then like all of the other
i mean maybe it wouldn't be that much
yeah
it'd be it'd be about
300 between 150 a piece that's not bad
john smith says when i was a kid my
favorite was epcot yeah i was that kind
of kid epcot
when i was in fifth
grade
fifth grade when would that have been
uh when i was 11 so that had been
1983 1984
epcot had just opened yeah and we went
on a field trip there i loved epcot yeah
i mean we had the best [ __ ] time
there graham this is a 12 ball of coke
there
and she and he said that his kids were
underwhelmed by disney they
disney ain't [ __ ] well they haven't kept
up like they have kept cheap looking but
they can't keep up with
i mean it's orlando
so you have like tons of other
big like universal you have like
other big yeah parks yeah so you have a
lot of competition there's a lot of [ __ ]
people don't know about disney
disney is a vast empire and a lot of it
has failed they used to have cruises
they used to have a bunch of islands
that went off out into the ocean that
you could go out on doesn't still have
those no it's all shut down didn't work
um they just they ended up losing money
it it tried to almost become its own
country
but it just never was
adult enough it was never cool enough
it wasn't high tech enough
they never kept up with the [ __ ] with
sun fade like crazy florida shit's got
to be repainted every year if it looks
like that yeah especially if it's red
it's red yeah it's just it
no
you can't just rest back on your laurels
they were trying to really make money
off of hotels because that's where the
money was their money was coming from
the hotels
not so much the theme park
i mean my hat i have to say my sister
who's four years younger than me
she comes down she doesn't live here
anymore
she lives in atlanta she's lived all
over the country but she comes down
every year
and she does like a big disney vacation
because she loves that [ __ ] she stays in
the hotels she like does all the stuff
and
it's so she has a good time doing that
stuff but
man the thing about disney is that you
really have to
and i guess this is like a tribute to
its popularity because she's like dude
you have to like book your
restaurant bookings and like oh if you
want to like be in the mansion like or
the castle with cinderella or whatever
you have to like book that like month
and month and months ahead because it's
like way overbooked so people are still
doing it
that was
i i heard that that the park sales are
down a lot and
well that's probably yeah they tried the
star wars angle that didn't work
[ __ ] um that that ev that that part
of the theme theme park isn't working
it's
they this the star wars angle was
supposed to compete with universal
because they needed something that was
more contemporary people don't realize
how old-fashioned disney is the look of
it there are some things i still like
about it there's classic [ __ ] like like
i said in a small world and stuff like
that but i will write [ __ ] puppets i
mean i will ride on the honda mansion
yeah yeah
i love that [ __ ] a dollar for dollar if
you're a tourist go to universal
universal studios
is better
better rides higher technology stuff
[ __ ] more adult themed type stuff
the family
more the family tends to like it better
you don't have disney princesses for
little girls you got hot chicks running
around and [ __ ] marvel superhero
outfits with dudes that are [ __ ]
roided out so there's more it's sexier
i'm gonna say
and some of them [ __ ]
marvel chicks are friends of ours you
know that worked at those theme parks
doing it you know and [ __ ] and
it's it's a wild scene you know it i'm
not gonna say it's it's not like
it's not so adult that's porn i'm just
saying it's it's pg instead of g rated
you know and it's
the rides are just a lot more exciting
the broomstick ride they're [ __ ] the
harry potter things a virtual reality
ride
man
and tom has not read any of the books i
don't know anything i don't give a [ __ ]
about any of that all right i just went
on the harry potter broomstick ride and
i bought that [ __ ]
i felt like i was riding on a [ __ ]
broomstick
flying through the air at about 150
miles an hour some of that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] faster than free fall and you
know what it was all vr
yeah it was all virtual reality you're
not moving fast at all but it convinces
you that you are moving fast and flying
i [ __ ]
love they know they play with your brain
they [ __ ] my mind up and i was like oh
yeah i want to go on that [ __ ] again but
[ __ ]
tyson was with us and he's like nah man
we got to do the next one he [ __ ]
every ride was good every ride is real
good
i mean better versus universal is fun
i would say i do have a soft spot for
disney though for you californians
because i grew up i have more fun at
universal studios then i had an old
1970s magic mountain and 1970s 1980s
magic mount was hardcore you could get
killed there
you could [ __ ]
those roller coasters just fall apart
over there you know that happened
[ __ ] a couple times but and [ __ ]
it was
in magic mountain was the [ __ ] in those
days
it was
like something out of [ __ ] old
rollerball movie
but that's
that's kind of how
were getting way off [ __ ] topic yeah
uh yeah okay we gotta get back this
is we you're getting way up this [ __ ]
okay
i wanna say if you're gonna come here if
you're gonna come here for tourism if
you're foreign
no man you want to go to universal [ __ ]
disney
universal
fun day says what about jesus land
i mean we would love to see it if you
want to pay like if i could go there for
free yeah
i would be intrigued i'm not going to
pick it's little it's it's not as big as
you it's little i'm not paying this
little come on i would like to go just
to for shits and giggles it'd be it'd be
funny to see
but
i don't think they're on top
i know they're not on their game i think
i would probably get like [ __ ]
crucified because of my eye rolling
they would they would [ __ ] i was like
it's a low budget [ __ ] theme park
it's very low budget
okay
well their whole thing but they probably
want a hundred dollars a person so
you're like why would you go with that
i'm sure when you could just go to
[ __ ]
universal for that go to somewhere good
that's not like lame yeah come on
uh john smith says we also went to a now
closed down theme park called boardwalk
and baseball oh my god
i remember boardwalking baseball
baseball theme park
i think
um
i never went there but i remember when
it opened yeah i think they might have
please correct me if i'm wrong
i think they might have opened that on
the site of the old circus world which i
actually did go to
i did go to old circus what was the
theme park with the circus theme
so i like rode an elephant there and
[ __ ] like that but i think later on like
after that closed they opened it as they
were trying to like do a baseball themed
and i was just like what the [ __ ] is
that about so i think that's what that
was it's not there anymore i don't even
think anybody here remembers it but i
remember i remember
is there a greater misery says granthars
than a week on a disney cruise honestly
any cruise
i'm not a cruise person
like i get the appeal of it
but
it's like hey let's hang out on the
ocean in the middle of nowhere
for all this time and then we'll
occasionally like stop by some land that
we can like do some [ __ ] on
i don't know man i'm i'm just not into
it
i'm not into it and maybe the cruise
ship will like have their all their
toilets back up and everything will be
like [ __ ] covered in sewage
you know yeah
it might happen like that i'm just
waiting for a date universal is owned by
disney which is owned by amazon which is
owned by a poor mug which is owned by
has that not happened yet yeah yeah i
mean uh yeah i kind of feel like that
will probably happen at some point
[ __ ] disney isn't doing well on the
stock market
but uh
a lot of it because all that money that
they sunk is sunk into disney plus that
they were
really thinking that that was going to
take off but then they just [ __ ] up
the star wars franchise
uh did and you know remember our friends
that worked for disney who's laughed and
was pissed off
that's that's that disney got star wars
he says they will never [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] right he called it
what's her name's ex-husband
[ __ ] uh
you're talking about years back
she was minnie mouse
tracy tracy tracy's husband tracy was a
minnie mouse tracy's husband yeah
tracy's ex-husband guy he was a mechanic
there at star wars yeah yeah yeah and
and [ __ ] when they bought star wars
he was like oh [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ]
that up and i said yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] that up because yeah they will [ __ ]
star wars up and i said disney can't do
star wars he goes hell no they can't do
star wars
this is why couldn't they because you
don't know him like i know
and he worked there in that corporation
and they did they [ __ ] up star wars
all the
[ __ ] although mandalorian one and two
was good [ __ ] you know some of the
movies were really good but
obi-wan it came out everything they
[ __ ] that up they're just they're not
very creative and they're just
which is strange because they handled
the mcu well okay look we got to get
back on top
yeah you're you're trying to just tell
by the way she's sitting thomas okay
you're really trying by patient all
right
two hours okay i'm just kind of like i
haven't even look okay look where the
thing is okay it's like right there not
even a quarter you're trying to keep me
on control you have a sidetrack show i
started the sidetrack show specifically
so you could just talk about [ __ ]
the whole time yeah but here's here's
the thing they don't [ __ ] get me
going on side tracks though they don't
get me going on oh you're blaming others
i'm blaming him he's bleeding blaming
them
grantor says what are the workers that
jesus land dress up as israelites it's a
sidetrack we can't talk about that
that's i mean they probably do yeah i
kind of want to go but i don't want to
pay yeah
that's a side track we can't get on it
so where was i why didn't we get into
this [ __ ] i don't know
you don't count you don't care you don't
really know
it's right there it's right there you
should have done some research on your
no i know about this one i know about
this one no you don't yeah no you don't
we've already covered this guy i
remember what they did
mostly mostly rebecca says rogue one was
brilliant it was actually you're getting
sidetracked
no i'm just like i'm trying to like
don't worry about people's questions
all right so we're talking about broken
arms yeah
so i kind of like gave a little bit of a
context
so
people are robbing graves left and right
because
they need some bodies and you know
there's money to be made so people are
doing that
so into this uh morass if you want to
call it that
steps broken hair now william burke
uh born probably 1792
in uh ireland like i said both these
[ __ ] were iron
i'm not saying anything about that but
they're both irish
now he had like an okay upbringing like
his parents were like middle class he
wasn't poor or anything like that
uh he had a brother named constantine
they had a very comfortable upbringing
and they were both in the british army
they joined as teenagers
uh
and in fact william burke actually was
in a militia
until he married a woman uh another
irish woman
uh where they kind of settled county uh
mayo mile i'm not really sure like i'm
not from ireland so i don't know
now what happened with that though 1918
he has a big fight with his
father-in-law over some land dispute or
some [ __ ] like that
so he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out of
here
he leaves his wife and presumably
children because i think he had children
as well he's like yeah i'm out of here
so he left
he just like abandoned them
so he moved to scotland
and uh started working just like as a
laborer right uh he was actually like uh
one of the laborers what they called
like uh i think they called nabbies like
on the irish uh union canal
so he first moved to a little place
called madison near falkirk and then a
set up house with a woman who
i don't think he ever officially married
so we're just gonna like call him uh
call her the girlfriend her name was
helen mcdougall now she was also irish
uh she was a little bit of um
i don't want to say like she had a
little bit of a bad reputation let's say
that she didn't she's a help
i don't know if i'd go that far okay but
people thought she was kind of like a
drunk
and she didn't have the greatest
reputation around town but he kind of
like took up with her like i said i
don't think he ever married her like
legally or anything
but they kind of like became a thing and
he would like claim her as a wife later
on
but i don't think they ever actually
married
so
uh after a couple of years uh he worked
on the you know on this canal and after
that was done
he moved to uh edinburgh and he moved to
this place called tanner's clothes it's
actually not there anymore it's been
torn down
um you know obviously the area is still
there but it doesn't look like it used
to look so
he moved there with her in november of
1827
and they started doing a thing called
what they would do was they would buy
second-hand clothing from apparently
people who died or were selling stuff
and then they would sell it on so it was
like a thrift store essentially is what
they were doing
uh and also later he would become a
cobbler like he would fix people's shoes
and stuff like that
and he actually was kind of good at it
uh earning about a pound a week which i
don't know how much that is in today's
money but was probably
better than most people were making like
the 1820s yeah so not bad maybe 200
bucks a week i mean not great but still
not bad so he's like fixing people's
shoes that's upper middle class
so
from
everything from everything that they
have about him william burke
was
the kind of more
sociable of the two uh he was very
socially adept he was very
uh he was a hard worker he was very
cheerful he was very he was easy to make
friends like stuff like that he was like
a dude you want to hang out with that
kind that type of guy
um you know singing dancing doing that
kind of stuff so he was very popular
like in the neighborhood fixing people's
shoes and whatnot
now the other guy william hare
uh they don't know a great deal about
his background uh maybe
from
uh county oh gosh armag arm
i guess i don't know i'm sure i'm
pronouncing that super long super wrong
uh they don't know when he was born
exactly so they don't actually know how
old he was
when he was arrested in 1828 he actually
gave his
ages 21 but they don't actually know if
that was accurate so i've seen birth
dates ranging from 1792 to 1804 so take
that as you will
they don't know much about his
background now he did work in ireland uh
as kind of he worked on farms and [ __ ]
like that like agricultural kind of
stuff
he also worked on the union canal which
is where he met burke
uh he worked there for seven years he
moved to edinburgh in the in the mid
1820s
and he worked as an assistant to a coal
man coal guy i guess like a cold
shoveler i don't know
like i said like all the jobs back then
like we don't have those jobs anymore so
it's like nobody actually knows what
those are it's funny
it is like and it's weird i was watching
like an earlier like a video about this
earlier and he's just like every single
job in this i don't even know what the
[ __ ] that is gone long gone like nobody
does that the jobs we're doing now won't
exist in the future they're just
temporary
well you know what i mean
the two main jobs throughout human
history have been soldier and hooker
those are the two [ __ ] names i mean
pretty much those are the only thing
that like people like still understand
like nowadays like every now and then
like you hear some job it's like what
the [ __ ] because every night like i look
up stuff
because i do a lot of like true crime
stuff and like all this kind of stuff
from like the 18th century 19th century
and like you look up oh this person was
a whatever and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah dudes
like look it up dudes they made the
bands on the barrels well that was a big
deal back then you needed barrels yeah
you know what i mean yeah
so there was that
so he had actually like worked like i
said as a laborer on the union canal
seven years he moved to edinburgh and
then he worked as the coleman's
assistant he moved into tanner's clothes
which was the same street
that um
you know that burke lived in
now he moved into like a boarding house
and the boarding house was owned by a
guy named luge
and his wife his name was margaret
now the dude died
in 1826
at this point william hare sees an
opportunity and moves in on the wife hey
margaret what's up i hear your uh
husband's dead
so you might need a new man so that
evidently worked out
so
the thing about hair though it's like
these two
burke well like i said was very socially
adapted he seemed very intelligent very
cunning
hair on the other hand was kind of like
a brute
uh he was illiterate very uncouth that
was one word that uh people at the time
used to describe him so he was kind of
like a big dumb
dude defarted and sucked on his teeth
and put yeah that kind of lick on his
fingers and touch your food and [ __ ]
that kind of dude yeah he was just yeah
so
these two a match made in heaven i guess
you could say they were very very
different
uh also he would like get in fights he
would get drunk and like beat people up
stuff like that he was very like violent
very
he would start fights yeah
um also his girlfriend
a lot of sources call him the wife but i
don't think they ever legally married so
i guess she was just like kind of caught
a law yeah kind of late or maybe
commonwealth i don't know what the wheel
what the law was back then
but um i love this
that uh a contemporary source called her
heart featured and debauched
that means written hard and put away wet
prince
she didn't have like the best reputation
at the time and he was like oh my people
and he just like graduated like like
gravitated to her
so yeah that's how that happened
so uh so basically 1827 uh burke and his
girlfriend helen mcdougall
they go to work on this harvest like i
said they're always looking for work and
then that's where they met william hare
now the two guys like struck up
struck up a friendship
now
so they go back to edinburgh and uh you
know william here was kind of like uh
you know we need a place to stay and
burke was like hey we have a boarding
house
or they kind of like move into the same
boarding house so that's kind of like
where the two couples kind of like
started hanging out now both of these
two couples like i said they were kind
of
dirt bags
um and their whole thing was like hey
we're gonna hang out and like just
[ __ ] get as drunk as [ __ ]
much like we're doing right now
and
whatever happens will happen
murder uh spoiler alert that's what
happened with this
but they kind of like got known for
being like big huge drinkers even in
scotland at that time which is probably
like a big that's you know that that's
saying something if you were known for
that
um and also being a little uh
boisterous i guess
boisterous let's call it that
now the first thing that happens this is
kind of what set them on this course
so in very late november of 1827
there's a dude named donald nobody knows
his last name he was just
sadly like a lot of their victims
of which there were many
um
were either they don't know their names
or they don't know their last names
because a lot of them were kind of like
itinerant or you know
they didn't so they don't really know a
lot about them which is kind of sad
but so there was this guy named donald
who was staying as a lodger in uh
william hare's house
he ended up dying of natural causes
of
dropsy
now dropsy
um
is what nowadays you would call edema
it's kind of like a swelling
of uh various appendages and stuff like
that which will kill you yeah fluid
retention is what that is
how does that start
what makes a [ __ ] retain flu um
i'm not actually sure i think there's a
lot of different because i kind of
looked it up for a second but yeah
there's a lot of different like
conditions i've seen people like that
they wear the damn [ __ ] like elastic
thing yeah keep the fluid out and you
know
they got to have take a bunch of piss
pills to piss out fluid
and then you're like well what the hell
does that start off in the beginning you
know anyway you know
well there's somebody kind of overweight
i noticed so i don't know if that's well
not necessarily because that could it
could kind of happen to anybody like
fluid retention in various parts of your
body like i said um but that's what they
used to call it dropsy but
it's called a demon elena's but that's
what it is
um so it could kill you
especially back then when like they
didn't know anything about like [ __ ]
medicine or anything
so
donald
dies of dropsy
uh in
william hare's champion says it's kidney
disease it doesn't okay
yeah okay good
gal congested heart failure too yeah
okay okay which was you know endemic
back then i kind of feel like oh did she
eat well yeah people were eating like
[ __ ] poison ass food yeah jesus
christ like seriously if we've been
watching um
the food that made america which it
doesn't go super into
like all the horrible [ __ ] that people
read it kind of like refers to it like
all the horrible [ __ ] that people were
eating like prior to the industrial
revolution
but
if you want to look into that it's fast
there's i've read a couple books about
it and it's like a fascinating topic
like before
the fda and all that stuff came in and
we're like uh no absolutely not we have
to like have some [ __ ] guidelines
with the [ __ ] and like some laws
um people were just eating all kind of
[ __ ] and they didn't like know what it
was and people were just getting disease
and it was awful it was awful
so people were dying of like completely
preventable [ __ ]
so
this dude
donald
like i said we don't know his last name
but he was just lodging in william
hare's boarding house
and he died
of natural causes as far as we know
but the thing about it was that when he
died he still owed four pounds of back
rent
so william hare is pissing and moaning
to
william burke
man this [ __ ] [ __ ] died and he still
owed me like all this money and back
rent
so what they decided to do well okay
well maybe we can recoup this loss we'll
like you know find a silver lining
you know in the in the storm cloud of
this like situation
will sell his body
to
an anatomist and maybe we'll make the
money back that's what they decided to
do so they didn't kill this dude he just
died naturally and that's where they got
the idea
so what they did though just to cover
their bases i'm assuming
so they had this carpenter that they
knew and the carpenter said okay well i
built he built them a coffin
and um the local parish because the guy
was like not he didn't have any
relatives or anything like that so the
local parish like paid for his burial
so they buried him in this wooden coffin
now after
the guy left
the you know broken hair come back
and they opened the coffin up they took
the body out which they stuffed under
the bed they weren't like master
criminals which you'll see
um and then they filled the coffin with
some other [ __ ] like it was heavy like
some little tanners like stuff because
you know they just put like a bunch of
[ __ ] in there so it would still be heavy
and then they filled it up with that and
they like resealed it because the coffin
had been sealed
now after
dark after the coffin had been taken
away to be buried
they took the body to
edinburgh university
now they were kind of like looking can
you imagine like putting a body in a
[ __ ] box or whatever and like going
to a medical school and being like hey
body who wants to buy money
that's essentially what they're doing a
sly is asking what's a drink drink of
choice in edinburgh at that time
probably yeah
i mean as far like from what i like the
research i did on this all the [ __ ]
drank whiskey whiskey whiskey well
scotch whiskey
that's kind of like their thing that's
kind of like their thing
so you know
but yeah so they go to the
they're shameless they go to the
university and they're like asking
around hey who wants to buy a body we
heard that you guys are looking for
bodies so we got one
right here in this box or whatever it
was
now
essentially what happened they go to
edinburgh university
and they actually wanted to go to kind
of like the main guy that was like the
big anatomist at the time whose name was
professor monroe
but what ended up happening was they ran
into this student like on a staircase
and they were kind of like um hey we
need we have a body to sell so what can
we do about that bundy said drambuie is
the [ __ ] oh maybe
[Laughter]
that's some fine [ __ ] there i haven't
had drambui in a long time that's like
[ __ ] liqueur of [ __ ] whiskey
remember
i used to drink it up in brazil that
[ __ ] was like gold in brazil when i was
good
i gotta get him i don't remember five
ever
it's a little thick it's a little sweet
but it's good it's good but yeah i mean
yeah
all right so
he talks to a student and the student
says
hey you know [ __ ] monroe he didn't say
that i'm sure but he's like hey um
my teacher is dr robert knox and he
needs bodies so maybe you should go over
there and like ask him about that
so he told him
where the dude lived
and there was a place called surgeon
square which looked nice for like from
the pictures
back then
so they're like okay well whatever so
they go to
see dr knox
now
knox was just kind of like woohoo bodies
um i will give you seven pounds ten
shillings for this body
now how that shook out
william hare got four pounds five
shillings
uh william burke got three pounds five
shillings now hair got larger [ __ ]
because he's like hey like this [ __ ]
was staying in my
boarding house and he [ __ ] died and
he still owed me some back rent so i
should get like more [ __ ] so that's how
they like worked that out
now according to burke later on this is
much later like at the trial
he said that as him and hare were
leaving the school
uh that the anatomists or like at least
i don't know if it was dr knox
particularly or if it was his assistance
that said something like we'd be glad to
see you again if you got any other
bodies you need to dispose of okay
which apparently gave them the idea
yeah okay oh my goodness
well yeah and they're kind of like
thinking because like i said you have to
think in this time period
um there was a lot of traffic in
digging up fresh bodies like you'd wait
for somebody to die
and then you go in there like
all on the down low like after like the
funeral or whatever and dig that [ __ ] up
and like sell it to like anatomical but
burke and hair were kind of like uh they
were entrepreneurs
you know so they were just kind of like
how about
we cut out the middleman
and just make our own [ __ ] bodies
yeah so i kind of feel like birkenhair
very associated with body snatchers
they didn't really snatch any bodies in
the sense of like digging up bodies that
were already dead they were just like
straight-up serial killers they're just
kind of like we don't even want to go
through all that we don't have to like
have wait for people to die and like dig
it up we're just gonna kill the [ __ ]
and sell them to like [ __ ] it that's
kind of like what their thing was hhomes
[ __ ] came to that conclusion same
kind of thing but i think he had a
sexual element to it also yeah these two
i feel like did not just business these
two were just very very
pragmatic
uh in the sense that they didn't really
care who
whoever it was that they could like
tempt into their
web or whatever
they would kill you and like sell your
psychology of a victorian um
insurance fraud fraudist
yeah guys that were just poisoning
people to get insurance money
real common in the well they weren't
poisoning them no but i'm just saying
yeah same psychology as somebody like
that let's just kill this person and get
the money
yeah like i said it was more like a
pragmatic yeah it wasn't about sexual
gratification no because both of these
guys when they first started doing this
um they were
i want to say they were older they were
like probably in their late 20s or early
30s and so it's not like most serial
killers start when they're young
teenagers
yeah i don't feel like they had any
particular predilection toward this kind
of thing it's just it was a purely i'm
not excusing it like i said but it does
seem like a purely pragmatic this is a
way we can make money and these are
people who will not be missed
yeah they saw it as like a purely
practical consideration which is which
are the excess population which like i
said in its own way is
is cold-hearted yeah yeah yeah and in
some ways it's like more cold-hearted
clearing out the excess population
converting them into money
that's what they were doing that's kind
of like what they thought that's kind of
what they thought of non-essential
personnel
yeah they were like hey there's just
like old drunks or like prostitutes or
whatever so it's like we're gonna make
these people more essential to us at
least yeah yeah making some money that's
what they would do
so now it's always on how you
rationalize it and it's not just these
criminals they've got criminals way up
high in society in the in the military
industrial complex just saying we're
going to make them essential to us
[Laughter]
yeah well certain types of people yeah
me because i don't you know i get it but
i don't think that way but i don't live
this way
but some people just see other people as
a mean to an end yeah people which like
i said to me that's the uh definition of
sociopathic exactly people with
different great ambitions have to be
[ __ ] controlled you gotta watch those
[ __ ] why does this [ __ ]
have such great ambition what is he
trying to do how did he get up to that
level it's you're gonna find a certain
kind of psychology in those people just
the way it is
telling you the truth that's all i mean
anybody that sees other people as a
means as a means to an end yeah um you
crazy in whatever reason that's like
something that you really have to watch
because that's
uh that's not a good situation because
that could lead to all kinds of like
terrible things and it does and it does
it look at history yeah yeah
mike barrett says jenny are you gonna do
any jess franco films that would be
great oh i'm sure i probably will at
some point i'm sorry i'm sure i will at
some point
uh but yeah so
yeah that's the thing any any time
you're using and these dudes
definitely were using people as a means
to an end they didn't give a [ __ ] about
these people they were just kind of like
who's not gonna be missed who is
available
um we just need them to like make
everything goes down a socio-economic
[ __ ] class okay
these guys are at the lower end end of
the socio-economic system
but these same kind of personalities
exist higher up on the socioeconomic
[ __ ] scale and they do the same kind
of [ __ ] it's just that
it's more official looking
just
telling you guys that's
how a lot of the
[ __ ] like is that anybody that can
come at people think that way and think
that they are not like people and then
you combine that with like supposedly
supposedly official
government positions or official
positions within cultures
bad combination bad combination it
happens
it does yeah but yeah
so
humans
humans man evil hairless monkeys not all
of them but no and honestly not all no
but the hierarchy [ __ ] assembles
itself that way because of human nature
that's what i'm saying power must always
be kept in check
authority must always be in check
never blindly trust authority
you can trust but verify
trust but verify
yeah well yeah it's always kind of like
like i said not everybody's like that
but you don't know if it also takes a
couple
so all it takes is one you just always
gotta watch just watch your back they're
out there
that's all yeah just be aware we don't
assume that everyone is like that
because most people aren't no but be
aware
that there are some people like you need
to do a show and revisit mk ultra again
that was like a real good example of
that but okay we'll talk about
remember that
yeah yeah
okay so at this point okay
now at this point like i said the first
dude that died
was as far as anyone knows natural
causes he just died of natural causes
and they were just kind of like hey
cha-ching
opportunity calls
so they did that but then they were kind
of like hey
uh this is very lucrative all right so
let's just like start killing people
that no one's gonna miss
and we can make even more money
now because this was a long time ago the
1820s uh and because there's not huge
amounts of records
um they don't really know and it's sad
because they don't really know um the
order of the people that died and some
of the victims they don't actually even
know their names
but we'll kind of like try to do is
the best that we can
now
and the thing too is that most of the
[ __ ] that they know is from burke's
confession
and he gave two or three of them and
they were a little bit contradictory so
there's that now the first murder
probably
uh happened in january or february 1828
now
the first victim was either
a miller
named joseph who was lodging in william
harris house because like i said you got
a lodging house
that's like some
it's like a victim buffet you know what
i mean like from a [ __ ] up point of
view
because people come going all the time
no one's gonna like check up on it
there's that kind of [ __ ]
uh or the first victim might have been a
woman named abigail simpson who was a
actually salt merchant
uh you know
it differs but both of these people died
so it doesn't really like matter all
that much
now
uh joseph probably the more likely first
victim
um
what happened
the thing about birken hair
they were
i feel like burke was kind of smart like
harry was kind of like an idiot but
they did know enough even though they
didn't have like forensic science back
then
they knew enough
to
smother their victims so that the
victims would not have any weird marks
on them like they didn't strangle them
or anything like that they would kind of
like have this thing where
they would kind of like put their hand
like over their nose and mouth yeah and
they would just like hold it
yeah wouldn't leave any bruises wouldn't
leave any marks wouldn't leave anything
like that so they were at least that
savvy
to know that that was
the best way to go about things and i
think that that kind of
i mean even nowadays that's kind of like
hard to prove yeah there are ways though
there's yeah nowadays you can breathe
but back then when i could and you guys
a how-to manual on how to get away with
murder because you suffocate somebody
there are other telltale signs that they
can do with modern forensics to find out
that person had been suffocated
uh
they can look into the whites of the
person's eyes there's a bunch of damage
that can happen to capital areas and
[ __ ] and for all i know there are other
[ __ ] things that they can do with
[ __ ]
blood tests and that dead blood to find
out a person was set with it's just
really it all boils down to the [ __ ]
same thing what jurisdiction did this
happen with how much money do they have
how important is victimology in other
words how high profile is the victim
if it's a [ __ ] victim that is [ __ ]
all
extensive criminal record or high risk
anyway
it doesn't seem to be serial murder uh
it's a male uh it's an older male
they're not going to worry about it
well the thing about it too was that
this particular victim yeah and they
think that maybe this is how birkin hair
justified because this was like their
first murder they had already profited
off a dead body but that was like a
natural death this was the first person
that they'd actually murdered they were
kind of like well
joseph if he was their first victim was
actually like kind of sick
and so they were kind of like well he's
in our boarding house and we don't want
him to infect the other
patrons at the boarding house so i'm
sure they had like some justifications
because like i said
every villain
has justifications for their actions
and these two were no exception
so i kind of feel like well yeah but
what they did they were at least savvy
enough one of them would like kind of
like sit on the person like on their
legs and chest like to keep them from
moving around and then the other one
would just like basically
put their hand like on their over their
nose and mouth and just suffocate them
which is a horrible kind of way to die
because the person knows
they can see you yeah that you're doing
that and it takes a while
but that's how they would do it and they
wouldn't like leave any marks
on the person
so
yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up but that's
how they kind of like hit upon i don't
know
how they hit upon that in particular
um but it was a like a good way of like
not getting caught because they didn't
get caught for a while
so there's that
uh so yeah
now
now there was another victim too like
joseph was probably the first one maybe
not but whichever the order there was
another victim named abigail simpson
uh now he was like an uh english lodger
he was also staying at the house
and he was from uh cheshire
now nobody knows what his name is which
is like kind of sad
but he was a kind of like traveling so
he sold like matches and stuff like that
now while he was at
william hare's lodging house staying
there he got sick
uh with jaundice
now because he was already sick uh brook
and hair were just kind of like woo
cha-ching like i said um and they could
kind of like
have plausible deniability we're just
gonna like smother this dude and it'll
look like he already had a disease so
it's fine like i said i kind of feel
like that's how they justify to
themselves
um
so he's justified himself oh well he
could get all of our other
uh residents sick so we have to like
take him out that's probably like how
they thought about it so they did the
same thing they suffocated him as well
uh they would sit on him and then like
you know put the hands over his face or
whatever until he died
and then they would like you know sell
them on now uh simpson was actually he
was an older dude and he was uh on a
pension he lived in the nearby village
and uh or she rather she was it was a
woman i know the like
yeah why didn't i say he my name was
abigail
i don't know what i'm talking about
but yeah my notes are like [ __ ] up
so
well now i'm gonna be able to make it
jenny
yeah i'm fine like
i think i
made a typo of my in my nose and they
put some more ice in this for you but
yeah
so yeah she had like she had a um income
she was like on a pension because she
was older but she was also like selling
salt like on the side and she kind of
got picked up
so what happened
to her was that she got and this was
kind of like happened a lot with them
she gets invited to
uh william hare's
house
and they would be like hey come back to
our house and like have a drink with us
and most people are just kind of like
okay whatever they didn't like have any
reason to like
you know think about like hey free
liquor whatever so they would like come
back there and they would have a drink
and then
they would give her like a [ __ ] ton of
booze
until she was like too drunk to go
anywhere or until she passed out
and then they would smother you so you
know that's there's that
and then what they would do is they
would take the body and they would put
it in a tea chest which if you don't
know what that is like it's just it's
basically like a big wooden crate they
used to use it for shipping tea like
overseas like if you had tea that was
coming from here to there like you know
shipping to
uk or whatever you'd put it like in this
big like wooden chest so they everybody
had these like around
apparently so they would put the bodies
in there
and they'd kind of like drag it through
the streets
basically
they would take it to
dr knox's
anatomy thing he's like hey
got a fresh body for you
dr knox
very excited
uh he's kind of like man you [ __ ] are
really coming up with some fresh ass
[ __ ]
um i love it
so he started paying them 10 pounds each
per body now
it's kind of hard like i've seen a
couple of things i don't really know how
much that is in modern
terminology i've heard that it's kind of
like a thousand pounds
maybe
so it's kind of like that's a ballpark
figure it's kind of like a thousand
pounds
for like just dragging them which
that's a lot but it really does seem
like
not enough
to like murder somebody for you know
what i'm saying i mean
if i was gonna like murder somebody and
sell their body i would need like
[ __ ]
i'm gonna retire forever money not just
like a thousand but that's like
not even like a month's
bills you know what i'm saying but
i don't know i don't know
so
they were uh apparently cool with it so
they get 10 pounds per body
and
so they bring them there in the t chest
now there's a lot of controversy over
how much dr knox who was buying the
bodies from them
how much did he know
i don't really know where i fall on that
i kind of feel like he would have to be
a [ __ ] idiot
not to know
what was going on
yes he was buying bodies from other
resurrection men yes he was
doing that but
how would you like he made statements on
several occasions that it's like man
burke and hair bring me like the
freshest bodies it's like how do you
guys do this so he had to [ __ ] know
he had to know
that there was something going on he had
um
i'm not gonna spoil that until later but
yeah
i kind of feel like he had to know
and i'm not saying that he
should have like had the same
sentence or anything like that but he
had to know what was going on
so yeah so these first two
like i said they kill a couple people
they get 10 pounds each
like i said probably about a thousand
dollars that's like a ballpark i'm not
really sure if that's entirely accurate
but you know
so they do that now
february or march
of 1828
they also killed another old woman who
is unnamed uh her name is lost to
history
margaret hare
uh you know william hare's wife
invited her back to that because the
wives and girlfriends were in on this
[ __ ] by the way
so
margaret like is like hey come back to
our house and like have a drink or
whatever so she's just kind of like fine
so she comes back there they give her a
bunch of whiskey she falls asleep
and then william hare comes back from
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing
and
smothered her
um
and
you know killed her
now william burke comes back and they're
like okay we're gonna put the body in
the [ __ ] box and we're gonna take a
dr knox they get another 10 pounds
william burke meets two women in early
april of the following year
mary patterson uh
and also another woman named janet brown
now i think these two women were
actually uh sex workers so yeah
now
he brings the two women back to his
house um and he says hey i got a bunch
of booze there and they're just kind of
like fine so they go back there and they
drink a bunch of them and he's giving
them food and all this kind of stuff
so
they go back they have like a bunch of
whiskey he meets them in a bar
but
instead of going back to his house he
actually goes to the house of his
brother
constantine
now his brother constantine leaves her
work william burke at this point they're
like oh well
we he's gone now so we should drink more
so they just kept drinking and drinking
they drank so much
that
uh
that
one of them like pat mary patterson fell
asleep at the table so she like passed
out
now william burke and janet brown
kept talking at the table
but then
helen mcdougall who if you remember was
burke was burke's girlfriend slash wife
kind of
she busts into the house she's like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you were like talking you
were like
pretty much gonna like sleep with a
prostitute right now and it's like i'm
not okay with that
even though she knew that they were
killing people which is kind of weird
but okay
so she comes in they get like in an
altercation about it
so his
wife slash a girlfriend she gets mad
um she's like you guys are having an
affair i don't like it
so they start having a fight
william burke and helen mcdougall
he throws a glass at her like it goes
out into the street like people in the
neighborhood like the neighborhood like
come to see it bro there's that yeah
there's a lot of idiocracy in the
beginning right
it's like a youtube video keep him over
there
it's a whole thing it's a whole thing
like i said these are not master
criminals
they're like killing people to sell his
bodies and yet they're still like
getting in fights with their wives that
like spill out into the street yeah so
like i said not geniuses these
[ __ ] just opportunists
yeah that essentially is what they were
they weren't thinking about that much
they were just kind of like look i just
want to make some money and it's like we
can kill some people these people are
like homeless or nobody's going to me
nobody's going nobody's going to miss
them it's like yeah it was all like like
i said
pragmatic so the whole thing listed
they're fighting in the street everybody
comes out it says it seemed like a
doctor would figure out the reason for
the death the alums being messed up
you gotta understand the [ __ ]
mentality of the time
well this is early 19th century or yeah
early 19th centuries you had a bunch of
old people showing up dead and [ __ ]
they didn't care
they didn't care why they died they're
like look if there was no obvious
sign that they had been murdered they
were just kind of like what
these [ __ ] were checking out
soon anyway it's all good that that
that's that is
they're not worried about crime well you
have to think that like even
fingerprinting right didn't really come
into the mainstream until after the jack
the ripper burners which was late 19th
century there's also the psychology if
you have to understand the priority of
victim victimology okay
guys in law enforcement
they're men
they're going to prioritize
[ __ ] deaths based upon what the
victim's like
if it's a bunch of young girls
who are prime females coming up on
marriage yeah they'll jump right down
there they're going to be all over that
what the [ __ ] if you're talking about
dudes in their 60s and 70s and drunks
and [ __ ]
they don't care how they died they're
kind of like yeah like that's still a
little [ __ ] out of here nowadays yeah
like looking them up
if you're a drug addict or you're
mentally ill yeah
you're a sex worker right
they're not going to give i mean i'd
hate to say
they're not going to give as much of a
[ __ ] no because they're not going to
give as much because they're just not
you know from the pandemic that they
have a concept of [ __ ] a [ __ ] uh
what do they call it non-essential
personnel right
well now they also have a concept of
[ __ ] people that are a detriment
and when they always have that they've
always had that they're like well these
are nuisance people anyway okay yeah
whatever yeah yeah get them out of here
yeah they got murdered so yeah that's
what you're dealing with
well that's how the that's how these
[ __ ] got away with it first of all of
course they killed 16 [ __ ] people
that they know of yeah yeah probably
more right not non-essential personnel
that's what they called it during the
pandemics yeah there's like a bunch of
drunks or like [ __ ] itinerant people
they don't care you got non-essential
and then you have [ __ ] kind of like
[ __ ] nuisance personnel and when they
die they're just like good good good
well good good okay fine fine yeah
there's no obviously good no no
no obvious murder fine okay good they
just pass it on yeah
now if that person was chopped up they
would go like well something's going on
and [ __ ] i'll get in trouble if i
[ __ ] pass up on this
you know what i mean so i gotta say yeah
we need to find out what's why who
chopped this dude up okay
but if it's just like yeah he's dead
okay bye-bye
they don't care
i mean it's terrible but even nowadays
even nowadays yep yep yep and it and
it's it's in the united states it is
county by
county if this is in a [ __ ] county
where a lot of people are dying and it's
[ __ ] it's a collapsing county there's
no economy there it's like a an urban
area and there's no jobs and [ __ ]
just falling apart a detroit type
situation and they find a 70 year old
[ __ ] basically a dude who's homeless
and they find him dead they don't care
what happened to that dude which is
awful
but they don't but they don't care
because there's lots of those
yeah yeah they're just kind of like yeah
we got like more important yeah we got
more important things to do
but like i said that's still a person
this is the world we live in i know but
like i said that's kind of like what
bums me out about this is that like half
of their victims were they didn't even
know what their [ __ ] names were
yeah because they were just like
ignorant like whatever um dan bell went
to that damn park where they were body
dumped what was the name of that damn
park outside chicago was in chicago or
was it uh lincoln baltimore yeah lincoln
lincoln park lincoln lincoln yeah and
[ __ ] he's got whole videos of it and
they found bodies out there [ __ ] they
don't know and no one like they're like
i mean they can't give a crap but not
really that much right still happens
today grow up people
well no i mean don't be condescending
i'm just saying that
there's a certain segment of the
population that nobody cares if they get
murdered right i mean like i said i've
written
enough like true crime to know that yeah
yeah if you're like wealthy and white
yeah people are going to give a [ __ ] if
you get murdered
otherwise not so much
well white isn't everything it well
it's mostly money
that's part of it but i think it's
mostly female young they'll care more
about that okay
female young pretty then oh yeah they're
going to be on well yeah if you're
pretty well like i said well like i said
i've written about a lot of cases of
young children that were not white yeah
uh that really didn't get all but were
they male 1
no i'm just saying even females that one
dude there was no female children yeah
uh they get abducted murdered and stuff
like that if you're not white
um
not people care but not as much
it would depend on the time
too
nowadays it wouldn't be like which is
shitty that's like super shitty a lot of
times i hate it what they'll do is
they'll say well this is this is all
coming out of a [ __ ] high crime area
a low income high crime area
and uh we don't know who's doing it and
we don't really have the funding and you
know so there's something to that
everything is kind of
sure but in a lot of ways too they're
kind of like well they're using that as
an excuse to like not do [ __ ] about it
and i don't think it's an excuse i think
it's an inability because i mean i don't
think they don't care like some people
individually
individually people do
care they didn't figure out because look
they didn't figure out who who killed
john bennett ramsey and she was a rich
young pretty [ __ ] little bitty white
little baby okay
i think i know who did it okay i think
i'm pretty sure who did it just based
upon the way that they acted
but i don't want to get sued
but it was somebody inside that house
and not the mama and not the dad
okay
there's only one other [ __ ] option
okay i ain't saying nothing that's
probably what happened okay i mean i
don't know it wasn't probably most
likely i wasn't there okay
um and the cops just couldn't
make that damn accusation because that
[ __ ] they would have defended you
know by the family would have defended
the allegation they knew
that this looks like to me
grampur's professional law enforcement
agent
that i grew up with in the comments
section he could drop it too grantham
does you agree with me it was somebody
inside that house
and it wasn't the parents that's all i'm
gonna say
that's the only thing
some of that [ __ ] that happened like
remember the [ __ ] the the black dude
the dj
he was killing all the little boys
they got him
some people say well that's not him but
no that was him
or the atlanta child yeah now had it
been girls
it would have been different
probably
thing is though is that you have to have
evidence
you know yeah i mean that's the thing
you can't have and like i said i'm not a
big fan of just saying like oh this
person did it because certain evidence
you really have to have to have evidence
and you see a lot of the things that
happen to them little girls out in the
[ __ ] hood there's no evidence for
anything
and then the cops are like there they're
[ __ ] stretched to the max
so it's not so much
the race involved like well it's just
black people that's not what they're
doing is the fact that they don't have
any [ __ ] money and they don't have
any evidence
and and they're they're overworked
the local cops they try to catch them
it's just that they can't
well they have so much other [ __ ] they
got other [ __ ] that's going on and
there's a lot of others like i said it's
always more complicated and then we're
and then jenny what jenny's talking
about was mostly the 70s and the 80s
which is the [ __ ] heyday of serial
murder
those times have passed
uh
i think a lot of it had to do with
leaded gasoline
we've talked about that before in other
shows and i thought i invented that
myself i thought i was a genius
that i thought that i had figured it out
jenny says no there's a lot of people
that think that
oh yeah i've seen that brought up and
like yeah they're like discussion
remember how they had leaded gasoline
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] quietly [ __ ]
vanished
those little lead particles were [ __ ]
blowing all around them city areas and
people were
breathing that in and we know for a fact
that lead had a lot to do with [ __ ]
up the rope the roman ruling class 2 000
years ago that will make you crazy and
make you very violent yeah it [ __ ] your
brain out [ __ ] your brain up
i mean and they quietly got rid of that
gasoline
well i'm sure they didn't want to alarm
anybody yeah they were just kind of like
yeah we're just gonna
back away slowly yeah and the height of
the whole leaded gasoline build up
theory that i
later went back
and looked at
no
they were like oh [ __ ] a lot of gasoline
is building up in these [ __ ] urban
areas and people are breathing this and
they're going [ __ ] crazy
and we're lucky to have as few serial
killers as we had and then when leaded
gasoline went away
the amount of serial killers and serial
killings went away violence actually
declined
as
as lead gasoline went away
let it gasoline
so
there was a biological
answer yeah i don't think that was the
only no it wasn't the only thing that
was one of the contributing but i think
that was one of the key it was a
contributing factor
yeah
i'm pretty sure
yeah i don't doubt it yeah i mean like i
said there's a lot of other factors but
i think that was definitely one of yeah
one of the major ones sure
because lowers your iq and makes you
[ __ ]
violent
yeah well it you know it's it's kind of
a thing where it like lowers your
inhibitions and stuff you know they've
done studies on that so yeah yeah um
okay so where was i all right so
um
yeah so there was this whole thing where
helen comes in helen mcdougall
comes in it's like you [ __ ] you're like
sleeping the prostitute
uh and they get in a big fight and it's
this big
a street scene and like everybody comes
out to see it
now at this point
uh janet brown
says oh [ __ ] uh okay well i didn't know
this dude was married i'm out of here
which probably saved her life to be
honest with you and she's like okay i'm
leaving so she left
uh helen mcdougall also lift she's like
i don't need this [ __ ] and she took
off even though she knew what was going
on
so she left
now
uh they go and get uh
william hare and his wife
and then what happened after that was
that they locked the two guys barking
hair
locked their wives out of the room
and they ended up murdering
mary patterson one of the prostitutes in
her sleep while like while she was
sleeping now the other one got away
but yeah she was in the room they're
like hey she's here so it might as well
now so they took her body to dr knox in
the famous tea chest
now
uh
the wife or the girlfriend um of one of
them mcdougall helen mcdougall
schizo the skirt and the petticoats they
got eight pounds
for the body
the body was still
warm when they delivered because they
had just killed her obviously
now one of the assistants
uh to dr knox says where did you get
this [ __ ] from because he's starting to
get suspicious
um and plus the thing about
uh mary patterson
was that
she was
by all accounts very recognizably
beautiful she was a prostitute in the
area so a lot of people recognized her
because she was unusually good-looking
and a lot of um
local people had patronized her okay
so
a lot of people knew who she was
so one of the assistants was like hey
i know who that is like when they
brought the body in
uh where did you get this
now burke says um
yeah she just
drank herself to death
uh we just bought it from some old [ __ ]
that was over in like the neighborhood
like i don't know she just like died
like of natural causes and we just
bought it and we brought it here
now
dr knox
and this is messed up we'll get into
this later like why i think like dr knox
probably should have
suffered more
consequences than you did
he um
was very like he's like oh my god this
is like i think she was only 18
at the time that she was killed
and he was like oh my god we have this
beautiful 18 year old
prostitute that was apparently famous
around edinburgh for how beautiful she
was
oh my god i have her corpse now
i'm really into it in a like a weird
[ __ ] way
so he decided i'm gonna put this in a
whiskey barrel and i'm gonna like gonna
keep it now according to some sources i
don't know if this is true or not so
please take this with a grain of salt
but i have heard from some sources
that
um he didn't just
oh i'm gonna save this for later to like
you know do the anatomy thing and like
cut it up and everything
he kept it in a whiskey barrel
and apparently
allegedly
he
charged money
for people to come see it
because she was so beautiful and like
everybody kind of knew her
so he almost kind of did like a weird
like sideshow thing where he's like hey
come and see the body of this like
famous prostitute like she's done it
like i i don't know if that's true but
i've heard that
so i don't know if he did that now janet
brown
like her friend who was with them that
night she actually did like come back
and be like hey what the [ __ ] happened
to my friend
um
and everybody that was involved in the
murder said oh i don't know man she like
took off and she went to glasgow we
don't know where she went
um she took off with some dude
so there was that so great great
now at some
point
i gotta feed go ahead okay i'll take
care of them let's see what the comments
are and i will jenny's gonna go ahead
and use the restroom she calls it pen
whoa i'm gonna say the restroom
go ahead look at the way she's walking
look at myself
she's [ __ ] doing that
walking all [ __ ] cute when you go to
the bathroom
okay
let's see what everybody's talking about
mike said you're doing a great job
slides in there talking about today's
money [ __ ]
100 000 to be a star just saying i don't
know what he's talking about talking
about huffing glue
okay
now
now bunny's talking about where casey
anthony lived she seemed to like disney
she probably did the case casey
anthony's around here
and i don't know i've told this i've
told this story before
years back
years back i was working working for a
guy named mr seibel dr
seibel i took care of all of his horses
on his private
farm
mr cybele's mom built orlando general
hospital he's a very famous doctor in
this area
and
his son
worked at the courthouse where they
were trying casey anthony
and they liked her at the courthouse
they didn't think there was enough
evidence to to prove her guilty
and then as the trial continued she was
found not guilty hateful now
as far as
as far as casey anthony herself
i heard two different things about her
after that trial we did a show about her
right yeah
um one of the things that i heard about
her is that she was uh working online as
a some kind of cuddle buddy where you
paper some chick to cuddle with you
i don't know if there's a happy ending
involved in that or not i don't know
and then uh i heard also uh
something contrary to that
is that she got a job with her um
with the with the law firm that had
represented her
uh i don't really know what that deal
was yeah it could have been that she
became somebody's girlfriend
you know what i mean of the lawyer i
don't i don't really know
um but as far as the casey anthony thing
happened
as far as that particular case
i'm not convinced it was murder
it may have been some kind of a
mass slaughter or something i think it
was more like negligence negligent
homicide i think it was i don't think
she meant to kill her i don't think so
either i think it was negligent and then
she was just kind of like oh [ __ ] now
i'm in trouble yeah and i gotta cover it
up i kind of feel like that i don't i
don't think she meant to kill that kid
no i don't think so either i mean it's
not it doesn't make it better yeah i
don't remember all the absolutely but i
remember coming to the conclusion that i
what i think happened
is that she put the kid in the trunk
to go get laid somewhere and forgot
about the kid and the kid got cooked
fell asleep
something like that
earth would you put your child in a
trunk or what may not have been a trunk
she might have been in the back seat
yeah might have been in the back seat
and then and then
she went to go
hang out with some dude and fell asleep
and when she woke up [ __ ] she woke up
in the morning it was now 10 10 o'clock
in the afternoon you have to understand
at 10 o'clock in the afternoon in
florida it's [ __ ] 10 o'clock
10 o'clock is not the afternoon
well you know i mean 10 o'clock in the
morning is deadly heat see look at her
she was she's trying to do 10 o'clock in
the in the morning yeah but i'm
technically kill a kid the best kind of
correct if the kid was in the backseat
of a car it would kill a kid
at 10 o'clock
it would well it happened
so uh pretty much every summer we have
unfortunately we have one or two cases
every single summer yeah where somebody
some weirdo yeah leaves their kid in the
car hey i'm just gonna run in the
grocery store
for five or ten years and then they come
back and their kids dead so i think yeah
that's what i think happened
she was partying fell asleep after
getting laid
and the kid cooked in the morning
she woke up and she said oh [ __ ]
and yeah and then she
hid the body and tried to blame it on
her parents
somehow
she kind of blamed it on her dad i think
her in some weird way
yeah she's not a great person no
defending no but i don't think she
murdered the kid
yeah not deliberately i think it was
probably like just dumb accidental
[ __ ] she did
it was negligence yeah i i just think it
was negligence yeah i don't think it was
like malicious but that doesn't make it
any better i mean the kid's still dead
but
but have you come after her and locked
her up for a whole her whole life
then she'd be [ __ ] dead too [ __ ]
so you'd
lose two people
uh
she didn't mean to do it she was just
be a dumb she was young
yeah she was just a dumbass that didn't
give a [ __ ] about anybody other than
herself well we don't know that i it
might have been [ __ ] i'm gonna yeah
you're gonna be okay baby i'll be back
in a minute and then she goes there and
[ __ ] something dude and she as i just
said she didn't give a [ __ ] about
anybody other than herself come on
that's what i'm saying
pookie's in here all right so we still
have a lot of this to get through so can
i please get through this
okay
uh so yeah i don't even remember where i
was
okay yeah so
i'm not like i don't know if this is
true or not but this is gonna color my
opinion of dr knox going forward because
spoiler alert like i said he kind of got
away with it but i kind of feel like
if this is the case
when
um this particular victim was killed and
he was just kind of like ooh she's so
pretty
and young i i believe she was only 18.
i'm gonna put her in a whiskey barrel
and i'm gonna like charge people like
come see the dead body because
apparently that was a thing that people
did back then because they were [ __ ]
weirdos
so
he did that
um
so i don't love it whiskey bro yeah for
like three months with whiskey in it
i don't know like they thought well it
was preserving the body okay so you know
that's some weird [ __ ]
they did weird [ __ ] man i mean can you
guys have like better like read a book
jesus christ they did weird [ __ ] in
[ __ ] back in the honky motherland
like they were taking better [ __ ] they
like take their entire time they would
take like a dozen cats and tie all their
tails together put them in a bottle
and throw the barrel on a fire and
[ __ ] watch the cats [ __ ]
kill each other trying to get out of the
fire i mean it's just the kind of weird
[ __ ] european see and like i said people
talk about the good old days [ __ ] that
well some places were there were no good
old days there were good old days
nowadays people have other
uh harmless ways to occupy their time
look play games on your phone yeah like
[ __ ] go through instagram you're not
killing anyone you're not killing
animals that's awesome
do that well i don't think everybody was
i don't think everybody was down with
that it was just the weird [ __ ] they
would well obviously when there was good
old days when i was in mississippi we
would do anvil shoots and i've even
talked about that shout out blasted damn
advil
[ __ ] was crazy nobody got hurt the dog
almost tried to catch the danville on
the way back yeah but a dog could have
got killed that's just the way what we
didn't realize we realized she was like
lock the dog exactly the point we gotta
lock the dog up people were idiots back
then and they were just kind of like
look it was the 90s in the late 80s yeah
people were idiots back then
i was alive i remember
they were more idiots it was just fun
well people are idiots now
people are still in it
so i'm kind
oh my god i didn't realize that i could
actually kill my dog duh
duck
come on we didn't think the dog would
try to catch it
because
people are idiots it did because dog
didn't catch it though y'all already dog
missed it yeah but it could have
happened it could have happened i mean
seriously
have some [ __ ] foresight well from
there now the dog was locked up before
after they did [ __ ] force
i mean the ability to see outcomes
of things yeah i kind of feel like
that's sort of like a precursor to
intelligence if you don't have that
then
we no no tommy key instantly knew when
the dog [ __ ] ran out the door to go
catch it that he said get the dog in
there but the fact that we didn't know
that think of that he didn't
see this is jenny trying to be too smart
you're trying to be too smart
oh my goodness that'd be so terrible it
was just something we did on the [ __ ]
it's just something we used to do
without thinking about it no we thought
because you're idiots no we thought
about it it was just we we forgot to
lock it up you didn't really think that
hard to shut the door obviously you
forgot the shirt you didn't think you
forgot to shut the door we didn't
realize the dog would go try to catch
the [ __ ] anvil but go ahead good
that's the difference between smart
people and dumb people no is that you
having fun so you dumb people having fun
see we were not dumb it was just it was
like yeah but dumb people having the
expense
having fun at like the expense of like
innocent creatures and like see look at
her she's trying to get all [ __ ]
metaphysical no i'm saying okay
what if the dog got killed
would you have felt bad oh yeah it could
have happened yeah it wasn't my dog
though it was tommy keys dog
i don't care whose dog it was
i'm just saying that the fact that you
didn't foresee that
means you are idiots go ahead and
[ __ ] do the show i ain't the i y'all
are eating that's dumb because she
didn't like to talk about [ __ ]
[ __ ] happened i didn't realize that
you're an idiot they left the door open
the dog went the dog would ran out yeah
don't do that yeah you're an idiot
i'm just saying this [ __ ] happens man
sure i get that
but like
jeez we were running after the dog no no
no no no no
[Laughter]
dumb people get your [ __ ] together get
your shoes go ahead do the show all
right
so yeah
so basically okay so they killed this
woman who was a sex worker
now her friend comes back later to look
for
like i said i kind of feel like i don't
know if this is true or not but i do
kind of feel like they maybe displayed
her body for a little while so like look
how hot this dead body is which that's a
whole like [ __ ] quagmire that i don't
really want to get into but you know
what i mean
jesus good old days you guys
so yeah
so there was that
uh so at some point early to mid uh
1828. so there's another woman only
known as mrs haldane haldane i guess is
how you pronounce her last name
now
william burke
just described her and this is all from
his mostly from his confessions
he called her a stout old woman which
you know means fat old lady nice okay
whatever
yeah okay serial killer she's a fat hole
i'm sure i'm gonna take your [ __ ]
judgment about what would you probably
fit i mean you know
so she uh gets some rooms at william
hare's boarding house now like i said if
you have a boarding house at this time
period this is probably like an ideal
setup for serial killing because
people come and going all the time no
one's gonna notice
you know you get that kind of [ __ ] so
they were like taking full advantage
so she comes there gets some rooms
and they befriended her they're kind of
like hey have some drinks with us like
you would do like they would do
so they got her drunk
she falls asleep in the stable
and then they smothered her as they
would and they sold her body to dr knox
this is [ __ ] up
several months later
this same woman's
daughter
uh margaret or some sources call her
peggy which i guess peggy is kind of
like a no a nickname for margaret what
is it no okay well meg but i've seen
peggy
like people call margaret like call
peggy it doesn't make any sense but okay
it's the same thing as like richard dick
that doesn't make any sense either but
yeah
so there's that
she came along later apparently not
knowing that these [ __ ] were involved
in her mom's murder they're kind of like
she's kind of like hey yeah i need a
room too so she gets a room at william
harris house
and her and burke
started drinking
and he killed her same way now hair
wasn't there at the time he's like oh
i'm i'm undertaking this on my own and
he killed her
and puts her in the t-chest takes her to
dr knox and got a payday pounds for the
body
next murder took place may 1828. this
old woman uh sadly unnamed uh again came
and uh was a lodger at the boarding
house
now she also got drunk with them because
i kind of feel like they well at least
burke seemed like
he was like a psychopath in the sense
that
he didn't give a [ __ ] about anybody but
he was also like really charming
so from all contemporary accounts he was
like really able to like get into like
he was very ingratiating so he was like
able to
uh put people at ease
hare was different he was kind of like i
said he was kind of like a brute he
didn't he couldn't read he was kind of
like a douche so it was like nobody
really
i don't know it wasn't that but like
burke was more like hey i'm like super
charming and
apparently nobody had any reason to like
doubt his
sincerity like he seemed very genuine
that's kind of like what uh the
contemporary account say
so
uh this old woman comes there she has a
room and they're just kind of like hey
uh she's drunk so burke uh smothered her
again hair was not there um and he sold
her to knox again for 10 pounds
now the next murder was a woman only
known as effie
now she was a cinder gatherer which is
another job that does not exist anymore
thankfully at least in this part of the
world
what she would do was she would kind of
go through
uh you know
rubbish tips and
garbage and stuff and she would just
like clean stuff out or like sell stuff
that she found in there so there was
that
which was
uh sadly kind of like a booming business
back in those days
now
uh
effie she like burke knew of her because
she had sold him
leather scraps because like i said he
was a cobbler he picked shoes and stuff
so he knew of her because she had found
leather scraps in the garbage or
whatever and like sold it to him so he's
kind of like hey victim ding ding ding
so there was that
so he says hey got some whiskey why
don't you come in the stable and drink
with me and she's kind of like okay free
booze
um you know you're poor what else are
you gonna do
and he would get them drunk enough that
they would kind of like pass out or not
really know what was going on
and then at that point uh he and hair
would kill her again got 10 pounds for
the body
there was another victim again unnamed
uh this was a guy or a person that was
like found in the street um just really
really drunk and walking around it was a
woman actually but she was like walking
around and she like um you know didn't
know where she was or anything like that
this is kind of [ __ ] up
so william burke
finds her in the street she's too drunk
to stand up
now the cops had actually seen her be
like miss or you are right
burke comes up
and he's like
oh um i know her i'll take her back to
her
house like she'll be all right i'll take
care of her
and the cops are like well thank you sir
you are such a good samaritan
uh you know just [ __ ] up
uh so yeah he
basically posed as a good samaritan and
then took her back to harrah's house
and then killed her so great
uh again
ten pounds from dr knox dr knox at this
point
i'm not gonna [ __ ]
i don't know i was gonna say i'm not
gonna [ __ ] too much on dr knox i kind of
feel like he probably knew what was
going on
because even though
i'm gonna say during this time period i
wasn't alive back then but there was
like a lot of like resurrection men they
were digging up fresh dead bodies to
sell
and doctors were
maybe not super happy about it but they
understood that this was like a
necessary evil i guess
so they're just kind of like okay well
this isn't legal but we need the bodies
so we're buying stuff from grave rappers
now the fact that burke and hare were
coming to the dr knox particularly
and it's like hey we got this body we
got that body oh they're super fresh now
dr knox did
comment on how fresh the bodies were
but
i don't know
i mean i'm pretty sure that he knew what
was going on i'm pretty sure
and we'll get into some [ __ ] later on
that i'm
i'm gonna say like kind of like tips it
over the scales to me where i'm i'm
pretty sure that he knew that they were
murdering people but i kind of feel like
he was just kind of like hey i need the
bodies so i'm just like not gonna like
make raise too much of a stink about it
they were excess personnel anyway that's
what i'm saying and i kind of feel well
and the thing one thing i've heard about
dr knox too is that he was one of those
weird like um racialist
kind of like hey well i'm a doctor but
all of these like
excess people
well that's all the value that they have
is as bodies so
maybe he wasn't really like losing too
much sleep over oh but it's like
homeless drunks or prostitutes no
being like yeah no his point of view is
they're going to die anyway they don't
have it yeah i kind of feel like that's
yeah just like they don't have a long
lifespan there's no difference if they
die now or two or three years later
because that two or three years of life
that they had they're not gonna do
anything different than they would would
have been doing before
it's the same way a lot of people see us
they're like well those bits just sit in
front of television
you know what i mean it doesn't matter
if he sits at the front of television
between one year or five years more it's
still the same they sit there and watch
tv programs
and that's the way a lot of [ __ ]
elite rich people saw them but like i
said
thinking of another human being yeah
as
a commodity oh well
like i said a mean to an end or a thing
if you think of another person as an
object yeah then you are going to be
part of the problem you're you're
probably well i think the people that
[ __ ] basically run and control the
[ __ ] world are like that
well yeah that's on jane you're part of
the problem yeah the whole sex island
thing and everything that's them you are
essentially like looking at other people
i mean honestly i see you as bugs i
thought that that was like the kind of
like the base
of morality
don't see another person
as
an object for your
edification yeah that's not how it is or
is a means to an end i'm just saying
like the second that you start doing
that
that's when you've gone like off the
[ __ ] well these these these are still
poor people like this doctor he's
relatively still poor but when you're a
[ __ ] billionaire who owns all these
[ __ ] big corporations and
agribusinesses and [ __ ] this and that
no no they see regular people as just
somebody who buys things and somebody
who sits in front of television screens
and looks at them
uh in these little bitty houses
for a
certain amount of time and then they die
they get fat and they die okay that's
that's how they see them
but uh no that's that's how they see
most people and
that's what ridley scott's talking about
i mean me [ __ ] i'm like like i said i'm
a very like science-oriented person yeah
so to me yeah i see every human being as
a completely
unique
creation yeah they don't see that
um
so it's like every time a person dies
it's like that's kind of like a tragedy
because that's never going to happen
again that particular
[Music]
colony okay okay well the the people
that the people that run all this [ __ ]
and own everything they will go yeah
that's right that's never going to
happen again and that's a good thing
they don't care
about that they i know they don't they
they don't know they're like yeah that's
what they they see that that's big well
because that's i'm a better person they
see that person they see that person as
a consumer sure that they that they're
there to [ __ ] yield labor and buy
things they're like a little system
and here's another thing
they consider themselves to be your
creator
because your ancestors that gave birth
to you
worked for and were created by
their industries or their parents
industries during the baby boom you only
exist because of what their ancestors
did but the hilariously
is that
one thing if you're real into like
science or evolution or anything like
that is that you are no better
yeah than any of us oh no they just know
oh i know they they think they're much
better they're wrong they want eternal
life [ __ ]
they want eternal life oh better they
want to download their consciousness
into a damn [ __ ] metaverse where
they'll live forever oh i know and they
want to cut off all the damn power
supply and kill everybody because we're
obsolete
but like i said that yeah that that in a
way well i know they do yeah i know they
do but that's like very funny to me
because that's like not how that shit's
gonna work well they think well we
created this big baby boom and all these
people and now we don't need them so we
got to get rid of them that's [ __ ]
like humans are relatively
very small in the grand scheme of things
um
so get the [ __ ] over yourselves um
you're no better than anybody else you
take a [ __ ] like everyone else um
you know
sorry you're just yeah you got more
money you got more power good for you uh
you're gonna die just like everyone else
you're gonna be bones just like everyone
else uh you know that's how it's just
gonna happen but
you know i i don't really have any kind
of like [ __ ] illusions about this guy
i know they do but
it's kind of sad that they it's kind of
like funny and like pathetic that they
kind of like think that but anyway
so yeah so they kill this woman
now
the thing about this particular woman
and this is kind of like where i feel
like broken hair were starting to get a
little bit sloppy
because prior to this
they were kind of just targeting either
people that died naturally or people
that were like homeless or people are
just like lodging in their [ __ ] but
mary patterson
was not
famous but she was kind of like
recognizable like a lot of people in
edinburgh were like hey she was like a
sex worker and a lot of people have been
to her so and she was um
you know unusually beautiful so a lot of
people like to remember her so i kind of
feel like that at that point people were
like you know what i mean because people
like recognize who she was
now at this point uh in june of that
year
they murdered two other lodgers now
again i don't think that their names
were preserved for posterity
unfortunately but this was like a
grandma she was like an older woman and
her grandson who was a mute child
now
this is [ __ ] up so what happened like
they bring the two into hey come in we
got food and we got lodging and we got
booze and whatever so they come in there
and they take the grandmother hey we're
gonna like take your grandma into this
other room can you imagine like this i
don't remember how i don't know how old
this kid was but they take the grandma
off into the other room
and they do their [ __ ] and they like
smother her
and at this point they're kind of like
well we need to kill the kid too and
they're kind of like we'll wait should
we it's just like a kid
but they're like well yeah but he's like
a witness so we should probably do that
too
so
they kill the grandma
and then
they kill the kid as well who's in the
cat tree is she in the little bowls i've
never seen her in the little bowls she's
trying them out again oh yeah
yeah we've moved the cabinet catch right
here it's like right out there that time
happens but yeah so
they kill the old lady
and then they're like well we have to
kill the kid too because he's a witness
like he'll know what's going on
so they so they kill the kid too
now
this and like i said i'm not excusing it
but what burke said later on in his
confession was that when they were
killing the kid because like i said
they're smothering their victims
in the sense that one of them is like
sitting on the leg so they can't like
wiggle around and stuff and then like
one of them is like putting his hand
like over the nose mouth and so they're
like smothering them like while they're
watching their face
and they're doing this to a little kid
and the fact that burke was like
watching this little kid's face because
he comes in like hey what are you doing
with my grandma like where is my grandma
who they've already killed
and so
the fact that he
like actually put his hand over this
little kid's face
and killed this little kid and like saw
his eyes like while he was dying
now apparently
this was
as [ __ ] up as all the [ __ ] that these
two have done so far this was like a
step past
the whole [ __ ] so they're kind of like
burke was kind of like yeah this [ __ ]
haunted me for the rest of my those kids
uh that kid's eyes
like the way that he looked like why was
that because they did kill him like
spoiled over
but they did kill him
um
you know i like i said that's
yeah good i'm glad that he was [ __ ]
haunted because jesus christ what the
[ __ ] are you doing
but so he kills a little kid
now
so he kills the grandma and the little
kid
now
the t-chest that they usually used for
carrying the bodies to dr knox
too small for two people they didn't
think of that i guess
so they're like okay we're gonna put
them in this herring barrel
so they take him to
dr knox he pays them eight pounds each
now
this is like this is really weird
according to burke he says
that when he put the barrel with the two
bodies because the t-chest wouldn't fit
two bodies so they had to like this
bigger barrel that they put the two
bodies in
so they put it on this cart and the
horse was pulling it
according to burke
the horse once he got to a certain point
wouldn't go any farther he was like [ __ ]
this the horse
made a stand
where he was just like not going any
further
uh and he couldn't get him to go anymore
that was the story that he told
now later i hate to tell you that he got
so mad at the horse that he shot it like
later on but the horse would just like
not he was like i am not participating
in this
debauchery any further
but
i mean
good for that horse that's like a hero
horse where's that like this yeah he's
like [ __ ] this i'm not
i'm not involved in this situation but
that was like the story yeah but he did
like uh shoot that horse later on sadly
so uh at this point so william burke and
his girlfriend helen mcdougall they go
to fall kirk to visit one of their like
dads or something like that
now burke
knew
that
william hare didn't have a lot of uh
cash
at the ready and had like even pawn some
of his clothes like to make some money
so when the couple came back though
um they're like oh my god they were a
[ __ ] skin when they were gone but
then they come back and then hair
has all this [ __ ] money somehow out
of nowhere they have all these new
clothes
they have all this like surplus cash
they're doing all kind of stuff they're
like what the [ __ ] have you guys been
doing while we were on vacation like
visiting the relatives or whatever
so they asked him and hair says oh i
totally didn't like sell another body i
don't even know what you're talking
about
but burke goes back to dr knox and knox
says yeah
um hare sold us a woman's body for eight
pounds
and at this point burke and hare got
into like this big [ __ ] feud like
that fight it was like [ __ ] you were
like selling bodies without my knowledge
i wasn't in on that stuff blah blah blah
but like i said you're gone
i mean that's like your business hey i'm
gonna like [ __ ] sell a body while
you're gone whatever
um but they got in a big fight they were
like fighting they were like punching
each other or whatnot
so at this point john burke or william
burke rather and his wife
moved to
this other house because they had had
been kind of like living together in
this boarding house but they moved to
another house which was um
uh
burke's cousin's house his name was john
brogan
so it was only a couple blocks away but
they moved to that house instead they're
like we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
we don't want to like hang out with you
[ __ ] anymore
i have to say though that even though
this was like a big rift between them it
didn't like last super long
late september early october
of this year
uh
william hare goes and visits william
burke
and then they see this woman who was
like a laundry woman washer woman type
woman named mrs osler
she came to the property to do some
laundry as she did that was her job
and the men were kind of like
so they got her drunk and they killed
her
and sold her corpse to dr knox eight
pounds
week or two after that
this is [ __ ] up
so one of
helen mcdougall's relatives now this is
uh this is wait
burke's girlfriend or hare's girlfriend
this is one of her relatives
she comes to visit
they're like we should kill that [ __ ]
so like i said they're getting a little
sloppy get a little sloppy
she's visiting from falkirk
so after a couple days they're like yeah
we should go
let's let's kill her in like so so they
did they killed her this was a relative
like not a super close roller but a
distance like a cousin type of relative
they're not getting that much money come
on
well i mean ten pound well ten pounds
what was that like a thousand but still
that's like take kills yeah it's
ridiculous i mean man if you want me to
kill somebody you need more than foul
morning right jesus christ that doesn't
even cover my bills for one month yeah
jesus christ you know you didn't give me
enough to like retire from my whole
entire life
depends on who it is depends on the
situation
even then i would like be
but but for a thousand dollars no way no
way yeah come on but yeah they were just
i don't know so they did that so this is
family members so apparently like
rando's
it's not good enough to like just kill
randos up the street now now we're gonna
kill family members so they're starting
to do that like i said very sloppy
so they kill one of uh
you know
helen mcdougall's family members
a distant cousin
who was visiting so they kill her and
they sell her body and they get 10
pounds
now
at this point too
uh hair
hair's wife
says hey
maybe we should kill
helen mcdougall
maybe we should kill her
she's a scottish woman and they can't be
trusted so maybe with the she was one of
the four that you knew about
so maybe we should kill her and sell her
body and
basically how are you gonna trust
scottish people that's what i mean
so at this point he's just like uh
that's my girlfriend no that's funny can
we not can we not right let's let's just
kill random people why would we kill
like people we know but yeah
he brought that up can you imagine back
in the hockey land [ __ ] funny man
and they were like best friends hey can
we kill your wife she's got it she can't
trust guys
come on what are you doing
you can't kill my wife or my girlfriend
or whatever
jesus christ what are you thinking yeah
but he was he brought it up it was
another time he brought it up and
apparently there were still like friends
after that which is i don't understand
that it was another they were still
friends after he killed the [ __ ] wife
yes well no he didn't kill her okay he
just brought it up brought it up okay
can you imagine like okay imagine this
you and your friend and your best friend
like let's presume that you and your
friend had like killed some people and
like sold the bodies yeah they said
let's kill your girlfriend
yeah and somebody said hey let's kill
jenny were they joking around are they
serious
i don't think they were joking yeah i
mean at this point like i said they were
getting kind of sloppy because they were
killing their family for money because
the thing about it is like prior to this
they were just like killing like you
know random like prostitutes or you know
homeless people or whatever people that
wouldn't necessarily be missed
if you're gonna kill people that are
like related
to your [ __ ]
then
i mean just
as a pro tip that's probably not a great
idea but that's kind of what they were
doing and then the fact that it's like
hey let's kill your [ __ ] hey she
knows too much
yeah
what were you thinking you guys are like
not good at crime
i mean they got away with it for a long
time because uh
forensic science back then was like nil
like they didn't really have any [ __ ]
way of doing this [ __ ] but yeah
so now
here's where they got in trouble though
they didn't kill the wife but the fact
that he suggested it i can't believe
that they were still friends after that
hey let's kill your girlfriend
yella no let's not but we'll still be
friends that's that's weird
now the next victim though was kind of
one of the things that got them in
trouble
so the next victim they targeted was a
very familiar face in the streets of
edinburgh and this was a guy named james
wilson now he was only 18.
and in the streets of edinburgh he was
kind of like very well known he was
known as daft jamie
now he was kind of like um
mentally challenged well daft yeah let's
call it that yeah
but everybody loved him like he was kind
of he was homeless
but he would like earn his he was kind
of like a beggar and he would kind of
like earn his living by like dancing and
singing it everybody loved him everybody
thought he was like awesome
dap jamie
um he also was very distinctive in the
fact that his face was very distinctive
and he also had i believe like a club
foot or at least have like a deformed
foot that like people recognized
so there was that um ever like i said
everybody in edinburgh knew who he was
everybody was uh loved him so there was
that
they decided for whatever reason that
they were going to kill him
so
so even [ __ ]
the mentally handicapped people are not
safe daphne nobody was yeah deaf
basically means [ __ ] [ __ ] they
mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] jamie [ __ ] and he was a
[ __ ] celebrity but everybody dropped
him though yeah they liked him
everybody's just kind of like he was
kind of like a fixture yeah yeah you'd
go from a certain part of the area like
an ember it's like oh there he is and
he's like singing and dance and you'd
like throw him a coin or something like
that [ __ ] are ruthless i'm
telling you man [ __ ] edinburgh is
what i'm telling you it was because i
mean back then yeah back in those days
sure it's not like that now edinburgh is
[ __ ] nice now but back in those days
it was [ __ ] it's beautiful it was the
hood back in those days
yeah pretty bad
yeah well like i said london was like
that too and any big city was kind of
like that yeah city's attracted better
it's kind of like lawless yeah
but so yeah so this guy everybody knew
who he was but for whatever reason
broken hair were like hey we're gonna
like kill that [ __ ]
so
uh
so yeah in november of that year um
william hare lures
dap jamie to his house he's like hey
i've got some booze whiskey
um
go like he sent his wife to like go get
burke because they have to like do
everything as a as a team you know
so they led him into the bedroom of the
house
um
and margaret
she locks the door
and then pushed the key under the door
now the thing about it that happened
though was that daft jamie
won
not really into alcohol so he didn't
really like drink a lot
yeah well he was more like a snuff guy
okay um
so he was kind of like well y'all know
that is [ __ ] on the back of the
[ __ ] tobacco cart so they'd move it
around a bunch of [ __ ] tobacco dust
and fall in the bottom and they'd use
[ __ ] brooms and [ __ ]
sweep up all the tobacco dust they put
in little cans of salad it was called
[ __ ] snuff it's way out of style i've
done some of it
uh you have it in a little thing and you
put it in a little spoon like a cocaine
spoon you snort it up into your [ __ ]
nose
and you get a rush from it i mean very
widespread back then but it's it's
tobacco yeah it's tobacco yeah so
kind of give you a rush from it
although it kind of like it's like
anything else any other kind of tobacco
if you're a smoker
you build up a tolerance to it and it
goes away and then it becomes just
something you have to do you don't
really get much from it
but uh yeah
it
i don't want to say it was the crack of
the era
the crack of the era was jin
they they considered that to be like
crack
uh because it was just cheap distilled
alcohol when the first
alcohol wasn't normally distilled
that was a new invention
they thought [ __ ] gin would end the
world that it was apocalyptic
little did they know what was coming but
they blamed all
society's ills on gin yeah
i mean you know yeah
let's blame society's hills on satanism
for video games or whatever will be the
end i guess
nothing's going to end the world is fine
yeah gin was the crap of the [ __ ]
1700 calm down yeah but yeah so
so what happened yeah so he wasn't
really into drinking so he would drink a
little just to be polite
but he didn't get like [ __ ] up drunk
like pass out drunk like they were kind
of like hoping for
and also even though he was
uh let's say like mentally challenged he
was also like kind of a big strong
dude
so when they tried to kill him
he fought back
um you know
and it took both of them
to
you know kind of
to kill him he did get killed uh
honestly but
yeah but he did like fight back and like
he wasn't drunk daddy says edinburgh is
beautiful but it's a show i don't know
i've seen pictures of it look great i
don't know it's like it does look
beautiful in pictures like i said i've
never been to scotland i've been to
wales like i lived in wales a long time
but
yeah
and i've been to london as well
it could not be worse than an american
bad city
it could i kind of feel like probably
not no like i said um
that would be considered a nice
neighborhood here well that was kind of
like the impression that i got because
like i said when i'm and this was like
90s early to mid 2000s when i was in the
uk i was just kind of like even the bad
neighborhoods it's like oh that's a bad
neighborhood don't go there i'm like
like nothing compared to here yeah
shitty neighborhoods in yeah
america right
like um you know
it's just like it's not the same which
is good which is good that's good
shittiest neighborhoods i've ever been
in were brazil and i'd still had fun
there you just have to know what yes you
just have to know how to navigate it
sao paulo brazil had some shitty
neighborhoods
but you could have fun there a lot of
fun
you just had to like know how to watch
your step
yeah and i kind of feel like that's true
in the us too but like but like i said
if you're in the us
i don't know i kind of feel like
europeans feel like oh if we come to the
us like it's super dangerous i don't
think it's as dangerous as
people think
but in the same way it's confined to
certain areas i've been to like shitty
like shitty neighborhoods in europe that
were like not nearly as shitty as
neighborhoods that i've walked around in
the us you know what i mean so it's it's
a difference you gave us five pounds
thank you thank you have a five or four
time but thank you thank you thank you
if you guys want to [ __ ] go ahead and
[ __ ] chip in [ __ ] send us some
super chats jenny's been working hard we
know times are tough
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm sitting here
loaded all right and we're just trying
to enter
entertain y'all
but uh
super chats have been [ __ ]
killing us past couple weeks
this is our only night to really make
them they haven't been making them well
and i have to say too that like the ad
revenues
have been
going down much lower yeah than usual
been hard times out there for everybody
so so we understand so that's where
everybody that was just my plug there
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna continue to
plug too much because we know you all
are good people and [ __ ] you're doing
what you could do i mean you guys turn
up every time we're on which i which
blows my mind why would anybody want to
like hear it for those of you people
that listen to us recorded
because some a lot of people can't
listen to us live
uh if you'd like to contribute you could
always do [ __ ] uh contact jenny and
send her a uh
uh
what do you call it uh
what paypal paypal can you center to
paypal or you can um become a subscriber
well we got patreon so
we have a lot of patrons also so even if
it's 5 10 bucks a month we'd appreciate
it and you get early access and
you get to vote
on
topics that we talk about on these shows
yeah i mean we mostly talk about it
right um and you get to vote on the
movie rush perspective right every
weekend
we are an interactive show
yeah sure yeah
uh who got the shittiest town fight
[Laughter]
oh man there's a lot of them here i mean
like i said i've been to like some
shitty places in the uk and i'm just
kind of like why are you like this isn't
that shitty yeah i've grown up in way
shittier places than that shitty doesn't
necessarily mean bad there's a lot of
[ __ ]
ghost towns in the [ __ ] south
that are just vacant and [ __ ]
forgotten [ __ ]
like something out of a damn movie you
know
um it doesn't necessarily doesn't
necessarily mean that there's trouble
there you know what i mean it's just
there's a lot of weird places in the
united states it's cool though you know
each state is different each region is
different
yeah i mean like watch your back
everywhere yeah i kind of feel like
that's just good advice anywhere you go
whether it's safe or not they can't
protect you they can't even protect
themselves just like watch your back
just watch your back right but i mean
i don't most places you go in the u.s
i kind of feel like um it's not as
dangerous as maybe it's portrayed well
depending on where you go
um most places you're probably
okay
but i would still watch your back
wherever you are
even if you're somewhere that's safe
still watch your back but i kind of feel
like most of the time you're probably
okay most people are okay
most people are okay most of it depends
on who you are and how you act and what
people think of you that has a lot to do
with it
you know that's true yeah
i mean [ __ ] i can pretty i've been in
every [ __ ] situation the united
states can throw throw at you with all
the different ethnic groups and
everything
some people you can't negotiate with you
just can't and it really doesn't matter
if i can race there or whatever there's
a certain kind of person that you just
can't negotiate with you don't want to
be around them
but the average person here is [ __ ]
just like any other normal most people
are okay they're just like i said most
people are okay
you it's about respect you treat them
with respect they treat you with respect
it's that same the laws don't have
anything to do with anything because
they're not following them anyway it's
but it's like common law
where you're good to them they're good
to you there's reciprocation
most people are like that
if you're an [ __ ] and you come here
it's going to be trouble that's what i'm
saying well and i kind of feel like that
applies anywhere around the world it's
not just the u.s
most people that get hurt in the united
states
kind of deserve it
well i don't know if i'd go that far no
but no the average person that gets hurt
is out there [ __ ] acting like an
[ __ ] and [ __ ] doing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and they get into a fight and they get
killed
that's the average just the average
person killed here is involved in the
drug trade
okay that's 85 of it
as long as you stay away from that
you're you're okay
yeah just be cool just be cool right
don't like draw attention to yourself
don't like be obnoxious
and most of the time it's going to be a
go like you know i've been in situations
where that didn't apply but
yeah most of the time
look at those all those shootings and
the [ __ ] homicide rates
ninety percent of that eighty percent of
that is drug trade if you're not in the
drug trade then that's not you
okay
there's random [ __ ] but that's like
getting struck by lightning
yeah which is it's not great it's not
yet but it's just yeah it's rare there's
like not anything you can do about it
either which just live your life yeah i
mean take precautions don't worry about
it and like i said just like watch your
back you're right
so
yeah so they target this dude who i'm
not really sure if they knew that this
dude was like kind of like local famous
or not
but they were kind of like hey this dude
seems vulnerable
so
we're gonna do this so they killed him
he did fight back
but because there were two of them they
were able to overpower him and they
actually ended up killing him
now they stripped his body and they
stole
his possessions as if they weren't
douchey enough
um
so they take the body the following day
to dr knox
now a bunch of dr knox's students
were kind of like hey
that's daft jamie because everybody in
town like knew who that was
this is the point
where i feel like dr knox went from oh i
don't know anything to oh i know some
[ __ ] but i'm just like gonna pretend i
don't
because what happened here
was that
a bunch of his students said hey that
staff jamie and probably he got murdered
like i don't think he died of like
natural causes
what dr knox did he didn't call the cops
he didn't go to the authorities nothing
like that he's like oh well what i'm
gonna do
i'm gonna cut off his head
and his
feet
so no one will recognize him and i'm
still gonna like utilize him for the
dissection classes
that is the point
where [ __ ] you knew what was going on
you knew who that was all your students
knew that was they told you who that was
and the fact that you were kind of like
oh i'm gonna cut his head off so nobody
recognizes him anymore and his clubfoot
because everybody knew about that i was
just kind of like yeah that was the
point where you like went past the point
of like oh plausible deniability you
knew about that [ __ ] and you just like
chose to ignore it because you were
getting bodies just gonna say okay i
know he's dead now i'm just saying that
was the point that it like went past it
for me
so yeah so he cut off his head and cut
off his feet so nobody would recognize
him and then he dissected him anyway
so
the last victim who was killed on
halloween night 1828 ooh what was that
okay some weird window came out
uh margaret dougherty now she was a
middle-aged irish woman
what ended up happening with her was
that william uh william burke
he kind of like lures her into the
boarding house it's like hey i'm from
ireland too i'm from the same
uh you know area of ireland as you and
we're gonna like come and drink together
blah blah blah my mom is also from the
same area as you are yada yada
so she comes in there
and they start drinking now at one point
burke leaves dougherty in the company of
his uh of the girlfriend helen mcdougall
now i'm gonna go get more whiskey he
says but he's actually going to get
william hare his partner
now at this point there are two other
lodgers this is a lodging house if you
remember there's an uh a couple other
lodgers who are a couple ann and james
gray
now they kind of came in and they were
drinking with the people and it's like
well so they saw
the murderers and the victim together
so at this point
what ended up happening
was that
uh the murderers were kind of like hey
we'll give you some money
if you guys will stay at william hare's
house for the night this is our relative
we want to have some alone time
why don't you [ __ ] off to like some
other place
and we'll give you money and they were
just kind of like
um
okay but no because we think something
weird is going on
so everybody keeps drinking
uh at this time
uh around nine o'clock in the evening
uh ann and james gray
they're kind of like they had gone out
for a little while but then they came
back
and they got some clothes for their kids
and they saw
uh broken hair and both of their wives
and dougherty their future victim and
they were all drunk they're all like
singing songs and like dancing and like
having a good time together seemingly
now broken hair did get into a fight
again like at some point during this
time
but
they were able to reconcile long enough
to kill
and dougherty uh they smothered her like
they did the others and they put her
body in a pile of straw
at the end of the bed like i believe it
was harrah's bedroom
now the next day the grays who like i
said were lodgers at this house they
came back
and they're kind of like what the [ __ ]
is going on in here you guys like this
is a weird like energy
and
uh burke is kind of like hey don't go
don't go by my bed what are you guys
doing
and at this point like anne was like hey
i just left my stockings over there what
the [ __ ] are you like [ __ ] aggro
about
so they wanted to go over there by the
bed so they got very suspicious that
broken hair were kind of like hey you
can't go over there
now
at whatever point because like i said
broken hair not the brightest
uh lights
on the christmas tree let's say that
so they were kind of like well we got to
go out for a little while so they left
grays
alone in the house
with the body that they had left there
not master criminals as i'm saying
so so
uh they get left alone in the house
so the grades are just kind of like okay
well we know some like sketchy shits
going on here so they start like looking
around in the room right as you would
and they start going through the hay and
they find
uh anne dougherty's body in the hay at
the edge of the of the bed
so it's still got blood on the face and
there's you know and they're just kind
of like okay we're gonna go call the
cops so they like run out the door and
they're gonna go tell the police about
it now while they're going out to tell
the police they run into helen mcdougall
helen mcdougall
doesn't really help her case
hey i'll give you guys 10 pounds a week
if you don't go to the police and tell
them anything
uh the graves are just kind of like [ __ ]
that you guys are murderers we're going
to the cops so they i mean good for them
good for them
they you know they could have taken a
lot of money but they did
they were like yeah we're telling you
[ __ ]
so the greys went right to the cops and
reported it
so
burke and hare because they knew the
cops were coming
they took the body and they're like oh
my god we gotta get this out of here so
they took it to dr knox where they
usually took the [ __ ]
at this point the cops come
now they didn't find the body obviously
but they found like a bunch of anne
dougherty's blood stained clothing
underneath the bed because like i said
these are not master criminals they're
like hey just take her bloody clothes
and like kick it under the [ __ ] bed
no one will find it the cops found it
so they questioned burke and his wife
and they said oh we don't know what
happened like and our she just left man
we don't we don't know what happened
um but they questioned each of them
separately
and both of them gave different times
for whatever time this woman allegedly
left so the cops were just kind of like
not buying it so yeah there was that let
me say something real quick what's that
they're they're kind of teasing me about
teasing me about oh tom's schooling us
again i just wanted to say that jenny
and i see the analytics of the show we
got people all over the world listening
to this show that have never been to the
united states only see it on television
a lot of stereotypes you're gonna pick
up over [ __ ] television and movies
all right
like the united states is a good place
it's it's good even you can go to even a
damn place that's kind of iffy and still
have a good time there because americans
in general are good even though they
they fight with each other like i said
most people are okay yeah most people
are okay i mean you got people in japan
scared to come here because they think
they get killed in a damn school
shooting and [ __ ] man that is like
getting struck by lightning there's so
many [ __ ] i mean that's shitty it
happens way more often than it should
[ __ ] huge this place is huge
all right
and
you know
it's all about statistics statistically
you don't have a problem
but you got to watch you got to watch
your back i mean you will probably be
okay i mean 99 of that you will probably
yeah most people 99 of people
are totally fine right are totally
friendly
but you got to watch your back because
you never know right but i feel like
that's true of anywhere yeah and you
can't be all stereotypical about [ __ ]
who's who they got a lot of good people
of all different kind of everybody's
different yeah they've got a lot of
different a lot of good people just like
anywhere of all different [ __ ] races
and ethnicities and [ __ ] you know what i
mean [ __ ] so you never know who
you're gonna well that's kind of like
one of the cool things about
the us is like you never know you don't
know what's gonna happen what that
person's person's backstory is
like it could be all kind of crazy it is
an adventurous place it it is kind of
like the wild west still but that's not
a bad thing that's a good thing the wild
west was good but the wild west wasn't
the wild west you saw on television it's
just different
it's different yeah anything's possible
and that's a good thing like i said
you'll probably be fine just watch your
back but like i said you got to watch
your back anywhere right
but you'll probably be fine right he'll
probably be fine
most people are fine most people around
the world are fine yeah
you know
yeah it's only a very small percentage
but you do got to watch out for that
percentage because you never know people
are human beings most people are fine
yeah people are human beings but most
most people
will would you they're just they mimic
what you do you're good to them they're
good to you
that that's it it's the golden rule and
to be honest like most people like
overwhelmingly most people are like
either friendly or they're indifferent
right which is fine
yeah if you come here as a foreigner
most of them will be indifferent to you
yeah because we got all kinds of
foreigners the only people you gotta
watch for are people that are like
actively malevolent which is a very
small percentage yeah but you never know
when you're gonna come across that so
you do have to like look out for it but
normally
statistically you're not going to run
into that yeah grudging says movies but
yeah it's movies that are doing that
and movies are fantasy
yeah it happens it happens well like i
said that happens about every country
but like i said just
it's fine most of the time it's fine but
don't be too trusting because you never
know
but yeah so
yeah so they find the body the grades go
to the police
and at this point they're like hey uh
they have some body here or they have
this body here
so the cops find the clothes
so
they go to
dr knox's place the cops do
and when they go there they find
uh you know they find the
clothing like at broken hare's place and
they're just kind of like okay well
we need to like [ __ ] you know uh
investigate this
they
ask birkin his wife
um
burke and his wife say oh yeah well she
was here but she left
and like i said they don't
they gave like different times for when
she left so obviously they know that
they're bullshitting
so
the cops like arrest them and bring them
in for
questioning the next morning the cops
find out about dr knox so they go to his
place
and they go to his dissecting rooms and
they find dougherty's body
now at this point um she gets identified
this is the woman that was last seen
alive with broken hair
uh so they arrested william hare and his
wife uh later that day and the guy that
owned their boarding house whose name
was james brogan they also arrested him
because they weren't really sure like
how much he knew about the [ __ ]
um all of them at the time of their
arrest said we don't know anything about
anything
so uh so okay
at this point
they got caught i mean you know we know
what they've been up to
as
many as 16 maybe more but
this is all they know of 16 people
murdered by broken hair
burke later said
that
um yeah we got ourselves like all
liquored up when we were doing the
murders
i don't know if they were trying to like
exonerate themselves or make themselves
seem more sympathetic but they were like
yeah we had to like suck ourselves up by
like getting drunk like before we did it
um and especially after he killed the
kid remember like the grandmother and
the kid situation
like after that happened he said yeah he
was haunted by that the rest i don't
know that's true or not but i don't know
if he was just trying to get sympathy or
whatever but he said yeah i couldn't
sleep at night i like had a drink all
the time like just to sleep and i would
have nightmares and blah blah
so he's like
took opium as well
because he said that like he couldn't
deal with it like that was like his big
thing like killing a child he didn't
really seem to give a [ __ ] about killing
adults uh old women young men
old
men young men like whoever whoever he
killed he didn't really seem to get that
much of a [ __ ]
but he said that he got upset about
killing that one kid
i don't know if that's true but maybe he
was just trying to get something want
another drink sure
but yeah so he said that that was the
case anyway
so at this point november
1828
so they issue a warrant for
uh burke's detention
uh
and harris detention and that of their
wives because they were seen as
accomplices
um james brogan who was the guy that
owned the um
you know the boarding house where
they're staying he they thought that he
maybe had knew something about it but
they didn't have enough evidence so they
released him
without charging him
so the four of them what they did at
least they knew this much um they kept
them all separate
and they took all their statements
separately because they wanted to see if
they would like incriminate each other
or like you know give contradictory
statements so they at least knew enough
to do that
um and they were probably right to do so
because all their stories kind of like
um contradicted one another
now
one of the surgeons the police surgeons
uh did an autopsy or whatever of
dougherty's body which at this point was
the only body that they had if you
remember because even though they've
killed like 16 people
this is really the first time that
they've ever been brought to the
attention of the authority and so the
authorities are just kind of like oh my
god this is like coming out of nowhere
thank you
so there's kind of like that like i said
they didn't have like [ __ ] csi back
then or nothing like that
so uh the police surgeon examines
socrates body and he says
uh he brings in two other like forensic
specialists or whatever they had the
equivalent in the day
and they're like okay well
it's possible that this victim could
have been suffocated but they don't
really have
any hardcore evidence to because
suffocation i mean even nowadays i think
it's kind of like hard to prove but
especially back then they didn't have
any forensic science or anything if you
just like basically put your hand over
someone's face and [ __ ] suffocated
them
unless you left bruises there was really
no way to
and they didn't so there was really no
way to
uh you know to pin that like on our word
they could have just died natural
clauses thank you gadget3 another five
spot because i've been away for a while
back though thank you very much thank
you very much that's nice we appreciate
you being back
so
yeah
so they come back uh yeah maybe it's
suffocation but we can't prove it
now because a bunch of a couple of
doctors had said that
uh the burks and hares uh both of them
like both couples
did get charged with murder
now they go into an investigation of dr
knox as well because you know his name
came up during the [ __ ]
and
knox's story was that hey i just thought
that some [ __ ] from like some poor
ass lodging houses like people were
dying in the stuff and they were like
selling me the bodies i had no idea what
was going on i find that hard to believe
but
just gonna say i mean
yeah there was a lot of that [ __ ] going
on where people were just like dying or
digging bodies up or just kind of like
maybe they were haunting places where
people were
dying in tenements or whatever
but
he had to [ __ ] know i mean burke and
hare were coming to him like basically
every week and be like hey we got like a
fresh one he's like ooh all right
i mean
more money thank you i know yeah i said
thank you
he had to know that something was going
on he had to yeah they're just in
they're in business i kind of feel like
he just he knew but he's like he didn't
want to know right i kind of feel like
he's like look i just need the [ __ ] and
i'm paying for the [ __ ] i'm not going to
question where it's coming from he had
bills to pay
that's yeah yeah i kind of feel like he
just
was like dude it's on you yeah me it's
yeah he was like maintaining plots
that's how you say it down here it's on
y'all yeah sorry i kind of feel like
that's what you're hiding
that's how he was coming at you yeah he
had to know though or he had at least
suspect these [ __ ] are probably
murdering people because why like these
corpses like super fresh
like some were like super warm yeah
um so okay so what happened
so the cops at this point
uh because this is the early 19th
century they don't have a lot of good
forensic evidence
um basically all you had to catch
somebody in the act or you had to get a
confession or something like that
they know
that these [ __ ] have murdered several
people but they don't have hard evidence
so like okay
we know at least one of you
[ __ ]
will
cave
so what we're gonna do they're tactic
because they didn't have a lot of hard
evidence as you wouldn't back in the day
we are going to
pinpoint the person that we think is the
most likely to like roll over on the
others and we're gonna like say to that
person hey we're gonna give you like
immunity if you roll over on the other
people
so that's what they did
um
basically because they just wanted a
conviction okay of anybody that was
involved in this [ __ ]
um they also thought that probably there
had been other murders going on but they
didn't really have like the evidence to
prosecute but they're like we just need
somebody to like pay for this [ __ ]
so
uh
what they did too and the thing about it
too was that the media wasn't super
helpful because obviously like even back
but people [ __ ] about the media
nowadays but back then
they didn't even like give a [ __ ] about
like if it was true or not they're just
like well what sells papers we're gonna
put like put the most [ __ ] lurid [ __ ]
we can put in there and they would put
that they didn't give a [ __ ] if it was
true or not they wouldn't get sued or
nothing there was no laws in place so
they made up all kind of [ __ ] crazy
ass stories so that was happening so
that there was another like uh pressure
there so uh you know when it got to a
point where every missing person ever
like in that area oh my god broken hair
must have like killed them which
i mean that was probably like a
reasonable thing to think but probably
not true i mean they didn't kill all
those people because i'm sure like a lot
of missing people but yeah
i mean 16 people is a lot so they went
to that
now uh so
what ended up happening
was that
so they bring them in
uh they found like they had some other
evidence too like for example janet
brown who was a prostitute and she was
uh mary patterson's friend like i said
they had gone there
janet brown like got the [ __ ] out of
there but mary patterson got killed and
she came back and she saw um mary
patterson's clothing which was all
bloody and which was like under the
beneath the bed and she's like yeah that
was her clothes
and then uh daft jamie
like his pants
had turned up on
william burke's nephew so it's like
they're killing people it's bad enough
they're killing people and they're like
giving their clothes away to like their
relatives and [ __ ] hey here are some
pants haven't it
how [ __ ] up is that yeah so his
relatives are like walking around like
wearing murdered people's pants so some
people had like seen that and said hey
those are daft jammies fans so yeah so
there was that too
now
uh at this point like i said the the
lord advocate or whatever they called it
um
he's gonna say okay i'm gonna focus on
the weakest individual out of these four
[ __ ] because i know you all did
something
um i'm gonna get a confession
and i'm gonna get
uh
so i can get as many of you [ __ ] can
convicted as possible
so because burke
was uh perceived to be the most
intelligent and probably like the
mastermind
so like we're gonna go after hair
because he seems like kind of a dummy
and we could probably get him to roll
over so that's what they did they went
after william hare
now
uh
they told him you will get complete and
utter immunity from prosecution
if you roll over
on all the other [ __ ] and say
exactly what happened
um not just the docherty murder like the
docherty murder or any other ones that
you want to like talk about that's fine
so
he said to do that
um now it should be noted too that
because
uh
his
because back then like you couldn't be
uh
you couldn't like um give testimony
against your spouse
so
giving him immunity would also give his
wife immunity
and they were kind of like okay well
we'll deal with that we just want burke
mostly because they felt like he was the
mastermind behind it so they wanted hair
to like give them all the [ __ ]
details so they said okay you'll be on
me and for prosecution and your
girlfriend wife slash whatever will also
be immune from prosecution
so hair said okay absolutely and he gave
a full confession very very detailed
confession
i saw a documentary about this earlier
that made a very good point
he's like had this not happened because
honestly
they didn't they probably the reason
they went this route that they needed
the confession
was probably because they didn't have
enough physical evidence obviously well
like i said this is back in the early
19th century physical evidence was yeah
it was a thing but they didn't really
have
the forensic uh resources that people
have nowadays
so
they were trying to get somebody to
confess
so the fact that they were pushing so
hard to get somebody to confess so they
could at least get one conviction
meant that they didn't have a super
strong case and if it had gone to trial
maybe all of them would have gotten off
and they didn't really want that to
happen
so they were like well we will we're
willing to let her and his wife
girlfriend whatever like go free so we
can get burke and his wife
that might have also ended up
indirectly exonerating knox because dr
knox
like i said probably knew what was going
on and probably should have been
prosecuted also but spoiler alert he got
away with the [ __ ] like he just totally
went free because he was just like i
don't know
i don't question where they got the
bodies and stuff like that even though
probably he should have probably been
up there i don't i don't say he should
have been hanged or nothing but he
probably should have been prosecuted too
but the fact that they didn't have
enough evidence and that they had to go
in this one dude's confession probably
got him off as well so i'm just saying
i'm laughing at danny he'll say some
[ __ ] in the comment section then delete
his own posts
danny if you don't if you're gonna [ __ ]
if you're gonna say something leave it
there man
kind of feel like that maybe happens
automatically maybe
we're not doing it danny maybe he well
yeah i i can't even do it everybody in
this area somebody's taking your [ __ ]
away
i think he does it so he's doing yeah or
he has a thing where it's like he'll
post some [ __ ] and then like 10 seconds
later well even yeah well no because it
happens like he'll post like some
innocuous like nothing yeah and then
like five or ten seconds
yeah what are you doing danny what the
[ __ ] bro
maybe he has a thing where he's just
kind of like i'm just out of
consciousness she gets self-conscious of
speaking in public self-conscious
lord knows we've gotten yes that at this
point yeah
so yeah so they got him so hair like
basically rolled over on all of them uh
he turned king's evidence they promised
him like complete and total immunity
like if he would confess to all the [ __ ]
uh and again like his wife slash
girlfriend would also get immunity
because he wasn't allowed to testify
against her so
that was probably like worth it timmy's
like yeah okay totally whatever so he
did that
now uh so at this point because he
ratted
uh december 4th they laid formal charges
against uh william burke and helen
mcdougall uh you know for the murders of
it was uh three murders it was mary
patterson uh daft jamie and mrs
dougherty because mr doggerty was the
only one they had the body for
uh the other bodies had obviously been
um you know
anatomized they'd obviously have been
you know dissected uh so you know i
don't know what they did with them after
but they didn't really have them
now as i said dr knox
didn't face any charges
because burke's statement to the police
said oh he didn't know what was going on
i found that very hard to believe
i kind of feel like he probably knew but
i kind of feel he just didn't want to
know he didn't want to know
he just wanted bodies and he's just like
yep
don't tell me i kind of feel like that's
what was going on
but what happened though was when the
papers
got the details about the [ __ ] um and
they started printing it newspapers and
stuff and obviously back then they
didn't really have any laws about you
can't print this that need because it's
not true they were just kind of like
whatever we'll just like make up what it
said they would just kind of like make
up this sensational ass [ __ ]
and they would make up [ __ ] that wasn't
true and so obviously like everybody got
like really really
um
incensed about
dr knox's um
involvement in this situation
and uh some people thought that he was
maybe the mastermind behind the [ __ ]
because
he was the one that was like
oh go out and get me more bodies i don't
think i wouldn't go that far
um
he was a doctor he just wanted bodies to
dissect he needed a supply
and he wasn't really worried about where
the supply was coming from i don't know
if he necessarily said hey go out and
kill people i don't think he ever said
that but i think that
he was getting supplies so he wasn't
really questioning where he was coming
from that's all i i think that he was
just kind of like he knew what was going
on but he just didn't question it
you know which is its own kind of like
shitty behavior but i don't think he was
actually telling people hey
go out and kill people so i can get more
bodies i don't think he ever said that
now um the public though had a different
opinion uh most of them thought that he
should have been
right up there in the docket along with
the murderers
and they were a little pissed off that
he wasn't
um i should note too that this whole
situation
coined another it's not uh in common
usage in american english but in english
english uh there's a term called burking
and and that means
uh smothering [ __ ] to sell their
bodies really for money damn that's like
being casper
yeah yeah it's called burking yeah okay
and because of william burke but well
because i mean william here was involved
too but herring doesn't really sound as
cool as burking does to be caspered
is about casper the friendly ghost
that's when somebody [ __ ] kills you
in your sleep
it's called
yeah casper
think about that for a while that came
out of the american prison system casper
was friendly though casper the friendly
ghost well yeah you didn't know
it was friendly
you're asleep dreaming
that's the best way to go casper this
friendly ghost comes up and [ __ ]
[ __ ] kills you in your sleep
man
when i die i'd rather go that way i
don't know i don't really want to know
man if somebody's gonna murder me or
something like that don't wake me up or
nothing that [ __ ] just [ __ ]
just let me like go on to the afterlife
whenever that's i don't believe in an
afterlife but you know
i do i know you do yeah i don't but i'm
just saying this you haven't seen it yet
no near-death experiences you'll see
i will see i [ __ ] was listening to a
scientist the other day i'm [ __ ] rex
friedman and and the dude was a he was
he he was [ __ ] a big wig man hanging
out with [ __ ]
um uh the dudes from uh from from [ __ ]
man i'm [ __ ] drunk i'm trying to
remember that yeah you are can i finish
come on go ahead go ahead anyway no he
he's agreeing with me that yeah
consciousness is something that we can't
really
define and uh yeah it looks like well i
agree with that it looks like there
might be some
what we would call super metaphysical or
supernatural but the thing about it is
because we'll see that's the reason that
i'm skeptical is because look we don't
even understand our own brain yeah yeah
so it's like i think it's like a morning
leap
to extrapolate from us like hey we don't
understand like even how our own brains
work which is like an organic thing to
extrapolating to like some [ __ ]
metaphysical [ __ ] i think that's like a
way bigger leap than you need to take
i'm the other i'm okay good i mean
no i'm just saying i don't know i'm not
i don't know but i'm just saying until
we understand what the [ __ ] is going on
here which we don't
um
then we can't really they cannot explain
koala
not yet and
not yet why red feels the way that it
does and why certain things but like i'm
saying because we don't understand the
way the brain works we don't
it's not the brain it's the same i'm
just saying
until we understand entirely how the
brain works
you can't jump ahead and say oh it must
be supernatural paranormal we don't know
though we don't know that yet because we
don't want to say supernatural because
then that brings in all kinds of weird
[ __ ] it's just that it's a certain
element of physics that's beyond our
ability to sure i'm willing yeah i'm
willing to go that far
but i'm just saying that
that's the reason we don't understand
right we don't understand what can like
our brains do all kind of like weird
[ __ ] that we don't understand yet
physics does all kind of weird [ __ ]
i know y'all so we can't like jump
forward and say oh it's this that and
the other because we don't know yet in
the star trek show
that is 13 o'clock
you got spock and you got kirk
and ask kirk i'm gonna tell you that
yeah there's a afterlife
and [ __ ] even jenny around me has
seen some weird [ __ ] she's not gonna be
able to
to explain
because there's more to reality than we
know what the problem is is our sensory
apparatus it is not good enough
to actually tell us what reality is we
don't know what reality is
vision and
senses and smell it's just not enough
the way really reality really is is
beyond our
current abilities so we're not seeing
reality as it is
there's more to it
that's all i'm saying well yeah like
like i said everybody knows i'm willing
to go that far because like a shrimp
does not know reality it does not have a
sensory apparatus to understand reality
well well and we only evolved to a
certain to a particular point um you
know we don't and honestly it's only
because of our
brains and our intelligence that we've
actually been able to figure out what
we've been able to figure out
uh thus far and i kind of feel like it's
not
i mean we need to go farther with that
yeah i mean i'm impressed that we've
figured out what we've figured out at
this point but it's still like not just
based on the little weird [ __ ] that's
happened to me you can read it in
jenny's book
[ __ ] um mountain poltergeist
i believe in
an afterlife reincarnation possibly
things like higher dimensions
and
things like paranormal abilities
but those are very generic
terms
uh
weird [ __ ] is possible
i've seen it okay that's it go back to
which doma finish the show
okay yeah i'm [ __ ] so i'm i'm getting
hungry too yeah me too you can help me
oh make some deep i mean i'm almost at
that okay so like i said
uh this whole situation coined a new
english word burking like i said that's
basically not necessarily smothering but
usually smothering smothering somebody
to sell their body to science that's
what that word means
so they start this trial
christmas eve 1828. now you have to
think like back in scotland in the early
19th century christmas wasn't really
like a big holiday yeah um that's a
that's a modern invention yeah i know
like some christians will be like
horrified by that but by christmas yeah
well by christmas being not yeah i kind
of feel like oh back to the days of
jesus it's like no no no christmas is
new it's it's very new it's very new a
lot of christians didn't like the idea
of christmas they thought it was eddie
christian or pagan yeah it was fake well
because a lot of the [ __ ] is bacon it's
all just it doesn't matter though it's
just what my people yeah celebrate what
you want it's all good it's all good
yeah do what you want to do yeah no
one's judging no one's watching it's
fine
so yeah so christmas eve asia like i
said christmas eve they were still doing
like courts like it wasn't a holiday no
one was all that concerned
so they bring him in uh william burke
and helen mcdougall
are both charged uh with one murder uh
marjorie dougherty okay hold on let me
say something
sly is asking how he sends a super chat
um there is
where you enter
text
in youtube
or to the right there will be a little
square
symbol that has like a dollar sign in it
if you don't have that
you have to go into youtube and give
them your bank account information
and then you activate certain things
you'll see and then you can send a super
chat
but if you're not set up with that
because that takes time
you can just send jenny something on on
um paypal
later on tonight or you can send us
something on paypal
what's the easiest way to find your
paypal
i mean paypal is just like my
email address yeah which is
heck 80 at a hotmail.com
another way you can do is send her a
just a message on facebook or on
instagram one of our connections
somewhere
and tell her that you want to
send something and she'll she'll send
you the yeah and i can send you the link
just send the address
like if you're really into yeah and then
you can send what you wanted yeah
so yeah so they bring these
[ __ ]
to court so they get charged with one
murder
margarita now
william burke also got charged with mary
patterson's murder and daft jamie's
murder right so two other ones
now
the thing about it like here's one thing
that i love about scotland
you know how
i mean in the british and the american
legal system you have like kind of like
guilty not guilty scotland has a very
particular
thing
where it's kind of like their
verdict is not proven
i kind of love that i kind of feel like
most people like more countries should
do that
it's like look we probably we know you
did it but they didn't like prove it
and so yeah so they have a thing where
it's like not proven
so that's uh ended up
was what happened with um
helen mcdougall
is she ended up getting
a not proven verdict so she got set free
burke though uh got sentenced to death
by hanging
now
the judge listen to this [ __ ]
so the judge
when he was sentencing william burke to
death because hale got to go free
because he flipped right
so burke took all the [ __ ] heat for
this [ __ ]
the judge says to him and this is a
quote
i mean this is
i'm not gonna lie this is like some
pretty cool like poetic justin's justice
the judge says
your body
should be publicly dissected and
anatomized
and i trust that it is ever customary to
preserve skeletons
yours will be preserved in order that
posterity may keep in remembrance
of your atrocious crimes so it's like
thank you thank you thank you so he
figured it out you figured it out yeah
so i found it figured out the super chat
button okay yeah that's good
but yeah so i love that the judge was
just kind of like [ __ ] look what you
did to like all these innocent ass
people we're gonna do the same [ __ ] to
you you die i kind of love it it's kind
of like poetic yeah
so yeah
so
hale got away like i said but burke got
hanged
uh 28th of january 1829 20th of january
that's my brother's birthday but yeah so
he got hanged
uh
and
because it was such a famous case at
least 25 000 people
came out to see his hanging i've seen
like pictures of the [ __ ]
25 000 it was a lot damn there was
people everywhere and people like rent
out like rooms so they could like watch
out the windows damn you know what i'm
saying it's a huge [ __ ] mass of
people it was yeah it was a big crowd he
became a [ __ ] celebrity it was so
nice
this is like a big [ __ ] deal
so yeah so everybody came out to see him
get hanged
and then
uh his corpse got publicly dissected by
uh not dr knox but um another guy who
was like a big anatomist at the time his
name was dr monroe who was like the same
guy one of the same guys like at the
same uh college and they dissected him
in front of like a whole bunch of people
now what happened though was that
because a bunch of students came because
everybody wanted to see him get
dissected because it was like he was
famous
and they had a riot because everybody
couldn't get in because the tickets were
limited
so they had a riot and they were just
kind of like well okay well we'll let
you [ __ ] come in like afterward like
after he's dissected like you can come
in after and like look at it so they
don't like calm everybody down so there
was that kind of [ __ ] i mean
can you imagine this kind of like [ __ ]
happening nowadays like yeah i mean yeah
but
i don't know people haven't changed that
much not really they will just show up
to gawk
i mean i kind of feel like nowadays
people at least have the decency to be
like maybe we shouldn't do it sly sent
us another one man they send a big one
really yeah 99 thank you very much now
somehow sly you can only send the super
sticker and then somehow put text in it
too
and if you put text in it
it could be a question or it could be
a comment whatever
if it's a question we will uh we'll
respond directly to it
but yeah now you figured out super chat
good deal hooray thank you very much
thank you very much you got the fox
[ __ ] do you miss that yeah
i know i like the little animated yeah
yeah so there's a riot because
everybody's kind of like well we wanted
to see the body yeah i wanted to see the
body everyone's like dude
so there's that
so they let them come through in batches
of like 50 people the light comes in
through the body
during the procedure like while he's
doing the autopsy that everyone was
looking at yeah somebody it was either
monroe or somebody else i don't really
know i've seen the picture yeah but
somebody comes through
monroe
dips a quill pen
into burke's blood what
and writes
this is a quote this is written with the
blood of william burke who was hanged to
edinburgh this blood was taken from his
head so they're [ __ ] stunned they're
[ __ ] stunned on his [ __ ] i've seen
the [ __ ] cook yeah
okay
people back there were like messed up
well they knew how to they do show
business
they're trying to [ __ ] oh they're
they're all trying to make money [ __ ]
was the biggest big event
taken from his head
how old was that [ __ ] he was probably
[ __ ] 25 years old who wrote that
oh i don't know i bet you he was you
know
people [ __ ] forget how young these
people were yeah they do like [ __ ]
children yeah they were they were like
joking i mean i don't know i'm not yeah
i don't know how old the girl is well
even if they were older they were still
like children because they were very low
information
you know and this it was just a
different time yeah we're just gonna
like
take some ink from like some dead person
like who the [ __ ] would do that
if you did that nowadays it would be
like bro yeah i would have done that
back in those days though well back in
the world back in those days yeah back
in those days i'm like yeah yeah but
like i said if you did that now it'd be
like yeah it'd be uncouth
but you know this is another time
well hey man all cultures are like this
me and [ __ ] conovodsan talking all
the time you know he's he lives in
mexico and we we talk about [ __ ] the
mesoamericans and and um
the aztec all the time
and uh trade videos and so he'll come up
with some really good videos of [ __ ]
stuff about the aztecs
and uh it's just people were [ __ ]
crazy people were wild they would do
some wild [ __ ] back then but they're
only working on the information that
they had which was not much not much and
they're and they're working from the
framework of the culture of the time the
religious framework of the time again
yeah
and as as a cook i [ __ ] he'll send me
[ __ ] like really good
links to mexican cooks like cooking con
claudia on [ __ ] youtube she's like a
cute little mexican girl who'll teach
you how to [ __ ] cook is she the one
that made that like fantastic [ __ ] that
i cook it for you yes the pork yes
yes carnitas that's her name yeah if you
guys want to learn how to cook real
mexican food
go on youtube delicious and look up
cooking concluding
and she's this cute little mexican girl
she'll tell you how to [ __ ] cook what
they cook in mexico it's so much better
but
you had to understand something about
mexican cooking
in the olden days all these [ __ ]
fantastic [ __ ] mexican recipes were
done only for the mexican royalty or
aristocracy
up in [ __ ] you know
mexico city
during the time of [ __ ] cortez and
[ __ ] and it was human meat it was all
cat they were cannibals you know
and i'd be like carnitas came from
people you know they re hey
soylent greetings
[Laughter]
carnitas is made for people
yeah yeah yeah but hey if it's delicious
i'll eat it out again it was uh
religiously sanctified religious
cannibalism you know and
uh well you know
they're kind of into that they're eating
jesus flesh yeah exactly and you're
talking about a people that were like
very close
on par with the vikings
okay these were not weak dudes these
[ __ ] were [ __ ] conquerors
yeah and uh
badasses you know
then you gotta love it it was just from
the it was it was a culture of its day
and they still honor it to the to this
day i i'm totally and being
growing up partially in brazil i could
go to mexico i'd [ __ ] have a great
time there [ __ ] i want to go to
mexico city
you know
uh
hang out they got a great goth scene in
mexico
[ __ ] and have a good time there
jake says his carnitas is people i'm a
cannibal then yeah i can like carnitas
yeah carney just was people there's a
lot of [ __ ] that they used to cook
i gotta say though like when i like
that channel on youtube it's like that
is the best carnitas you've ever made
yeah it's good because it's gotta be i
mean all the carnation weight is good
but that's what's better because
less is more the [ __ ] spice profile
is a lot more mild uh good yeah claudius
carnitas is really are really good
um but you know
khan kanavasalan made me an honorary
mexican because i make my own [ __ ]
tortillas i think this [ __ ] had a
[ __ ] camera tortilla
yes i mean but it makes
i love mexican food mexican food indian
food yeah made my own salsa that i grew
the tomatoes and the peppers and all
that [ __ ] out in the backyard yeah all
the [ __ ] came in came out for this salsa
casita very good
real good and it was claudia's recipe
yeah roasted all of it the garlic the
peppers the tomatoes i didn't have
tomatillos but you don't really need
tomatoes you can use just tomatoes
if i could yeah i got some green
tomatoes
those are in there too but
and you cook it and
yeah
made salsa casiero
yeah it comes out
yeah good shape
all right so can i finish this finish it
up [ __ ] finish it up babe tell him
[ __ ] i called you babe
oh okay sound like that but no i fish it
up babe all right
so
yeah you should get them sensitive
it sounds like don't get sensitive well
you've done it it's not like you haven't
called me [ __ ] before that's just
[ __ ] in good nature though okay yeah
sure
okay so
i mean i'm not gonna lie
it is kind of like satisfying
that this is a [ __ ] they killed
so many people
and sold their bodies to science
uh the judge was kind of like yeah
turnabout's fair play [ __ ] uh
you are also going to be
uh cut up and anatomized and dissected
in front of everybody so i kind of
i kind of love that i kind of love that
so they did that
um you know everybody came to look at it
like i said people wrote letters with
the dude's blood and everything like
that
william burke skeleton also
uh got
donated to the anatomical museum of
edinburgh medical school and it's still
there as far as i know uh as far as i
know this year it's still there
um if you go to the surgeon's hall
museum it's still there they also have a
death mask of his
and they also have a notebook that was
made out of his tanned skin
because
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about that i don't feel too bad about
that because like i said
i don't care too bad what what happened
to this [ __ ] but yeah
so that happened to burke
now helen mcdougall though
she got released
uh at the end of the trial now she goes
home
but
um
obviously
everybody knew who she was
they knew what she was involved with so
it's not like she's gonna be able to
have a normal life
the next day
she actually goes to the liquor store or
whatever she's like hey i gotta go buy
some booze
and a whole bunch of like local people
were like uh yeah no that's not gonna
happen
um you got off with this you knew what
was going on
so they like attacked her like a big mob
she had to be taken into police custody
uh for her own protection
and the mob that was after her actually
like
attacked the police station
so she actually had to crawl out through
a back window
to another police station
and then at that point they were kind of
like well
you gotta get out of town we we don't
know what to do with you
so she kind of like left edinburgh after
that and nobody really knows what
happened to her subsequently
now william hare as i said because he
turned
uh as we would say in this country
states evidence but uh as they would say
over there king's evidence so uh he
rolled over on his partner
and he got released
now
because he was released uh nobody was
like super happy about that either
now they tried to like get him out of
town
uh safely they put him in a disguise
and tried to get him out of
edinburgh
now
they put him on a train but at one of
the stops that he had to stop at he got
recognized by somebody even though he
was in disguise
and a big like mob formed
and they're kind of like well we're
gonna like beat this bitch's ass
so
uh yeah so they're all kind of like
gathering around police had to come
and they had to like arrange like we you
know there's a decoy we have to like
send him off on a different thing so he
doesn't get like his ass beat and all
this other kind of stuff
so they actually had to take him to the
prison for like to keep him safe for a
little while
crowd surrounded that it was a whole
thing
so i don't know should they have just
probably let him like let the crowd beat
him to death i don't know
maybe
maybe
i'm not saying yes or no i'm just saying
um but after that
he like kind of like took off after all
this like protection that he went
through
um
basically the cops were just kind of
like they took him to the english border
they're like just go get the [ __ ] out of
here we don't care where you go
we don't want to take care of you
anymore we're like sick of looking after
you so he took off
and after that point um they really
don't know what happened to him uh he
probably if i was him i would have
changed my name um i'm sure that he
probably changed his name
now
like i said dr knox there's still
to this day
controversy over how much did dr knox
know like should he have been
uh prosecuted along with the others
um oh pookie
where'd she come from you're right
sweetie
oh
you guys we didn't tell you beijing had
to go to the fat today yeah she's very
sick
she's getting old i mean they gave me
some treatment for the her liver and her
kidneys she's throwing up
she's just getting old i know but she
lost three pounds since the last time
she was there oh
it should be okay though
i hope so being only there for so long i
know but just give her
she's an old cat now
how old is how old is beijing oh [ __ ]
got her in uh 2000
when were the beijing
2008 no i got it yeah 2 000. well before
i met you because yeah yeah
yeah we had her before and she was just
born she was only a few months old she
was a baby although when i met you she
was like not fully grown but she was
like not a kitten yeah
just you know they don't live that long
and she's getting old she's had a good
life though
i know she's still in pretty good shape
but she's throwing up
we'll see she's always had like well i
will say she's always had like a
sensitive stomach
yeah she barfs a lot yeah pookie doesn't
right but
i mean well it might be because she's
like a long-haired cat too it's it's
damn near impossible that a cat lives 20
years
okay sometimes they do it's very rare
yeah but you know we'll see
i mean i don't really like to yeah
taking care of her whole life should be
okay how old is beige
14.
2008 would be what
um i can't math
20 21 minus 2008
15 15 years so she's only got a few
years left in her
well i hope she lives all of the time
that no she'll just be here
she'll be sick and yeah we'll have to
put her down and it's just the way it is
put down so many horses you know over
the years and
it's best not to let them suffer you
know it's just they get sick and you're
going like oh there's gonna be a lot of
problems with the cat and uh
time for you go to sleep baby you know
it's just how it is i know but yeah you
know you want to keep them like alive
and
oh she's had a good life she has she's
had a good life she's you know
she you know she's got it made for a cat
it sucks because i like i kind of think
about that with pookie but like pookie's
only like she'll be five this summer so
she's still a baby she's still a baby
yeah but by the time that happens to
pookie she she won't be she'll be tired
you know time to go
i mean hopefully i'll be [ __ ] old but
that's a whole that's a whole lifespan
for them so
you know
i don't know they're not humans they
don't live that long i know i don't like
to think about it yeah well i mean you
know
i know it happens
don't think about it don't focus on it i
try not to
yeah
but you know i have nightmares about it
sometimes
about little pokey
but yeah so
so a lot of these [ __ ] other
than burke i mean burka hanged and
dissected and his skin made into books
and [ __ ] like that
uh and his skeleton being given to
medical thing but nobody else really got
punished for it in a way that maybe that
was satisfactory
for people
so the thing about dr knox like i said
there's a lot of controversy over
whether dr knox um should have been
prosecuted along with like i kind of
feel like the public opinion
was uh
with like dr knox probably should have
been prosecuted
because he probably knew what was going
on
he
never admitted to knowing anything about
where the bodies were coming from and he
always like maintained plausible
deniability
but he's always like well i just kind of
figured these dudes just like hung out
in these [ __ ] tenements and people
were dying all the time
and they were just bringing them into
the bodies so i didn't like think about
it you know what i mean so
but
i don't buy that
um the reason i don't buy that is
because of the whole
[ __ ] with daft jamie when dap jamie
turned up on his autopsy table
and his students were like hey that's
staff jamie he was just kind of like no
it's not and then he cut the head and
the feet off which were the most
recognizable aspects
adapt he's like what what are you
talking about all right i don't know who
that is so
the fact that he did that
um
if that hadn't happened i'd be willing
to give him the benefit of doubt but
since that happened yeah he knew no of
course he knew of course he knew
uh but he got away with it he got away
with it
burke was really the only one that
hanged for it
uh and he got like like i said his skin
got made into a notebook
his skeleton is still under actually if
you're in edinburgh if you're in the uh
museum nowadays you can still see a
skeleton there it is it's still there
so and the rest of them they don't
really know what happened like i said
there was some kind of like um
you know when they tried to like
go out and about in edinburgh like mobs
were like oh no and they try to like
[ __ ] kill them and stuff so they
probably like changed their names and
went elsewhere so they don't know what
happened to them uh after that
now one good thing that did come out uh
as a result of all this
[ __ ]
uh was that because there weren't enough
cadavers for scientific research
um this had been a problem that had been
addressed earlier than i mean early even
earlier than these murders had happened
by like jeremy bentham and stuff like
that
um
they had kind of like
thrown around a law back then they were
just kind of like hey maybe we should
make more bodies like available to
you for research and stuff but it didn't
pass
but after the murders happened
they kind of like pushed through some of
the like okay we absolutely need to like
[ __ ] pass some [ __ ] now
there was also another murder that
happened
sorry
damn there's also another murder that
happened
in uh east london
and this was a 14 year old kid
uh who was killed and then subsequently
sold on to
an anatomist at king's college london
and this is called like the london
berkers murder or whatever
so the fact that that happened and then
like the broken hair stuff
so they're like okay well obviously
people are going from like grave robbing
which wasn't like a big deal to now like
murdering people because hey they're
cutting out the middleman
uh so we need to do something about that
so
they basically
they hanged two guys in december of 1831
for
uh you know doing the murdering people
to get corpses
and so they're kind of like okay well we
need to like pass a law to like do
something about this
so
in
uh 1832 they passed the anatomy act
in parliament
and that was essentially opening up
more avenues for them to like the
government would essentially like set
aside x amount of
cadavers for
medical schools so they would kind of
like nip in the bud like look nobody
needs to like [ __ ]
rob graves or like murder people or
whatever to like get money so they
essentially like nip that in the bud
so that's kind of what they like ran
that through and it was very effective
in
i mean i kind of feel like the grave
robbing uh
you know the the trade in grave robbing
after that was like they nobody really
did it anymore because it wasn't like
really worth it so it was successful in
whatever it was trying to do
so yeah so it did have a silver lining
at least like broken hair they killed 16
innocent people which sucked
but at least it had
a positive outcome uh in the sense that
the government finally like paid
attention and they were just kind of
like okay well we need to pass a law to
like make
x amount of cadavers available so that
you know we don't have this illegal
trade in them happening so we don't have
incentives we will like kill people
so uh the event yeah well you know
yeah we got to make medical cadavers
[ __ ] i mean
start killing people desperate people
yeah i mean
burke and hare were kind of like the
first people that did that most people
just like dug graves up but broken hair
were just kind of like man we're gonna
make some bodies digging up graves seems
like a lot of work yeah so yeah it's
much easier just to like smother people
and the bodies are fresher
i mean
yeah it's honestly like surprising that
more people didn't come to that
conclusion yeah which like i said that
gives me hope and humanity that like
even back then
there was only two [ __ ] that
came up it would make sense that that
would happen yeah yeah well that's why
and and i kind of feel like at they at
least acknowledge they're like yeah
it was just like an outcome of all of
these like various factors and there's
like yeah we don't want that to happen
again
yes we understood that it's not right
but we understood where that came from
so let's not go there right so we're
gonna give you guys all the cadavers you
need
from legitimate legal sources so nobody
will have to resort to that kind of like
uh [ __ ] yeah as they did back then so
yeah so how long have been how long
we've been uh
streaming almost five hours five what
the [ __ ] this is a long ass show okay
we're gonna shut it down i'll i'll give
it something okay let's make it
something okay
all right five hours that's ridiculous
that's the longest one in a [ __ ] long
time well hey that's what happened i
yeah okay i wonder why that could happen
i don't know
but yeah so hopefully you guys enjoyed
the show i'm just i hopefully we stayed
on the topic enough to make it like
worthwhile
um you know but it was fun for us so we
will be back
what's it's wednesday right yeah we'll
be back friday night for the sidetrack
show
uh which is not that much different from
this show but we're not gonna even
pretend to like talk about it actual
topic
so we're gonna like go and like talk
about whatever
you know yeah yeah
so we're gonna go eat
you guys go eat
and
we will see you guys on friday evening
thank you all for dropping by thank you
for super chats we love you guys
we'll be back friday and we'll see you
then bye